the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
tactics graced the boards at the
sinkfield cup in St Louis chess is a
game a sport and an art with these
Masters showcasing the beauty of the
game of Kings Maxine Bashir lagrav hope
to create a masterpiece against Hans
Neiman but the younger player was able
to draw the game alireza farrugia
pressed against linear Dominguez but
couldn't find the win leaving Wesley so
in clear lead the Geniuses of the game
are in Peak form what Novelties will
they bring today round eight of
inspiring chess coming up next
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
cup the last stop of the grand Chester
it's been a fantastic tournament so far
as we are getting ready for the final
stage of the event who is going to
dominate in the championship rounds
let's go to the studio and find out with
Yasser Peter and alejana
from the home of Chess in America
welcome to the singfield cup the
centerpiece of the Saint Louis chess
Summer and the final stop on the 2022
Grand chest tour
hello and welcome back I'm Peter swidler
and with me is yes serovan glowing as
usual well thank you Peter uh good to be
with you hello everyone and thank you
for joining our show we are in
Championship weekend the penultimate
round coming up we will Crown a winner
of the Saint Cloud cup as well as the
grand chest tour champion who will win
there are a lot of players in the mix
Peter do the honors and tell us our
current standings let's take a look uh
and uh as we're all probably used by
usually by now we uh we have this uh
slightly weird uh cross table on your
screen with a very varying numbers of
games well played but one thing is
unchanged however however you counted
West is so is leading the tournament on
four out of six uh with Yanni ponishi
and Ariza ferozan three and a half out
of six tied for second they are ahead of
Fabiano caruana who is on the same
amount of points but with one more game
played right and
uh then we have a number of people on 50
and mvl and Shakira manjarov are not
really having such a great time no and
Peter our format uh the format of this
is around Robin now with nine players
with uh an hour and a half for the first
40 moves and then 30 minutes for the
rest of the game with a 30 second
Implement starting from the very
beginning drawers are not allowed for
our players here and one point where we
don't have a point for a draw the usual
scoring system is being used for
classical events in the garage door the
schedule is getting easier and easier to
be here yeah and the font is getting
larger and larger so it's easier to read
it's very good uh we have only two
rounds left uh today and tomorrow we
will play rounds eight and nine there
are potential playoffs for both the
grandchild store and for the single cup
the single Cup playoffs if they happen
they will happen immediately after the
end of round nine okay and the GCT
playoffs if they will be required they
will happen separately on Monday the
12th and then there's a rest day sorry a
closing ceremony no residence for
anybody anymore uh closing ceremony
immediately after the potential GST
playoffs and there we see players
getting wanted but Rejoice everyone
because yes he's with us Alejandro
Ramirez in studio good good afternoon
Alejandra good to have you with us good
afternoon Peter good afternoon yes sir
what a pleasure to be here calling the
action in the last two days not only of
the singfield cup but of the entire
Grand Chester and you said it yourself
there's a bunch of people in the mix
trying to get that first place but we
have clear favorites at least in my
opinion Wesley Seoul is currently the
leader of the tournament here at the
singfield cup and that puts it
mathematically as the leader so far in
the grand Chester but there is one
youngster that is incredibly hungry he's
trying to win every game that he plays
and they have a match up or for the ages
this could be a hundred thousand dollar
chess game between alireza firusha with
the white pieces against Wesley so with
black they have only played twice in
classical chess and Wesley actually got
the better of him in one of the games
the other one and end it in a draw and
guys I cannot overestimate how important
this is with a victory by alireza he not
only overtakes Wesley sawing the
standings of the singfield he would also
overtake him in the standings of the
grand Chester he might be winning both
tournaments in a row but he still has to
this portal to face because he faces
Wesley today with white he'll finish his
tournament with the black pieces against
mvl tomorrow meanwhile meanwhile Wesley
himself we know he's playing Perugia
today and tomorrow he will have a chance
to bounce back as he has the white
pieces against Lanier Dominguez
everything to be played for but this
round is absolutely crucial we have a
marquee matchup no doubt about it plenty
of trusts to be played plenty of money
at stake but let's hear about the buzz
surrounding the chess club as we have
with a social media specialist woman
Grandmaster Anastasia karlovich thank
you Alejandro let me remind our viewers
what was happening last days we have
this big drama since cup drama which
started with Magnus Carlson's withdrawal
from the tournament after before the
round four and then we had lots of
comments I mean it was really a big
story in all news and all social media
and I can say also that it was a Talk of
the Town of Saint Louis because all
these news were shown on TV and local
people are talking about it I've heard
from our from the guys from our
production team that many people
approached them and they asked them
what's going on people who never spoke
and never heard anything about cheers
before so I mean for sure that we can
see also on the screen uh the Tweet
sorry the screenshot Tony Rich is given
an interview to the local media
explaining actually what happened during
the first round and after that we also
know that Hans Seaman also came
yesterday for the interview and he spoke
about the mental pressure which he has
known his shoulders and he definitely
wants this tournament to be over so so
no later anisigiri also gave us some
reasons let's say how the drama can
continue so far actually I think slowed
down in the last days we didn't have any
statements also you can see that Magnus
doesn't play with hands so the only
thing we have is a tweet from Anish at
the moment so I think it's a really good
moment to forget about this drum a
little bit and concentrate on the last
two rounds because we're really looking
forward to see how the grandchester and
the events in Falcao will finish back to
you yes sir and Peter thank you
Anastasia nice keeping is up to date on
all of the stuff sorry Peter no spaces
after brackets I don't know I can if I
can continue this broadcast
spaces after brackets
to the honors Peter lay the table for
our viewers and tell them what they can
expect for this penultimate round eight
absolutely the bearings for for this
round as Alejandro has already spoken
about at length there's clearly the most
important game of the potentially the
entire event there with others are
playing against Wesley but we also have
linear Dominguez on the white side
against uh shahram
and importantly the game between Hans
Neiman and Fabiano caruana will be
fabi's last game of the tournament
yeah he is one of the two people who are
on seven games out of seven so far the
other one being maximoshiligrav who is
resting yeah who's resting today and
Fabi gets it by tomorrow so for Fabi
This is the End he's on 50 and playing
Black against Hans he would of course
like to end the tournament on a blast
score I don't think by this point has
any way of getting into the top three in
the grand chess tour right the final
standings but it would be a very nice
way for him to kind of finish a
tournament on the tournament on the high
here we are at the playing Hall as the
players wait they're turned he's very
thoroughly wandered Ali razor there
getting ready for this big gig for me
Peter I sorry to say it I'm a fanboy of
um Fabi but
kind of just a quiet tournament it is a
video make a mark it is a very I mean he
had his chances he uh he was I think
completely winning against Kenya
Dominguez and maybe there was one more
game where he it felt like he missed an
opportunity but yeah definitely you have
to say and you know I've been watching
this with a sort of uh increasing
sadness because I'm a huge fan of Fabio
and he's playing well ever since that
last that second half of the kind of the
cinnamon trade he's not really been
himself and uh I think uh I personally
would very much like to see him uh back
to playing well because uh when he plays
well it's a joy to watch exactly weigh
in here Alejandro uh the so this well
what is it the sinking Violet uh never
mind shrinking violet what's going on
with Bobby uh aliantra it's on he's not
been a disaster and he does come from a
couple of tournaments where you think
he's on a Free Fall especially the
Olympian was a very painful tournament
for Fabiano not only because of his
personal performance but because they
did kind of think the American ship
there over in India where we expected so
much more from the American team lost 18
rating points a huge huge amount was
briefly out of the top ten and well at
least in this one he more or less rides
the ship I think if he wins the last
game with black against Hans he won't be
also unsatisfied with the tournament and
he's going to be hoping for some kind of
mathematical Miracle to get him in those
top three places in the grand Chester
and it's still possible because remember
that the current leader of the of the
grand Chester before the tournament
started Maxima Sherlock exactly is just
having a disaster right that is that is
true and Livonia is also above above
fardeen in the grandchester standings is
I mean they're both on 50 50 if if Fabi
wins today and left doesn't finally
perhaps right yeah again has a shot yeah
he gained some serious uh Grand Chester
once and there's the man who have we
been speaking about Fabian karuana
getting ready his turn to be wanted as
the players get ready for again this
penultimate
uh tournament
now might be a good time just to get it
in they're fighting hard uh Peter what
are they fighting for in terms of money
there's plenty at stake apart from Pride
which I think drives a lot of these guys
and perhaps even more than money but
there's a lot of money at stake as well
as you can see on your screens there a
hundred thousand dollars for the winner
here and the 12 or 13 GST points at
stake as well which translates into
money exactly it surely does in some
cases as well and uh the total prize
fund is uh 350 000 very very generous
person being awarded at the GST event
and of course we have our brilliancy
prize very nice big shout out to Brian
for his support Peter yes absolutely we
also have this uh five thousand dollar
brilliant surprise donated by Brian
prister uh and uh well with only two
rounds to go perhaps it's time for for
the players to start you know really
stepping up and stepping up and
producing the goods and or petitioning
us right convince us that the goods have
already been produced and yeah this is
what we should be voting for because it
is the four of us who will eventually
decide where this money goes and our
views can be swayed you you write us and
let us know what you think uh should
qualify as the brilliancy we'll take it
under uh advisement this is the way they
can do it yeah how do people join the
show uh there's definitely all the chats
are being being monitored not by us
personally but people yeah people are
keeping a watchful eye over those and
also you can tweet at STL chess club and
those are also being seen by uh the
relevant people they're relevant our
overlords there we have it E4 E5
Wesley played uh the Petrov against Hans
a couple of rounds earlier this really
really nice game he won against against
Hans Neiman uh where uh kind of a
typical Wesley game he plays to equalize
then his opponent makes one inaccuracy
and it seems like the game is gone he
played a virtually Flawless game uh uh
Alejandro uh when I think of uh the
players in the tournament and I think of
the mistakes that Wesley has made
compared to the field my goodness he's
just been remarkably consistent yeah
he's so hard to beat right and this is
what alireza's task ahead is is beating
Wesley so because when you just want to
draw Wesley and you yourself are a 2750
player it doesn't seem like the hardest
he doesn't play this crazy wild
complications with black honestly not
worthwhite either he likes the same
Physicians he likes to nurse advantages
but beating Wesley man that is hard and
we've seen so many people try to beat
Wesley and just not only fail
but get get crushed yeah when they get
these complications when they do
eventually open up the game because
Wesley is a player that is just so well
prepared in so many uh different
openings and in so many different types
of positions he loves playing his
repertoire he is extremely loyal to it
uh the fact that he played the Petrov
which is in in itself a very safe
defense right was already unusual for
him exactly
um we do have another Petrov by the way
in the game between a Lavon and nepo
nepos Petrov has just brought him
yeah wonderful success yeah I think it
improved his his quality of life quite
significantly because he is now
equalizing against Lonnie 4 I think his
repertoire has become a lot more solid
it's not that he was I think he was
generally I always felt that he was a
very very strong uh uh neither player I
think the opening agrees with him at
least on a kind of a spiritual level I
think it's right it still his home but
uh yeah the Petrov in particular when
you prepare it with the degree of
seriousness that the world championship
match requires and this is what he
prepared it for basically it just
provides you with such a safety cushion
that he's been sort of largely
untroubled on the black side against 24
these days that really seems to be the
case it looks like uh lavon's playing
the much more traditional systems with
C4 rather than the Knight C3 moves let's
just pick it up from the uh top here we
have the Petrov Castle's Castle C4 and
this queen situ is uh also obviously
obviously a reasonably well-known move
but it's it's an old approach so these
days people play Queen B3 and there's
also uh I mean specifically Queen B3 in
this position uh instead of rookie one
there's a a bunch of other tries of
course but uh in in this position it is
almost exclusively Queen V3 these days
Quincy to being you have to say uh
arguably the second most popular move
but it sort of disappeared in recent
years because of just how topical and
how serious Queen B3 is but uh it's an
important game for Yvonne as well
because the one is definitely in the
running for both this tournament if he
wins today and the dgc overall perhaps
the way the standings are you have to
say that the top two prizes in the GST
overall standings are probably spoken
for right you can imagine some sort of
like if Wesley wins maybe a job salary
as all the way back to like a tie for
for fourth and maybe Wesley pardon me
Levon can sneak in there with it but
generally speaking we've shown this
graphic yesterday I don't know if it's
ready at hand for a production team but
we've shown the graphic well which is
still relevant with this round being so
young and like nothing really has to
happen in this round yet as to like how
would the GC standings look like if the
tournament ends now and and there and
there we have it on our screen in a
moment yes so uh the the gap between uh
second and third there as you can see so
this is the current sendings and coming
into the tournament yeah this is this is
before a move has been played right up
and uh after yesterday
uh and yesterday every single game has
been drawn so uh not not very much
movement in uh in the cross table right
uh we still had alireza being uh being
in a very good position but Wesley would
overtake him because Wesley would get 13
points right uh for the clear first and
Iris is apparently tied for second so he
would get nine so alireza is a point
behind and everybody else is way behind
uh I am talking about a virtual graphic
here but you can but you can imagine you
can imagine sort of what I'm talking
about there you've been doing great with
the virtual game
it's it's still uh it still is the same
one that we showed yesterday we don't
like we don't need to update it again
like the one the one we showed yesterday
is
still fine yeah so in a moment we will
show you that the point that you're
making is MBL has really tumbled out of
contention so you don't literally look
at that yeah and there and here it is
there it is if it ends right now it was
true before the start of yesterday's
round and because there were four four
draws in yesterday's round right it's
still true even now as you can see
Wesley is leading the provisional
standings so to speak by a point from
alireza mvl is still in third livon is
in fourth and Fabi is in fifth and a
Fabi wins today only one doesn't have a
particularly good end of the tournament
because Fabi has a rest day tomorrow so
everyone has like two ways two two games
to uh perhaps go in into the plus score
himself exactly yeah when you look at
the positioning right Fabi and mvl
yeah they're there but Levon has a full
game ahead of them right both mvl and
Favi and we are having arrested today
probably having a rest day tomorrow Mr
levonne is looking at this with great
interest and yeah I think I think
levonne is kind of buying the third spot
there uh and as I said like I think
something really dramatic needs to
happen for the first two prizes in the
GC overall standings for them not to go
to Wesley and others in some order we
don't know which order but in some order
it really does look like people go to uh
those two the grand Chester uh Champion
will win a bonus of a hundred thousand
uh dollars uh fifty thousand to the
runner up 25
000 for finishing third in the overall
Grand chess tour standings that's why
they're fighting so hard that's why this
game between
um
alireza and Wesley a hundred thousand
dollars absolutely it's a game so to
speak it's hugely important in the
concept context of both this tournament
and and the GST overall uh we see a Joko
piano by the way leader yeah in the game
between alireza and Wesley
all very conventional moves that's
pretty much pretty much conventional
although uh I'm a bit Curious by this
like a 786 has always been the sort of
the the obvious way to play these types
and positions this is what we were
taught uh this is absolutely how I was
brought up the place on the black side
of it right but I wonder like in this
particular setup I would be
I'm curious that he chooses this over A5
is what I'm trying to say A5 there's a
whole separate branch of theory these
days connected with the move A5 here
which has become more and more popular
as a way to prevent what I assume will
be happening right now which is uh the
result starts with A4 you could I think
maybe even start with B4 straight away
but then everyone starts with A4 and
white uh against the normal setup with
Rook 8 and Bishop B6 is very much
playing to assume uh well not control
but to gain some space on the queen side
and to play from there
but but Peter I got to ask because okay
I can see what you're saying you know
you want to gain space on the queen side
with moves like B4 maybe A5 maybe B5
you're getting some space but aren't you
hitting empty space so for example
suppose I say go ahead
oh okay too yeah because I what I wanted
to do was just simply get out of the way
of this Pawn Rush yeah I think I think
this is why they played before sort of
as a very very last move which ah like I
said instead of rookie eight I will play
before here but then it doesn't said I
mean again through gate I'm sorry yeah
sorry here if I do play rookie eight
yeah
no here yeah maybe but honestly uh it's
all it's all transpositions but this is
the sort of the tibia of uh the A6
Bishop space seven Italian by this point
Blacklist Bishop B6 here generally
speaking this is why you play rookie
eight so which B6 white takes only six
you take with the Rook yeah and now both
Queen C2 and I believe Bishop B2 and
neither one also reasonably serious
moves but Quincy 2 is by far the main
move in this position okay preserving uh
I think the point of Queen C2 is that
that move is pretty much always going to
be useful right and we don't entirely
know where the bishop and the Knight are
going right here or here C4 it actually
goes to B3 and so if you push the 65
there's definitely going to be at least
some argument for playing Knight B3
because the square yeah exactly is
yester is indicating the C5 Square once
we trade off that Bishop on A7 it
becomes a bit of a Target so Queen C2 is
a way to preserve all of our options
without committing to any one plan at
this time uh and and this this position
seemingly kind of innocuous very very
quiet position has in in our database
which doesn't have some of the faster
time controls actually so the number is
much larger yeah it has almost 200 games
our database blowed up uh with the with
news of this variation and Alejandra let
me uh turn it up oh by the way A6
followed by a
this has been pioneered by by Alexander
grishek I think he was the first who
realized you can play like this and uh
the the point of this is that we are now
planning to play Bishop E6 yeah next
move and generally if black plays A5 and
then Bishop B6 uh White's reply very
often would be Bishop C4 to B5
preventing that trade right I can show
you a specific variation relevant so if
you play a five move six we'll move
eight sorry go back if you play A5 move
eight right the absolute main Theory
here after A5 instead of A6 yes just a
second would go a five night digital
okay Bishop B6 Bishop B5
ah this is a hugely hugely important
position in the theory of the Italian
right now and there is like Queen B8
here is 100 200 games already and this
is this looks like a completely random
position right but it's featured in in
hundreds literally hundreds of games yes
but but the point is the bishop on B5
will escape if you continue chasing it
because I can go to A4 and 2c2 if you
like if you if you make an incredibly
yeah sorry yeah if you make a instead of
Queen B8 if you choose to play Knight A7
for example yes the bishop does not get
chased down it just gets very safely
back to a to C2 and then we play D3 D4
and we're actually kind of very we have
a very promising position here for white
exactly once you've provoked A4 which is
what Wesley has done and which is what
uh Alexander grishek was doing in those
games yeah so you play a6a5 here right
we're gonna beat it too right Black Goes
Bishop B6 having saved the tempo of
rookiee yeah and now if you play Bishop
B5 which is still a very solid move and
there's been a like Magnus played this
mvl played this a bunch of times I think
uh I maybe even had this on the black
side against mvl ones uh this is a very
serious position but 97 actually sort of
captures well without winning Bishop
yeah we're not winning this bishop but
we're definitely trading it yeah we're
forcing the trade even in this case
we're forcing the trade we're taking it
and both both D takes C5 and they takes
B5 are sort of Labor in that position
that has been played yeah yeah uh Magnus
won a very very uh good strategic game
against Wesley specifically after D4
Knight takes B5 D takes C5 uh was a very
very instructive game where he went for
a kind of a weird Pawn structure he took
on D6 right and then after Queen takes
D6 uh B3 uh he eventually played I mean
it was a slightly different move order
but eventually he played Knight C4
allowed that trade I see and it looks
like White's entire Queen side has been
destroyed right but the F3 Knight by
h2f1 and uh E3 got to G5 later in the
game compensating for all of it and uh
uh this is a very very interesting
variation which has seen a lot of
high-level Grandmaster practice wow uh
the the the advancement of opening
theory is is simply remarkable Alejandro
over to you what is caught your eye in
this penultimate round I think we got
the case of a bit of Confusion by one of
the players going through this game
between levonne aronian and Jane ponies
and we got to this position after Queen
C2 we said it was the old variation
yeah I've never played Bishop G6 it's
one of the moves here in this position
the other move is Knight A6
and after the move C5 Bishop C7 live on
play
relatively instantly the move Knight bd2
I went through the database 100 of the
games go Knight C3
if you look at my engine
it's giving about a plus 0.2 for Knight
C3 and the moment that you put in Knight
bd2 it immediately switches to a minus
immediately and then I was playing
around with is there a difference like
if you play Knight A6 first and you play
A3 and then you go through the same
variations then in this position the
engines are saying that you can play an
ibd2 and then it makes more sense
because B4 comes faster something along
those lines but the moment I put F5 on
the board it just really did not like it
Queen B3 now played I hope that he has
some kind of idea he's already spending
a little burning a little bit of time
but the engines are starting to like
black a lot thinking that after Rook F7
defending this Pawn indirectly because
Queen takes B7 of course you have the
static on Bishop takes H2 and then just
follow it up with normal development
including the move Knight D7 because
then Queen takes B7 can be met my knight
D takes C5 uh let me put that on the
board for example like if I play
something dumb and I play Knight D7 you
play Queen takes B7 I have Knight D take
C5 hits the queen hits the bishop and if
you take my knight I have this discovery
and then I capture your queen so you
can't do that and if Rook F7 is played I
not really sure what Levon is planning
on doing here this is already a pretty
comfortable structure for the black side
the pressure on e4 is already very
heavily guarded by the pawns and as far
as I know this is like strategically
very nice for them I think that side I
think one way to perhaps for this to not
be a mix-up is what the what the first
line on your screen is saying which I
think we probably need to show and to
try to explain because Knight C4 this
will this would be the only way for me
to uh to justify what we're doing here
with white I really like my experience
overall tells me this can never work
okay because black really hasn't
committed enough crimes to be punished
we punished this harshly but that would
be the only in Rook F7 already on the
board so young clearly uh because I
think is missable like I didn't I didn't
really uh you have no sense maybe
there's actually some hidden Theory some
ideas that I I do not know about because
Rook F7 is not the only move in this
position I don't think but it's the only
one that fights for Advantage yeah you
can play B6 so you're not your position
is not that horrible no actually it's
the only one of course Knight takes E4
is right yeah that was that's the point
here Rook of seven not only protects B7
yeah but we were also threatening uh
yeah exactly we were threatening to just
win the Central Pawn here using the PIN
uh on this diagonal no it's it's a very
concrete idea but it's currently after
Rook F7 the Knight only four is so
strong and the advantage of not the
advantage of having not played Knight A6
yet and not having misplaced that night
like if if we get to play Knight bg7
here and not lose the pawn on B7
this is about as dream opposition of the
bishop D6 Petrov as you can imagine the
Knight only four is fully fully
established uh White has no real ways of
challenging it
and
white very often just gets kind of
swiped off the board because I mean
using the Knight on e4 is a kind of a
shield yeah you can launch very very
serious attacks against the white king
side that's why it really is stuck
without any particular slightly
concerned Lavon didn't Blitz out
something yeah like right that was
exactly what I was going to say like if
a move here comes instantly then we prep
we can start revising our assessment of
this position a little bit because the
ng900 is using is a good engine but
obviously if there is some very deep
level prep going on you you need to let
it stew you know you are 30 second
assessments might not be entirely
correct but I mean it's our hours are
never correct but the engine sometimes
actually gets there in 30 seconds but
maybe not yeah uh but if if Levon starts
thinking here that's not a good time
it's it's generally just a horrible sign
because as we're as we're discussing
like if black has time here to play
Knight bd7 Rook ba English page five
like nothing will ever move in
particular if Bishop g6h5 is such a
horrible move to face in these types of
positions because then your your night
player honestly 92 are completely stuck
right you you can't play another one
because your king size gets to be
destroyed and the lesson of three really
does not have any squares once the Black
Knight lands on this phone and
especially I feel like uh with the queen
on B3 like if we just go back to this
moment and you do play the move b2b4
they don't like this either I understand
uh the the point there is you've
defended C5 absolutely you you you you
have something to look forward to Bishop
B2 and 95. conversely you put your queen
on B3 now we've misplaced so many things
okay as you say you've made a concrete
threat you're threatening to take
everything on e4 and I have a concrete
answer so I block the diagonal I defend
B7 and and then I'm thinking well your
queen is actually misplaced yeah I
looked on B3 I looked up and now I'm
kind of I'm ready to give my verdicts uh
this looks like a Miss slip 11 dispose
is like Lev is not one of those players
who will pretend he doesn't know right
he would have continued blitzing if he
had a if he had if Knight C4 was was
prepared yeah or perhaps I don't know 94
F4 Knight G5 would be another way to try
to do something tactically I just don't
believe it works I remember as a class
player I played against Walter gentalla
and the American chess service and he
stuck a knight on e4 against me and I
had just exactly that type of position
that you described uh Peter just
everything kind of went wrong for me and
then came this move Bishop H5 and I was
like I can't move the Knight on D2 I can
never do this this guy couldn't go it
was just a disaster so you should give
me a little Kings like G5 four stars
coming and like if we have 6g5 G4 you
just get destroyed did you study my game
against Walter I mean uh it looks bad
now take us through why Knight C4 might
be necessary uh Alejandro because I mean
I think Frieda pretty much covered that
one right like what what do you play if
it's not no Knight C4 give me a good
move
yeah it's not because it's a good move
it's because if you if you don't the
alternatives are so bad right it's right
it's because you you by this point you
realize things have gone badly badly
astray and and you need to do something
spectacular to sort of change the course
of the game that's really the only
explanation for it okay but now having
got there as Peter said you know you're
making a combination you're making this
tactical move 94 but I haven't done I
haven't transgressed yeah I haven't done
anything I deserve to be punished for uh
do we take the Knight or do we just play
Knight D7 I think in terms of refutation
after 97 I think white probably is
intending to play 96 here Knight decent
yeah and if you take take
um there's Bishop G5 Nigeria like there
will be positional compensation here
because uh like the rook and lend on E6
specifically yeah I'm not exactly sure
exactly how we're supposed to proceed
but weirdly having shed this Pawn I'm
I'm feeling a bit Freer you know I'm
feeling a bit so happier about it okay
and as Wilhelm steinert so the best way
to refute a Gambit is to accept it yeah
so what happens on on on this uh and and
now do we play B6 well if we play B6 or
I'm pretty sure B5 is being replied to
with Bishop B6 like we're never doing
this to take on F7 if we take on F7 yeah
it's a resignation yeah right so we play
Bishop E6 and we hope to you know land
some kind of a tactical blow in the
future I don't exactly know which this
doesn't really look like it should work
yeah
I mean you know it's not like maybe I
think I think this is wrong I think we
go 55 I think we take on B6
yeah okay cbab and we play Knight G5
there maybe maybe this is the way to try
to Justified
yeah yeah at least you do have in this
case you're winning the development
sweepstakes I wanted to say there is a
that's actually a kind of a cute pack
right it is yes okay
um as I said I don't really believe this
works but your alternatives are just so
ugly yeah exactly if you let black
finish development here I'm disturbed
you're just going to be worse for
nothing like it's just going to be such
a pleasant free role for black the night
on e4 firmly is constantly in the middle
of the board here other games perhaps
yes exactly Alejandro I see that you've
got an English on your board no I'm just
going through the games this game is so
slow I mean I'm mostly interested in
this one between Jana and Lavon because
it's the one with the action I was going
through some of the lines that you were
talking about and you were spot on the
B5 Pawn takes is actually okay for uh
for white because of this move Knight G5
saying that you still actually have to
find equality with uh black already and
it finds it with Queen f8 96 and some
weird stuff but B5 is definitely not
necessary there is a difficult move
perhaps not that difficult move to find
here in this position it's the same move
Knight D7 yes you give up the B7 Pawn
pretty much for free and it is an
important one because it's the base of
your structure but the engine says that
after Queen takes B7 any move like king
h8 or something like this the moment
that you give up your Bishop even though
you collected a lot of Pawns in this in
this position right you're just not
developed
and it comes to D5 very quickly as well
right yeah Knight df6 or even Knight f8
more importantly Bishop comes to D5 this
Bishops let me put a stupid move on the
board this Bishop's targeting this King
site with this development and no way of
of countering the light Square blockade
means that according to the engines
white is just busted yeah A3 is a
horrible move if you if you play
something relevant you're not lost yet
like not yet but but it is really bad
yeah it's clearly clearly much better
for black for sure yeah despite the
material advantage let's call it that
for white so Rook F7 on the board level
still has to find the move Knight C4 but
he might find it out of necessity more
than anything else uh let's go to other
games meanwhile uh this one is
developing slowly through a position
that both sides should know the near
Dominguez of course we know is an
incredibly well prepared player and he's
playing currently against Muhammad yarov
and this is one of shocks bad lines this
is the open Spanish and he's played this
exact position against Fabiano caruana
in 2018 a game that I actually remember
quite well and I want to see where
Lanier is going to bring something new
to the table because obviously mamad
yarov knows exactly what to do in this
position he has not spent any time he's
on an hour and 34 minutes meanwhile
Dominguez all the way down to an hour
and 17. that's unusual for him when he
knows the opening he doesn't play
instantly but he plays a little quicker
than this considering that they've
already made a ton of moves remember
that adds 30 second increment per move
times 16 and I feel that perhaps he's
still trying to figure out which
variation he wants to play I don't know
we'll let this once too all right and
I'll just go back to our Marquee match
up the hundred thousand dollar uh game
if you will between Ali Reza and Wesley
so after a uh A6 A5 a kind of a
a contrarian movie just played Asics
that you're gonna play A5 interesting
Knight D2 Bishop E6 and Bishop B3 b2b3
it looks extremely odd I think but it's
become a very very well important part
of White's replies to the systems of the
bishop B6 uh in particular now that the
bishop on C4 is resigned to being traded
in Black once because before 5 Knight A7
as we've established right it's playable
but I think the current understanding is
black is completely fine B3 of course
the idea is if you ever do take on C4
we're not taking with the B Pawn pretty
much every single time you are not we
are we are we are of course yeah no we
want we want as as large of a pawn
Center as possible it completely stops
counter play with d65 it gives us a
semi-open file on the B file to do
something The Rook on B1 looks a bit
more sensible than an A1 okay and then
we we go around like another one night
G3 or Knight F1 Knight E3 it's it's not
that I would like to make a claim as why
it is immediately better but this is I
think ideal scenario I think
becomes more useful yeah once you see
the movie 2b3 you generally no longer
take on C4 and this is what uh Westing
has also done his play through K8 uh and
uh this is still a very reasonably
heavily uh trafficked position uh there
is a game here from 2020 between the
annual publisher and vision and for one
fresh yeah I have a feeling that maybe
uh maybe I even had a discussion on the
white side once but obviously I can't
remember against whom or how it went or
anything right I just know that I played
B3 in a very
surprisingly a large amount of Italian
positions uh in in recent years well one
of the reasons for delaying or avoiding
this trade is you do Avail yourself of
the possibility of d65. now is this the
type of thing that black is aiming for
absolutely Maybe not immediately
depending obviously on what white does
but it definitely is uh what you're
switching to in a lot of these cases
you're switching to the ideas of playing
the 65 and playing in the center like
this because as I said uh people do
occasionally take on C4 after B3 but
it's rare right and I would expect it's
pretty much never you know quote unquote
correct like I personally would
uh rather play anything else really
because I think it very much sort of
white is asking you to do this and then
like why are we doing it's not forced
why are we playing along I I feel like
I'm growing myself into an opening
theoretician now that you've played
rookie eight yes look at my uh
understanding Peter admire my Brilliance
yeah this is what Young actually played
against uh oh really
I didn't realize this I thought I was
you know bravely going where no person
has gone before well in many ways in
many ways but not in this but not in
this position uh the movie should be
fine it does make sense
d3d4 okay absolutely how would you
approach this position if you were white
would you play Knight F1 would you play
Bishop would you play Queen C2 no I
think here cleans it to his list is less
crucial I think we are very much playing
for d3d4 plans okay and for that I think
keeping the queen on G1 and preserving
you know an additional piece which
controls the D4 square is useful I think
I'm probably like
it's between Bishop B5 and Knight F1 I
think okay
I'm probably leading Bishop B5 because
I'm I'm worried we're allowing the 65
here a little bit my concern my most
pressing concern is if if black gets in
d65 and we do see Bishop B2 on the board
probably for that very reason that d65
is coming now that the Rook is on E8 and
D6 D5 just uh instantly played it yeah
he didn't even get a chance to toss the
ball I mean to our partner yeah that's
less work for me right
don't you go anywhere Alejandro well
let's take a look at this position
crucial for the GCT it seems like if you
take on D5 black is well prepared to now
take with the bishop of course you want
to defend the spot on E5 you could take
with the Knight but very often if you're
able to get this bishop off the e-file
it's just more comfortable to play with
the black pieces you can start putting
things on E6 including the Rook on E6
maybe transfer the rook and it's just
not of a wide Ones white usually wants
to retain the tension here which is why
actually in this position the move uh
Bishop B5 is so much more common than
the move Bishop B2 which I believe is a
novelty because after Bishop B5 D5 is
simply impossible and you have black now
needs to find another Avenue here the
main move is Bishop D7 just to get rid
of the pin and then you can consider
Bishop E2 which has been played many
times Queen C2 which is a very natural
move Peter had already mentioned that in
a slightly different position and after
Bishop B2 D5 is simply not a possibility
here for the black side D5 here you
simply well you could play it but
apparently it's not as good and our D5
in this position just seems to equalize
according to my engines you must must
the idea must be to move the bishop I
can't imagine that you take on D5 and
claim an edge but here in this position
I have a pawn Tech C4 Knight takes C4 I
don't think I don't think you take with
the pawn because Knight H5 the engines
are already saying is bad for white
actually wow and if you take with the
Knight I feel like you're just so
comfortable yeah you'd have to take with
the Rook because if you take with the
pawn now this Pawn on B3 looks very
silly yes take on D1 take on D1 and you
can take on B3 so again I don't know if
it's a case of a mix-up because D5 seems
to just solve all of Wesley's problems
yeah I'm a bit surprised at how quickly
uh Bishop bittu has been played it does
seem like you're absolutely allowing
black exactly to set up that black wants
in these types of structures and yeah it
feels like Wesley is very very
comfortable in this extremely crucial
game for the tournament and yeah it's
time to bring up the uh the English that
was kind of lurking off our streets
versus uh Fabi C4 uh by Hans opening
game E5 Knight C3 it's strange in his
book by uh on the English Michael Marin
or Marin uh suggests G2 G3 as the single
best move on move two all my life I
played Knight C3 and I was very
intrigued by
Michael's approach and I remember
playing against the lakshi sheriff he
ages ago he'd S8 this move against me
and it seems so contrarian because after
all aren't you losing a Tempo after
Knight D5 and unless if I 5 I think is
kind of a modern modern take on this
because for years they've been playing
[ __ ] B7 and claiming even this is okay
which is kind of striking exactly it
really is right but uh yeah the the
reason
um uh Mikhail Marin was suggesting uh G3
and 793 is I think I'm not sure if it's
specifically Bishop before here but it's
the point that this sort of reverse for
salimas if you can if you can call them
that like of various systems where black
can play Bishop before against tonight
on C3 they provide black with sort of an
additional additional sort of layer of
systems which you have to study and
which are very sound in many many cases
quite sound for black so by playing G3
we are trying to avoid at least some of
them exactly and one of them we are
watching today uh A5 and A5 is a is an
interesting kind of newish concept here
where black says I will spend uh quite a
serious amount of time uh you know
knocking this bishop around right but we
are not trading it for a night it goes
to A7 Avengers we will see in the game
and we get these types of double edge
positions which you know optically look
very very nice for white once again
let's get to where they got to okay A3
Bishop C5 another 3d6 E3 uh C6 now hands
played G2 G4 because you don't have to
uh retreat with the night yet you can
win this Tempo by uh playing D4 and 93
97 and uh before already already has
saved as well we're still following some
very high level Grandmaster games this
is still the game between uh radical and
Matthias bluebound from 2020 and a more
recent game between Alexis Arena and
Alexander rahmanov in 2021 this has
become somehow a kind of a topical line
where
it looks
a bit like an old Indian yes but with
the bishop on A7 and some Tempe losses
going on here uh take us down what the
the prescribed passive I'm not sure I've
never looked at this what I want to say
is you know optically it feels like
white has a reasonably nice spatial
Advantage there's a special NCH which
will be difficult to develop
um
c45 definitely in some positions will
become a topic even though you have to
time it properly because of course of
course because like for instance here
just to show what I mean by timing
properly because if I okay this way you
can do it my argument was if you place
the actual C5 immediately let's do it
let's go you can you should at least
consider e492 D5 right yes which leads
to a very strange structure where you
know white will already gain a lot of
space on the green side like you can
play B5 here right but black
in some cases we'll be quite happy but I
think with the King on E1 this probably
is quite good for white if the King was
already on G1 let's say we add b55
Castle yeah let's say you should be two
level T8 a new Castle King side and now
I go Bishop B8 Knight f896 Knight H4 and
so on yeah and you happily Checkmate me
because my or at least I attempt to
right my point is with the King on G1
there is this counter play with the King
still in the center if we try doing the
same like castles here yep I can play B5
B6 right right maybe even shed down the
bishop and suggest that without the King
on the on G1 providing black with
counter play like these might go these
whole whole bunch of pieces on the queen
side might never have another move in
this game right and and the and the pawn
is actually quite eventually it will be
quite quick quite a simple Target I do
remember a game between uh Gary Kasparov
and deep blue where this essentially
happened and Gary won uh rather
swimmingly I want to say
all right well
and again for Fabi you know he would
love to end this tournament on a high
note by the way Knight G8 episode on the
board and uh Bishop B2 is very logical
here Queen C2 is also played in one game
but I think having played before you
want to play Bishop B2 and this is what
exactly has already exactly uh played
now in you know in my mental I I would
love to be able to take take put the
pawn on C5 put the bishop on C4 put the
Knight on G5 Queen on C2 and let's go
let's go yeah I was wondering where you
where you're going with this because G5
G5 C5 can also be connected I think with
a very strong positional plan of 92
94.96 right yeah so yeah as I said like
optically I don't really feel like black
should be equal here
but it's become a very serious topic
we've seen extremely strong players like
we played with black Vision doesn't
really you know play
incorrect or sort of incorrect
variations very much so right uh it's a
very serious stamp of approval there the
fact that this [ __ ] they should play
this with with the black pieces right
but I mean if I had to pick a side it
would take me three seconds to be quiet
but uh
clearly it's not as as much of a one-way
one-way Street here as we are yeah
indicating now I mean as far as I'm
concerned black has two moves uh castles
is probably the most critical if I go
down this path and you end up yeah I
think going after yeah I think it's
still early you you do go for the pawn
probably yeah Queen takes beef because
we've just seen so many of those Pawn
sacrifices over the years that at least
you have to look at them all right and
after castles what would happen next
I'm probably playing mishpitsu like your
ideas of G5 G5 and C5 are not bad but I
think
you know finishing development first
should not really be a horrible idea
always good develop your your your
pieces everybody but E4 rookie a we'll
keep our eye on this and I break his
breaking development in our bedroom oh
uh what has Lavon done Levon you know
said their wife with his uh it's it's a
move intending to stop Knight D7 I don't
know if it does stop 97 but he is
defending specifically against the
tactic that Alejandro pointed out 97 he
will he will take on B7 or at least he
will hope that it works now Bishop C2
has a threat he wants to take I think on
ig5 and Knight G5 that as well then
because the The Rook will be of the king
will be forced it will be exposed to E7
are we sure this pin will not cost us
any material uh I think at least you're
happy about the developments after 94
and Bishop G5
specifically yeah because Bishop G5 is
yes thank you maybe it doesn't cost this
material yeah uh yeah I was just I I
paused because there is
well yeah I paused yeah this becomes
this becomes a mess but maybe we can
play Bishop G5 G4 and then pictures
quite strong yeah oh thank you yes that
is seven somehow that lurking threat of
Queen takes B7 has been lurking lurking
and apple does this very Nepal thing
very practical very quick doesn't think
too long oh you're threatening Knight
takes Pawn takes Knight G5 let's go H6
right is it wrong no second best move
the best move according to the engine
was A5 which defends from the
threatening completely different
directions trying to kick the queen away
from the diagonal right but I think H6
is just as good
they just suddenly say it's slightly
less good so so to be clear we take
first yeah yeah we take first only four
you do ah now then Knight of seven uh
but we just rookie seven uh yeah because
we have A4 anyway we continue having A4
on top exactly okay so A7 A5 first
engines move uh second not bad H7 H6 you
have a thread I stop it
yeah but the life is simple life is very
simple life is simple if you're playing
the petrol from the airport and mixes up
the move order and you're also extremely
strong and very very good at chess yeah
those are those are and you're really
well prepared yes this is a good
combination of factors here for young
but my my other point I think is still
sort of valid let's make a waiting move
here of sorry I don't know A2 A3 just to
just to illustrate what I was talking
about please
if you go 97 here which is extremely
desirable right I think I can try taking
on B7 because because after Knight gc5
my wish was not hanging exactly the
bishop and I can take on C6 here and I
think the queen escapes you have Rook of
six okay but I think it escapes yb5
and if it does escape yb5 I mean this is
a playable position we black different
people have counter play but we have at
least you have opponent yeah we have a
pawn we've destroyed the structure a
little bit right right we've gained
something exactly so uh Knight D7 isn't
untapped but on the other hand if I'm
black and it's my turn I'm not untoward
uh I'm kind of thinking Besame I think
we're very okay with the age of play
with zombies you know why not
um still it looks like uh Lavon by the
way from at least his body posture he's
like drilling down into the position and
I think he's mixed things up I think
he's in trouble
he's done this
times already in this tournament he
mentioned that he mixed up his opening
against Hans in the very very first game
right where he played uh this before he
won Berlin yeah yeah he played a 46 and
sent out his prep I believe that he's
done it again and I'm trying to remember
that he specifically came into studio
and said that he played the wrong move
order it didn't matter in that
particular game it ended up transposing
but that he had played the wrong move
order so it's not the first or second
time that he does that and it's clear by
now that he's done something wrong
because well the engine is really
claimed a black advantage and he's a
body posture very obviously telegraphs
that well things things have gone wrong
already and even in his analysis
yesterday in his game against Bobby he
came on Alejandro and he freely
confessed that in a previous game
against Bobby in the same variation he
mixed things up I mean and that's so
understandable Peter I mean what the
players have studied what they've
memorized uh it's easy to mix one the
volume the volume of things that livon
has looked over at scary over the course
of his life is absolutely scary and even
when uh when he was talking about this
line yesterday which he and Bobby kept
on playing and it's like it's one of the
Fabi in his interview said that he is
probably the person who's played that
line the most out of here you wanna
ending right like out of everybody in
the entire Chess World also has a bunch
of experience there but it all sort of
Blends together in your mind and you're
making those small
discernments and choosing between
between lines is difficult in the
meantime Bishop B5 has been played by
Larissa right uh Wesley instantly goes
divided the xc4 as we've expected right
yeah the in particular I think it's very
striking that the engine immediately
starts liking black after GE fortnite H5
because these types of positions they
sometimes are supposedly a bit better
for white because in that structure uh
why that list can pretend that the
biggest difference between white and
black here is that black has the light
on C6 which is kind of poor and white
has a light on D2 which could be
transferred over to I don't know F1 E3
G5 or C4 and and so on more flexible
yeah but Knight H5 here is just
incredibly annoying because uh as
Alejandro indicated in a you know kind
of a different variation B3 is
constantly very vulnerable meaning that
moving right away from D2 is difficult
and here I'm guessing it's something
like Knight F4 simply yeah we don't even
need to uh Queen G5 Queen H4 no this is
this is uh
the engines were actually suggesting you
absolutely have to take with the Knight
and the Rook right but considering the
fact that alireza has to play for a win
today I understand why he wasn't that
excited about taking with the knight in
The Rook allowing the temple with now if
we continue that line
yeah we go Bishop D5 so go play F6 I
guess right sorry just to once again uh
mention that anytime you take with the
pawn and leave the pesky on B3 hanging
yeah unfortunately completely unplayable
for white so you have to take with the
Rook yeah and my guess is we play Bishop
D5 the rule goes back we play Queen F6
just doesn't look like white will ever
be better here right maybe we're not
Wars somehow but it's not
you might just be worse yeah yeah but
it's not very the only reason I'm
suggesting it might not be worse is
because I I saw the evaluation on the
100 screen which wasn't really which
wasn't really as bad as I expected let's
put it like this okay but it takes takes
uh but I mean this night coming in F4
Queen F6 yeah I can make a lot of easy
moves here for black it's just it's just
very very comfortable very natural uh
play for for Wesley by the way uh Peter
uh the times between the two was he is
playing more or less instantly uh he
generally doesn't play as quickly as
some of the other people we see in this
tournament play when they know
everything so he's down like 10 minutes
on the clock from his starting time
considering the increment oh me but it's
pretty it's pretty quick and alireza has
already burned uh through half an hour
he is
not I think very happy with how this is
developing perhaps there was a bit of a
mix-up because Bishop bitsu at least on
our screen is a novelty and it does not
appear to be a particularly impressive
one we have to say I think it's not
great but if we're already talking about
a black Advantage how serious is it uh
Peter it's hard to judge because uh you
know white it doesn't feel like white
has done much wrong I mean we we know
Bishop on B2 yeah not not there yeah
yeah it's not healthy uh
Alejandro I mean we're we we've really
warmed up to Wesley's position we think
if Wesley gets to play Knight F4 and
queen F6 you can pretty much uh well not
resign but you resign yourself to a very
very unpleasant game
what's the advantage like the engine
that I'm using gives it 0.8 for black
which is very serious it's very serious
14 this is quite a lot yeah yes and what
is the the main lines then after Knight
H5
miserable things they're miserable
things I mean none of these things are
getting played Bishop A3 is one of them
just to exchange this bishop allowing
takes takes and the Knight jumping to F4
this is already very dangerous you have
to follow up with Rook A1 Queen F6 is
coming
flows flows for black right Rook 88
coming everything in Black's favor G5 at
some point with the idea of H5 G4 coming
very dangerous already not H5 but what
else do you do I mean this variation you
guys were mentioning terrible Queen G5
is good knight F4 is obviously good but
Queen G5 Knight ef3 Queen G6 the engine
is saying minus 1.5 minus 1.6 very very
serious threats you're running out of
moves Bishop takes H3 is a threat hard
to defend against that simple thing
because Bishop takes F2 is on tap if you
go this way right if you go back with
the Knight I'm not repeating moves take
Stakes Queen G3 picks up that night with
a humongous positional Advantage thank
you for destroying your king side if
Wesley plays Knight H5 in this position
I think Wesley would be in a huge
favorite of sealing the grand Chester
for himself wow yeah wow and and once
again he plays a very solid opening uh
and then uh because people feel sort of
obliged to challenge his uh his very uh
dominant position in both the tournament
and the tour people kind of throw
themselves at him well I'm seeing shades
of nepo where his Russian defense is
holding ground and then you know people
commit Kamikaze against him by the way
Alejandra I just had to ask you this
bishop on B2 looks terrible to me the
bishop on C5 looks great in my eyes you
offered the move Bishop A3 I'm also
wondering why would I ever trade off my
guided missile I'll put it on A7 and
what's the bishop doing on A3 that's
would want me to trade it off it's an
engine line Bishop Dave C6 B takes C6
and it just wants to go C4 C5 and seal
that Bishop shut up thank you I mean
there had to be a reason no no there has
to be a reason otherwise you don't trade
this bishop for running on A3 but that
is yeah that's a good reason I'm still
honestly some surprised by this because
we can't play in either 4c5 93 and just
take it off the board that but I guess
it doesn't I guess it doesn't work
tactically something maybe I'll second
exchange Peter actually maybe we go
Queen C2 here yeah and just say okay I
mean I mean I may not be happy but at
least this bishop I'm making my life's
Mission and never to let that Bishop
the more the more I feel like this is
probably the answer yeah I'm just I'll
defend you know the C5 to them yeah to
The Bitter End absolutely uh by the way
C3 C4 that is really uh quite like
coming up with this concept like if
Knight H5 happens and this is like
seriously the best white has I don't
fancy being alirezo there uh good point
yeah but Bishop takes A3 also I
appreciate that move because it wins a
Tempo You're Gonna Play Queen F6 and 904
okay G8 it's just a very very uh easy
flowing game as Alejandro was saying
it's just your every move makes
immediate perfect sense you have the
better the more active light pieces the
more active Queen you will be the first
one to put the Rook on an open file of
the queen of six through kg8 euro will
get to G8 faster and anything that white
is doing it's just an incredibly
comfortable position you do have to play
Knight H5 now though if you don't play
Knight H5 right this moment white
probably stabilizes great
uh very importantly there again I want
to just check in on the uh Lavon game
okay after H7 H6 Lavon said
tonight can you still do something so
he's uh he's bringing pieces back I feel
that like if we want to play 97 I think
we can actually play 97 if we continue
that variation a little bit I take on C5
if you take on C6 both of my light
pieces are hanging so I have to play
Rook F6
B5 is the only Square I want to include
Rook B8
so far two is the only square and I'll
just go and I see 5v6 here
and I'm suggesting this page five is my
next move if I can get it like if I
could already Play Bishop H5 here I'm
going for this position without a second
hesitation but Knight G3 kind of bothers
me just to stop stopping stopping page
five I feel like black probably isn't
worse here but we've got great calm yeah
but because Bishop H5 has been stopped I
am no longer so sure I'm better yeah and
I kind of feel like okay even if I go
down I go down with a full form
which is why which is nourishment you
know I guess we can just play me 76 and
not be not be that exactly but we
definitely like nepo I want to go uh one
game we really linear Shack I mean okay
not crucial for our standings but let's
face it the this is a very heavy weight
there theoretical matchup between two
world-class theoreticians absolutely
yeah and uh is uh I don't think you very
often you know enters the conversation
for like the the foremost theoreticians
of our age but in his own systems
he generally is extremely well booked up
I remember this is his system yeah I
remember in in Reykjavik 2015 2015 when
uh I think it was the last time I played
for the Russian national team uh we
played it was the last year 2015 I think
2015. and uh gosh is it really seven
years ago geez yeah okay so and uh and
that actually went well we won the
European teams very comfortably I I
played decently on board one uh we
played as everybody John and I remember
I asked the the coaching staff to come
up with something against the open
because I didn't really feel like
playing you know the Italian for
instance which I personally know nothing
like people people who play the Italian
these days they they kind of need to
know what they're doing and I definitely
didn't uh and they gave me some kind of
a check basically uh they gave me a line
which they said okay if he knows it will
be a draw but we're doing well in the
tournament so it wasn't really a
horrible result for us to have a draw on
board one in that match so everybody was
kind of okay with it and Shaka spent I
think the 20 minutes on the entire game
like he knew everything up can you
everything up to move 35 and it wasn't
it was a topical line but like nothing
surprised him at all there we had like
some kind of a small idea and uh he knew
that the small new idea really really
well as well wow uh Alejandro Lanier
just played rookie three which isn't in
my database how about you no it's not on
mine either and I don't think it was in
Mamet yaros because he did think for a
long time in this pad variation of his
after the move Rook E3 the engine saying
that H6 was a good move he's actually
gone all the way to H5 which also makes
sense in many in many ways it just
defends against G4 which is one of the
lines in this position G4 is one line
Bishop F4 is the other uh so H5 played
very quickly in the near here played the
move Bishop A2 perhaps he was thinking
about which check to perform in this
game but speaking of the H5 Square this
is what we want to see Wesley so has
played the move Knight H5 the engines
give him a strong advantage against
alireza fioruja and this guy's might be
the tour if Wesley plays well from here
on I think it's not so much that there
is an advantage but the more I see what
the engine wants to play with white the
more unlikely it is for me that alireza
will play it I think the bishop A3 move
is so passive and so ugly but what else
do you do in this position as Peter
mentioned you can't move this knight
from D2 B3 is always hanging I think
Wesley is going to be absolutely
thrilled after the first hour of play
thank you Alejandra the hundred thousand
dollar game and as we get ready for our
first break we've got to inform our uh
audience about Q Boutique I am I'm very
happy to be reading what's what's in
front of me you you don't know what's
coming so
um
our offer for today is uh chess campus
souvenirs and now is a great time to
shop for uh the souvenirs from the chess
campus including the stemless wine glass
which is what uh Yasser is now holding
that a laser and Stripes there's there's
a logo on it of the uh the singfield cup
uh the chess club mug which is the one
we showed you yesterday was is this this
very very beautiful mug also with the
logo on it oh yeah let's let's get that
up in there let's do this synchronized
and trying to get a good background for
sorry yes and finally uh uh the the shot
glasses yes yes there is a stance yeah
the the yasser's favorite the world just
Hall of Fame shot glass yeah within our
Armenian cognac no it doesn't include
the Armenian Cognac that's just a prop
much
not included not included but this is
many more Collectibles are uh available
on
cubicstl.com and uh yeah we're happy to
one scotch one bourbon and one beer
absolutely and we're going to see the
program for this break yeah exactly
we're going to see you on the other side
of our brain
thank you
[Music]
hey St Louis the Ascension Charity
Classic presented by Emerson is back
this September don't miss the excitement
when the PGA toured Champions best
compete again all for charity September
9th through the 11th at Norwood Hills
Country Club Pro-Am spots Hospitality
packages VIP tickets and more available
now at Ascension charityclassic.com
by now you guys probably know there's a
lot to see and do in St Louis but when
it comes to the art scene
there's more here than meets the eye
from laumeyer Sculpture Park and the
city garden to the stunning Cathedral
Basilica one of the largest Mosaic
collections in the entire world
so if art is your thing St Louis is on
display all year long ooh now that's an
exhibit
St Lou is always explored
founded in 1839 the University of
Missouri is steeped in Tradition the
recently founded Mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the University of
Missouri and the St Louis chess club
Collegiate Jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of Excellence
Mizzou has always strived for the best
Mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
Discovery and Excellence to the
chessboard
[Music]
go go
[Music]
blame yours at visit mode.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the penultimate round of
the singfield cup and uh we bring you
huge development yeah huge with only one
more move added to the game between our
two leaders of the tournament in the
game of The Reserve versus Wesley so but
what a move that's being added here 92
C4 and the chess engines as well but
this is but this is what both Alejandro
and myself were talking about before we
went on break is that the position maybe
is not lost yet but the moves you have
to make
not to be lost in this position with
white are so difficult and so unnatural
that what what actually happens in a
vast majority of cases after Knight H5
is that you just get completely
completely overrun and this is what
we're watching if if your choices are
instead of Knight C4 as as we've seen on
the 100 screen which by three right with
the idea of then locking it down if it
if it departs the C5 square right or
alternatively like the second one you
will also not guess and I wouldn't have
guessed it this is not my attempt to
slide you yes right no no the second
best move instead of Bishop A3
uh I mean now that I've told you you
will not guess it maybe you will because
that's always a very good hint but the
second best move in this mission is B3
before just throwing that pawn away
please please please open just yeah just
give my pieces something to do and also
yeah and also please remove your Bishop
from this diagonal especially
specifically that as well yeah and then
after she before Bishop takes before why
just make some kind of a quiet move I
mean not very quiet like Queen C2 here
and says now at least some things in my
position make some sense exactly I am
very grateful can I please not get mated
today you know exactly uh but he did
none of that in this night away yeah
instead of ever played Knight C4 and of
course the queen trade is nowhere as we
would say yeah and and after Queen F6
Black's next two moves are Rook 88 and
Knight F4 in some order and it's a Splat
against H3 and white is seemingly
completely defensive okay I got it I
gotta do it I mean nothing else I can do
now of course I can't take with this
night as desirable as that might be I
would love to get a Tempo against that
night but Queen takes F2 it's a bit too
strong they may be mate so okay
no no choice here and I was thinking
about that no no I think neither four
weirdly after neither four C4 I couldn't
find the immediate mate but I think if I
go like Bishop takes B3 and Rook takes
E5 here or something like oh maybe
bishop takes H3 and then Rook takes you
once again maybe c3c4 here somehow
doesn't lose but yeah GH rookie five I
think we resign here with Y because like
look at all the you know Chronicle
Defenders there over there
what the Defenders yeah
it's over it's just over uh so maybe
after Bishop H3 maybe you can play C3 C4
and somehow miraculously you're not dead
but like even this position I have a
feeling that if I calculate precisely I
should be able to give mate here
starting with I don't know Bishop takes
G2 followed by Knight F4 check or rookie
five followed by Queen G5 or queen G6
that one probably is actually stronger
let's go with you which one do you like
after a Whole 30 seconds 95 Queen G5 I
think is just made 95 I can't even play
F2 F4 so everything is pinned I think
I'm giving kind of giving Nathan two
moves here or something so I have to so
you take the bishop I got green G6 in
that position you do have Knight H4
fortunately that is a reason but then
after Queen G5 your entire your entire
board is hanging right like I I was
about to say I have uh a move to make
here but uh I'm not you have to play
okay G1 and then okay I don't know I go
rookie eight here or something just some
kind of a quiet movie yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I wouldn't be surprised if it
was completely busted as well right so
and this is me just kind of you know
throwing stuff at the board you can you
can definitely play more precisely I'm
pretty sure uh I love what you just did
Bishop takes H3 look like yeah we don't
even need to include honestly oh
actually you do I think I think it's a
good idea actually but normally yeah
normally winning a temple 38 shouldn't
be hard Queen C2 Bishop H3 I mean I've
been looking at
um it just looks horrible well takes
Rook takes E5 that's just no that's over
yeah one two three I mean three no this
never survives right like oh dear that
is absolutely embarrassing it's that's
your Royal Fork everybody no this is uh
Peter that's just that's just too easy
actually nobody this is the point in
this position that uh it it becomes
it becomes a reasonably manageable you
know calculation exercise and Wesley
calculates incredibly cleanly right he
is one of the uh easily one of the
cleanest and fastest calculators in the
business and it's just so pleasant
uh take it away from me Alejandro my
eyes hurt this is this is painful uh
you're not supposed to be lost with the
white pieces and one and a half dozen
moves I know it's terrible what Livonia
is doing to his own position
oh sorry I was on a different uh track
all together but this is just
just an advantage for Yan
it's for Wesley so
he saw this game before right let's
let's look it up with the move Knight F1
which was played you guys were analyzing
Knight bd7 B6 all good moves never
played the best one A5 and we had
already discussed this idea that this
queen on B3 is annoying let me see if I
can harass it with the move A4 kick it
out of this good Square where it's a
little unstable and now after the move
A4 which Levon has played stabilizing
the queen on B3 you have this move
Knight A6 played of course by Yan with
the idea the night before just just
closes down the queen side entirely
starts hitting the bishop on C2 and
after Bishop D2 just do not let that
Knight get to B4 Bishop H5 already
played White's position is just terrible
let's go with that it's not very poggers
you go at 95 you lose this one Bishop
takes F3 Queen H4 might be coming Bishop
takes F3 Knight G5 is coming you
actually have to do something about this
yes you still have the queen here but
what do you do in this position with
white like give me a good move
yeah the fact that the engine suggests
you have to play rookie 3 is I think an
indictment in itself right because you
want them to play like Knight G3 right
this is the most absolute natural move
you want to get this bishop out of the
way but it's hanging the bishop on D2
right Bishop takes Queen takes Knight
takes E2 thank you for the bishop right
you if you don't play that what do you
do Rook D1 just pins your knight that's
ugly yeah and queen of six uh comes in
and at some point what we were
describing earlier like Queen F6 Rook
from A8 goes to like f8 and then we
start going G5 G4 and just very soon
yeah very soon G5 G4 exactly Splat there
is nothing good about black White's
position it just similarly to Wesley's
it's not so much that it's a minus blah
blah position for example when mahmed
yarov had a minus something similar
against alireza we weren't calling the
game for mamad Yaro if we actually just
said all right well remember it has a
huge Advantage but it's very complicated
a lot of things can happen and we still
we're calculating furiously for both
sides in this both both games one this
one between Iranian and nepo and alireza
currently against Wesley it's the fact
that you have the advantage and the game
plays itself it just plays itself for
black everything is going to go on the
king side you're gonna push your pawns
and what's going to get mated so white
starts to need to find unnatural moves
like for example by far the top engine
move rookie 3.
to just to survive Rook 81 was played
which is more human but after Queen F6
you've run out of moves you just don't
have moves the top engine move here
Bishop C1 allowing the Knight to B4 but
just adjust something better it's very
difficult to even find something that
doesn't drop material you can't put the
bishop on D3 because Bishop takes F3
just wins the game right Bishop B1
doesn't do anything this rook's already
in the E file if you if you play after
Queen F6 Knight G3 then I take and if
you take this way I think I can start
yeah I just I just take your Pawn I just
take this guy
tasty yeah because C5 is also hanging
right I don't care about the pair of
Bishops I'm up two pawns right no this
is terrible
yeah oh my goodness clearly something
badly wrong has happened in in the
opening it's it's unclear what perhaps
as you were indicating perhaps he had
something similar on his screen with the
inclusion of Knight A6 and day three and
he thought there will not be any
difference but there definitely is yeah
it definitely is he's discovered it uh
black isn't okay black is more than okay
today today so far yeah Black is Black
is in control uh quick uh Gander at the
game between Lanier and Shaq because
there was a repetition after this novel
move uh up to this moment rookie three
uh previously played Bishop F4 and
others rookie three H5 yeah H5 took
about 15 minutes to play each the H7 H5
but that's where the Honda was pointing
out and in general in these types of
positions G2 G4 is a very very serious
threat I just wanted to show why because
because maybe for our viewers it's not
obvious why it's so strong let's say you
play H6 here
yeah we go we go G4 now the bishop has
to be preserved on this diagonal you
can't go to E6 because that abundance
yeah and now we go [ __ ] by two or
perhaps E6 followed by Bishop but maybe
maybe spray two first because I don't
want to allow Bishop F7 okay so we go
between two and suddenly this collection
of black pieces is completely unable to
stop E5 V6 yes and the 506 is something
you are playing for extremely extremely
often in these types of positions
because it makes your entire position
suddenly you know open up yeah yeah yeah
and this is the this is the it's not the
G4 wins material it's specifically to
lure the bishop away from this diagonal
so that you can land the 5v6 blow and
this is why H5 is such a it looks weird
right yeah not very often you play H7 H5
with that on F3 right because if it gets
to G5 you will not enjoy your life very
much especially as H5 also happens to be
a tender at H5 but it has a very very
sound positional positional
justification so the repeated Bishop A2
Bishop P6 and I just wanted to ask you
on this one Peter Bishop takes E6 are
you recapturing with the F Pawn or
you're recapturing the queen I'm not
sure I think if we can take with the
queen we'd much rather take with the
queen and we're not really like Rook D3
we'll win the E5 Pawn back maybe even
immediately I don't even need to take on
D3 first right right this seems fine
yeah even this seems fine fecx is maybe
slightly more ambitious but I would be
uh a bit worried about breaking up my
structure on the king side first okay in
any case uh Lanier said no no no I'm not
interested yeah there are people a
couple of times and he made a way to
move Bishop
replied with a kind of a waiting move of
his own G7 G6 and by the way just kind
of like uh David bronstein had this
wonderful expression in his practice and
Theory books about the candidates the
the the famous book he said like the the
the pawn on age 5 was kind of like it it
forced the needle and the thread it
required to move G7 G6 a needle and the
thread but defends upon on H5 how would
you sum up The Rook E3 Novelties it
brought linear great success I wouldn't
think so like optically white is not
white has not really achieved very much
we're still not really rounding up the
pawn on D3 very comfortably it's there
yeah it's it's still there we we have
been
forced by Vans to play Bishop C1 dito
which is a horrible move but it's also
an indication that our pressure against
the D3 Pawn has been you know lessened
to to a degree I think at some point
black might become interested in just
taking on A2 placing the queen on E6 and
then perhaps playing a6a5 and some kind
of advantageous uh version because the
issue for black here and I think the
only real serious issue for black in
these types of positions is that Knight
on C6 which has no moves that you would
call moves like right it can go back to
B8 but right but it definitely needs
it's its job hitting E5 and so on and
the way to solve that issue would be to
play a6a5 precisely and and to break
that structure open if and if white
needs to take on A5 which you know I
think in most cases they will like for
example King H1 the soft move if you
will maybe even immediately yeah a5ba we
take with the Rook absolutely and then
after the trade only six has been
provoked uh the night the Knight will uh
essentially lend on the A5 Square you
have to calculate because now white has
take stakes and very very importantly
Knight D4 for this one move 94 before
becomes available I otherwise when black
is right or C7 C5 even then yeah
everything is completely low one or two
moves away from making the D3 Pawn a
monster so it it always involves precise
calculations you you have to be careful
not to blunder something in those types
of forcing uh forcing sequences but I'm
not a very experienced open Spanish
player I I it feels like my my compass
here is uh glitchy so perhaps perhaps
you know linear understands it deeper
and maybe white has something but to my
eyes black is not really doing all that
poorly at all we have our Northern Star
in studio Alejandro to guide us to the
promised land Alejandro what's going on
with this Rook E3 novelty the engines
hate Black's position hey I just hate it
there we go I don't know why I've been
trying to play around with it like why
doesn't hate it I'm not entirely sure uh
but it is a plus one advantage from
Rookie three zero zero if you see zero
zero here both with the move A5 or H6 H5
I was not in love with but I thought it
was okay but it really hated G6 like G6
was to move it hated and I'm trying to
figure out it's because you lost a Tempo
you gave yourself a weakness took around
us I haven't figured out why it hates G6
so much the engines think after I let it
run for a little bit the takes takes
Queen E1 is particularly powerful in
this position wow the idea is that you
go Rook D1 Bishop's C1 and you're trying
to collect this Pawn on D3 without
giving up the pawn on E5 for example
before you played Bishop D2 you could
have taken here nobody really takes with
the pawn you take with the queen
obviously and after Rook takes D3 this
one E5 is always hanging so you want to
defend it with Queen E1 hold on to that
position you don't have A5 in this
position which is a very common resource
because I take twice and go Knight D4
and like that looks pretty ugly I don't
know if by that point you needed the
queen on G6 ah
this may be at least
right that the queen might have to go to
G6 to defend the spawn on D3 and now
that you don't have this Square you
don't have A5
so why White's plan is to Simply play
Queen E1 Rook D1 Bishop C1 take on D3
and the engine doesn't have a like a
great idea against it because the moment
that you move the queen somewhere active
let's say queen B3 to harass my
structure then you have to contend with
E6 and at this point your king is
unhappy about what's going on on this
side of the board you have to sidestep
with F5 Queen F1 is one of the moves
that the engine is saying again taking
on D3 and it's just not a liking Black's
position already thinking that G6 is a
major mistake what was it suggesting
instead uh it was suggesting to play A5
immediately or to just take on A2 take
on A2 and play Queen E6 so I assume that
since this position is more or less
playable
I'm gonna play Rook D5 and time in this
position can I play A5 here
no Wi-Fi is not playable again again the
same idea so D4 yeah yeah I I it just
wants to go Queen D5 and hold on to the
position this way if I play Queen E1
then you play A5 so yeah we need to
sidestep this idea of another 3d4 with
Tempo I think well if we try to you know
translate Engineers into uh into English
yeah we we do need to play 6a5 and we
need to try to do it in such a fashion
that once we recapture an F5 with the
Knight eventually another 3d4 will not
hit our Queen only six with the tempo
and that gives us a time to uh yeah even
generate even taking taking an A5
directly even though it does allow the
move Queen A1 different stuff but even
this was preferable than the move G6 I
think it is because you're not going to
get A5 at the correct timing
thank you Alejandro for that I just
wanted to go to the Lavon game because
yeah we're following we're following
what the uh Alejandro was showing yeah
the the but this Pawn sacrifice looked
well he's yeah three played and uh
Alejandra was playing Bishop G3 first
I'm wondering if we can also take on D4
without even including Bishop G3 hg3
um
but yeah this is just extremely solid
you can take on H6 but then Queen takes
B2 I think is borderline winning for
black because both Bishops are hanging
and with the Rook on F7 the bishop on H6
generates zero threats like we're not
really worried about very much there uh
and if you do that if you don't have
Bishop takes H6 you are just genuinely
two pawns down either C5 or B2 or
honestly C5 and then B2 and uh they're
all they're all hanging yeah they're all
hanging there it's interesting that but
I mean GTX F3 is such an ugly move
yeah I know I was wondering if maybe
this is like a better practical shot but
laughter like let's say maybe these
forces like takes the two Rook takes D2
okay I guess the reason he didn't do it
is that we couldn't G5 might be winning
a piece here right followed by a five or
four oh oh yeah yeah yeah well but even
if this didn't exist even if let's say
the best blackhead here is a move like
g76 and then Knight before oh I see yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah this guy is here
excuse me it's just like structurally it
is just so unbelievable affordable that
yeah as a chess coach you just beat your
stupid like what do you do what do you
do and and Bishop everyone is one of the
one of the you know most stylish players
and not only in terms of shirts warrant
or rounds like GF I think did not really
occur occur to him very much at all but
okay once again why did we include
Bishop uh it takes G3 we have to
calculate Knight of five here I assume
but aren't you walking into a nasty
nasty pen probably a Queenie five or
something yeah 25 might just be winning
right 25 threatening H2 threatening the
Knight
I was even thinking Bishop H2 I want to
win sort of more I I want to be greedier
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah my point is I
want to win more than just a pawn there
just yeah 25. well okay so I don't know
yeah I think we can take probably as
well yeah no particular reason why this
should be bad
it should take say five Queen takes C5
looks lost I mean all of this looks lost
Frank yeah like
uh maybe we're only one up here but this
is like the Knight only four is still
alive it's I think the most important
thing yeah
a live anchored and well indeed I mean
uh well uh when we lose the base uh
London Bridge is falling down very very
bad looking uh game going on here
um once again let me just go to this
this one is by far by far the slowest of
the round yeah right when we left it
more or less around these parts Bishop
B2 castles Bishop E2 yeah five we took
on D4 uh once again seems to be a
novelty yeah rookie 8 has been tried
Bishop B8 has been tried here but the
hd4 I think is a logical move because we
were always sort of worried about ideas
of G5 G5 C5 and this this takes it off
the menu for exactly nothing's default
very logical 95 H3 I think is a good
move to stop specifically I think Bishop
G4 more than more than anything else
because that Bishop on C8
is as is often the case in these types
of structures the one piece that black
really doesn't doesn't know what to do
right he would love to take off the C8
bishop and the YouTuber if you could
manage that or provoke f2f3 yeah both of
those would be I think very very welcome
for for Fabiano here okay so I'm very
much in favor of playing H3 in these
types of structures yes and then the
game continues kind of quietly yeah
white continues bringing stuff into the
game blood continues bringing stuff into
the game Queen C8 now played by Fabiano
kind of hinting that if you do nothing
maybe we'll play Bishop takes H3
and I think I don't think we want to
talk about that
I would take the man at his word I mean
I don't see Bluff written over Bishop
takes me like take time out to play if I
could play King H2 and F4 at the same
time you might have to because if you're
playing King H2 here I have a kind of a
cute little move Bishop C7 right which
creates a thread of Knight takes C4 and
then D6 D5 discovered check that's fine
which is kind of funny which which might
actually provoke up to F4 here but I
think a four is a bad move I think F4 is
very much part of the plan here for one
that no this works by the way I'm not
sure I've really seen that particular
pattern before
it's pretty cute but I actually wanted
to play exactly only square is on G6
yeah and then we play I don't know
Bishop G3 or something yeah your
restraint is admirable sir I mean those
of us who have been raised in chess
cafes around the world you know would
want to would want to toss the patties
with G4 and G5 I'm not against this at
all
I'm sort of mildly wondering if it
allows a perhaps a peace sacrifice
that's why we would welcome because the
position is not attractive and at least
we I think that the bishop first to
force you to take
everything because E3 will be hanging
right this way I get my queen to G4 I
see I see I suspect it's not that good
but honestly I don't like five
Exposition in general so so loud it
might be uh introducing some degree of
Mayhem is something I think I'd be
looking at okay so uh that well maybe a
slow boil but it's certainly heating up
and again I want to turn to our Marquee
matchup yeah there's been a game that
could determine yeah let me let me check
for a second the grandchester and the
singfield cup Wesley is also uh half a
half an hour ahead on the clock so up to
Bishop B5 after the move
he spent
uh six minutes on Bishop D2 and then he
spent about 10 minutes on Bishop B5
uh basically no time at all 10 minutes
on this move yeah there should be five
uh no minutes
arguably a major major mistake already
okay after Knight H5 uh he spent uh
almost no time on Nike for five minutes
which we consider to be a big blunder in
fact yeah and now he's been thinking for
about half an hour but it's kind of too
late
right now it's like that Wily coyote
moment where you know you're trying to
reverse course as best you can because
we're looking at Bishop H3 and Knight F4
I think it betrays a certain it betrays
a certain kind of you know naivete uh
there by uh by alireza because he he
clearly kind of recognized he's in
trouble definitely one move too late
maybe even two moves too late you can
argue right uh and uh in the position he
has this this
I probably should cost him the game now
because and you look on six here as a
kind of a matter of course I was
wondering it like once I saw Knight C4
on the board I thought maybe we can sort
of extricate ourselves by playing Knight
D3 first okay trying to get it to D5 but
I think it loses to a number of things
first of all even if we very simply go
Rook 88 okay you play 95 because that's
why you play 93 right take Stakes I
think the simplest is just takes takes
only 5v4 here
I just don't see how white survives this
because we the Knight can't really go
away I mean there is 94 but it looks
lost even root takes D5 for instance
like 94 or E5 we're upon up and the
attack will continue exactly that's it
also instead of a 5v4 knight F4 is
probably quite strong that was all of
this just looks horrible feared the
mostest uh Peter I mean they're just
like I'm looking it's like time out I I
know that these these movies end really
badly I've seen I I've seen the script
absolutely yeah and this is why he's
been thinking for half an hour because
he has now come to the realization that
you know normal measures no longer help
he's looking for something that is not
really I am I'm not a fan trust me I'm
not a fan of White's position Bishop C1
Rook d8 Queen E2 is a way of trying to
stay in the game Peter Knight G3 okay I
I did this purposely to lure your night
there
three and then I have to calculate King
H2 right exactly exactly but uh okay let
me let me think for a second after after
Queenie two there because it looks
horrible but maybe it doesn't work I can
start with this bridge
oh I can start with which page
gh93
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's show this it's kind of cute let's
show this for I feel like Linus I need
my security blanket uh that's just
horrible and then we take one of three
and this is the thing I'm not even
really sacrificing materials
I'm sacrificing something for one move
right by the way we do have Bishop take
C6 B take C Bishop takes C6 after a long
thing but yeah how long up about half an
hour 35 minutes something half an hour
uh okay Bishop c6b yeah BC played
instantly of course but right I mean
yeah and we're back on the back of the
uh we have another move by the Knight C
takes yeah I mean he's gone for this but
we kind of we've calculated this one
thing we haven't calculated is Rook 88
Queen E2 which might be a slightly
better try but honestly I also I'm not
no I think it's probably the same like
the four queen of fun trying to get the
queen to uh you know some squares where
it does something but I get the feeling
that even here let's say Bishop page 3
GH Rook E5 has to be completely winning
like there's no way this is not made
exactly like 95 Queen E5 yes you have
Rook 81 now that the queen is on F1
we're not getting mated immediately
right this is why I was trying to make
this work Knight E5 Queen E5 and let's
say Rook 8g1 here right
but I'm still assuming this is
absolutely lost I guess it shouldn't
hold yeah I I mean I've seen svenes are
gligarich and other players making these
positional sacrifices for a night on
that part but I saw one very recently
where Magnus Carlson on the black side
and I think it was some online
tournament just what a masterpiece uh
this position has uh you know like a
train wreck everywhere it's just it's a
disaster you absolutely know how this is
generally how this generally ends and
once again this is just my first attempt
to find something exactly I suspect
there are stronger things available for
black exactly after Queenie too
we also considered Knight F4 without
even yes yes we can we can throw in like
the four prior to playing Rook 88 so
that those engines just don't exist they
don't even exist yeah uh Alejandro I'm
sure you're going to confirm uh our
suspicions that this position is simply
simply awful uh but is there a precise
way for Wesley so to get a decisive
Advantage no no every move is winning
every move is I mean you can even start
like this
that's how bad yeah White's position is
yes bringing the Rook to d8 makes a lot
of sense sure Tempo but who cares about
that okay I'm getting Checkmate you
don't need it you don't need every
single piece actually if their Bishop
takes H3 the best move is Knight D3 good
luck uh Bishop takes H3 Pawn takes H3
Rook takes E5 is just over you can't
even take back we can't even take only
four you can't even take on E5 this is
just Checkmate in two right so true it's
just it's just over like Bishop H3 I
assume he's gonna play this because you
don't resign right right uh and then you
go Rook d8 then you resign and then then
you're very close you have to find them
in 94 just to keep in the game Queen G6
and queen F3 and you're still survive
you still survive but it's it's pretty
ugly Bishop G4 is four so you're not
getting checkmated immediately
and after Queen E3 you'll still have to
find some moves to actually finish off
the game uh the engines say that after
Knight C takes E5 Rook 88 is a Little
Bit Stronger Just So that on Knight D3
you can take on H3 and reach these
positions or you can be more cruel Play
Bishop takes B3
Queen takes B3 what else this is still
amazing attack that's the thing it's not
about the pawn on B3 it's amazing it's
mate I mean Rook takes F3 is coming and
you just cannot stop it right and then
it's just it's just death
so that's why Rook data is perhaps a
little bit more accurate we need to
what's the cleanest
uh I went through the engine every move
is winning I think passing is winning
but Knight F4
Knight F4 was one h8 wins uh yeah Bishop
H3 Pawn takes yeah so that position we
were talking about is minus five I can
see on our screen yeah unfortunately
it's minus six but yes close enough it's
just you just don't hold this here you
can't you can't take 25 and win but just
Rook D2 it's actually even cleaner boom
boom your upper Rook can't defend
against Queen G3 or anything or anything
or anything right yeah yeah so
collapsing absolutely collapsing guys
1965 I expect for the air I think it's a
little more human than calculating
Bishop takes H3 immediately if you
realize that Knight D3 exists because
the moment that you see Rook date and
the only reason you don't play Rook did
is that you might not even be looking at
this Pawn
on B3 you might just be so focused on
the king side trying to Checkmate
immediately that you don't see it that
way but if you spot this and you're like
well why not just so winning right right
yeah I mean it's uh it's horrible it's
it's a very very easily identifiable as
being like generally you'll never defend
these types of positions like there are
some very strange age cases where for
some reason it's not immediately lost
lost but it doesn't look like one of
those well Alejandro's billing of this
game is the hundred thousand dollar game
got us all excited but it's really
really a one-sided game because well for
alirez it just collapsing in this
episode he just seems to have a didn't
familiarity Peter or something sometimes
you just get the wrong ideas once Knight
H5 Queen F6 was allowed
it's a terrible position he made a
couple of Moves Like I think he was
trying to play a quickly and also B I
think he probably must have known that
Bishop B5 exists he must have seen those
games the you know kids today like
alireza works all the time so I'm sure
he's aware of
high profile games played in this line I
think he was trying to perhaps confuse
Wesley with some new move orders and he
also wanted to play as quickly as
possible to perhaps you know put some
additional pressure that way but yeah
Wesley doesn't get very phased by those
tactics and you have to play like the
thing about Wesley is that you you
actually have to play really well
against him or this will happen yeah and
uh yeah currently I mean Wesley is just
sitting there choosing well so far it's
been a black day because if we also look
at the game between Lavon and inepo nepo
is made a harvest he did he'll be he'll
be too too up in a moment yeah C5 is
also falling well he did capture on G3
and I I guess that was the most accurate
move he followed up with Queen takes D4
and you were just about to say C5 is
falling everything everything is falling
yeah
it actually is cleaner yeah there is uh
the engine does agree that taking on G3
is is a cleaner weight than than
allowing that takes a five in some
positions he's gonna be down two pawns
and I think he wishes he was down three
so he can resign with a clear conscience
yeah it's actually kind of I mean it
sounds cruel but it's hard to it's hard
to disagree
okay that that's going viral somehow
I mean you've been louded for your what
wonderful interviewing skills but
if I I could only resign if I was down
the third part I mean you can play
rookitsu here but I think the the cruel
thing about rookitu in this position I I
think I can still take on C5 yes and if
Knight takes C5 yeah
actually even the F takes E4 suspect is
winning right because I I know I was
gonna take that even wondering even
wondering when takes F7 changes nothing
in the position right because like if we
if we can put this on the screen we go
Fe we attack the White Queen We
seemingly have blunder Queen takes f77
Rook B2 and then we take on A5 and we
kind of look look our opponent in the
eye and say like why are you still here
one two three and the key will be yeah
uh and I know that movie as well and
it's it doesn't end well for uh White's
position so even blundering a whole
exchange uh could just seems Seems
horrible
yeah oh dear in a way this one maybe is
even more striking than uh than the
alireza Wesley game because and by the
way Levon you know he's he fought his
way back into the tournament he was
making a a nice impression if he will
for nepo especially the alireza Lost uh
he'll jump on some trampoline oh yeah
he'll be on on plus two after this game
if he does win it and uh yeah he
because Wesley seems to be completely
winning he will still not be in a tie
for first but he will be uh perhaps even
competing for some of the GCT money that
was that was my question
right but the interesting thing here is
like if we assume Jan converts from here
right he gets a Winner's interview
that's right he comes into our studio
and
you ask him do you feel like you've
played a game of chess today
I wonder if he will I wonder if he will
count this one because and I've been
I've been hanging hanging out with him a
little bit here that complained that he
sort of voiced on on air yesterday he
was definitely not making this up
because he needs practice a major reason
for for like obviously this is a
tournament is like like this is very
interesting in and of itself but also
for him to get some meaningful
championships some meaningful practice
before the match was definitely very
important right and I think for four
rounds in a row he did not get to game
play a game of chess at all like all of
those were theoretical draws pretty much
from from the beginning right but today
he was winning by move 30. like does
this count uh theoretical win I have to
move thirdly it's better it's better
than a draw for sure like it's obviously
preferable to to to to be to being a
non-game and a draw but also like people
just kind of decline decline to give him
a game day after day right so wait a
minute Alejandro we've got a win by
Wesley we suspect that's one win with
the black pieces we got a win by nepo we
suspect that's number two uh fabi's a
big fight going on the big fight uh but
uh
well okay Lanier is is kind of he's our
ballast the at least Lanier does have an
advantage with the white pieces he's not
lost no not at all
I mean you know he's going to spend
another 30 minutes trying to figure out
his position yeah right he's already
like a good thing for linear here is
that he can like make a move and then go
Bishop bishop
and gain a lot of time yeah so he he's
not in as horrible as horrible at time
travel as he might have been if that
repetition wasn't available right so
he's done this around move 18 and he's
also done this now with the inclusion of
Bishop D2 G6 as well uh I don't think he
can repeat twice anymore because Bishop
E6 will be a claim
well is it with the
for me was I I didn't understand what
Alejandro's Queen E7 I understood okay
Queen D5 I didn't understand that was
the because if you're gonna go no no
we're playing we're playing quindify
straight away we're not playing now
right but no no we're thinking on E6
then Queenie one
ah
okay so we're taking on e-cig as he's
done
he no longer has the the repetition
dance so and then you you were asking
about the move A5 Alejandro and then the
problem was that in this position we got
this Knight D4 issue yes very big issue
which is followed by six not not even
necessarily that the Poland D3 is
hanging it's just that we you know we
started giving mate on the king side
here exactly quite quickly and that is
why we play in this position Queen D5 as
a kind of a practice
in these types of structures is always
going to be a problem which Fabi has
done something very very striking by the
way we have a different uh take oh nice
mistakes
[Music]
on my board
why Peter oh
well because Bishop G5 simplifies in a
number of ways first and foremost I can
maybe even take on like it's maybe
slightly incorrect but weirdly I can I
think I complain I take C5 here even
uh Bishop thanks G5 is the only way to
continue I think I take on G3 Arc if
takes d8 exists right correct uh because
I was calculating 9393 I mean even that
position uh let's say you take on G8 my
point was I can play Rook d8 93 queen of
five here okay but it doesn't entirely
equalize because I've lost the A6 Pawn
along the way maybe I will make a draw
but like nobody really goes for this
voluntarily right but after Rook takes
D3 if we go all the way back to 91
Bishop G5 with takes D3 tell me when to
start yeah here I think I can take on
in some order G2 D3 and D5
you just choose whichever choose
whichever order you want uh I paused
because I could actually recapture with
the Rook I don't think it does anything
I think Queen takes is still going to be
stronger uh and now I take on D3 and and
I take 93 95 I think right because
rookie one Rook G8 shouldn't be good for
white at all
d8 here like maybe white needs to be
careful yes fair enough and so 95 Queen
E5 and yes there is a backward Pawn on
Knight C5 maybe yeah Knight C5 might
actually give white a little bit of
something here a little nibble one day I
might have to play B3 but at least it
might be tied down yes yes this is maybe
not nothing yeah this is uh we'll um
we'll keep eye an eye on this but let's
jump uh to Alejandro and see what uh
what's cooking in the kitchen
some of the variations you were going
through sure Bishop G5 gives one an edge
might not be the huge Edge that it is
given by the version you went through
entirely but it's still a good edge here
you have to take take and now the engine
wants to take 25 directly if you take
first and go like this this Knight C5
that you guys spotted it's actually a
lot more dangerous than you're giving it
at the beginning it is plus one
advantage this is an A6 Pawn that is
weakened the Knight on C5 is nicely
anchored game is not over by any means
but it is a nice little nibble here for
white but after Queen takes E5 it's
still not uh completely good for the
black side because after Knight F3
it's still the edges are still thinking
it's not such an easy ending if you just
go with takes takes Queen G5 yeah you or
queen E3 or both either
draw is probably favorite
but yeah that pawn on A6 is going to
continue being awkward exactly that
button A6 is just never going to get
better you never get A5 so the engines
are saying you know what that Bond's a
problem just get rid of it just go I5
immediately it's more important than
gaining back material it's actually a
typical idea of this variation of uh the
open Spanish where you just give up the
D3 Pawn but you get counter play in
return why because first of all you open
up the file for a rook you cannot take
with the Rook on E3 because if I will
always be hanging and if you take or you
allow me to take on before it doesn't
really matter either way you really do
want to take on a here take on 8 as he
takes before here I think even returning
The Rook to d8 and again using the fact
that you have a nice amount of pressure
the B4 is weak that E5 is weak and then
you have a lot of light Square control
the engines are saying black is actually
fine so perhaps this is the way to go
from ahmediar with the engines didn't
like 91 as much as Queenie one but it is
specifically because of the move A5 now
let's see if we have any updates on any
of the moves yeah Bishop H3 found and 93
of course played instantly by alireza it
is the only move not to resign uh since
C5 and H3 are hacking Rook d8 seems
almost nice I was wondering about Bishop
G2 here but I can see on our screen that
this is a mistake here
I'm blundering 94 I suppose every single
position it is a common move in this
position because I think now that
there's no point on E5 this will be the
recurring theme saving theme for white
that the bishop gets locked out of this
diagonal and that I can bring the queen
to the king side so Knight D4 is a very
important resource uh that's why I don't
expect Bishop takes G2 I expect Rook d8
to be played first uh let's see if Jan
has made any
not much happened yeah he did take on C5
immediately after rookie two we had gone
through some of those variations of
course after Bishop takes E4 yeah ge4 is
also playable yeah but as you mentioned
F takes E4 it is also kaput Queen F6
played and yeah it just looks lost A5
will be played almost for sure because
otherwise you lose the pawn but I don't
see where the hope is in this one uh
this is probably the most interesting
game we have right now
this is one between Hans and Fabi we did
get to this position after 496 and King
H2 and D5 is playable in this position
Knight H4 is playable it's a very rich
strategic position because there's so
many breaks for both sides here and Fabi
chooses a third option to move C5 which
I think is also very logical it's a very
fighting move it gives room for the
bishop it isolates upon and C4 what does
it do for white though it isolates white
black spawns as well C6 and B7 will be
long-term Targets on the other hand E4
is difficult to get in for white and
here Hans came up with a fascinating
move
Happy House let's go we're going to push
everybody on the king side try to make
this Knights unstable engine's really
hitting this position well you're
hitting this move because after Bishop
A5 with the idea of Adventure 94 they're
not so happy about leaving this King so
Airy let's put it that way
maybe not a bad idea maybe not a mistake
fully but they do like black a little
bit more after the the move G4 because
of Bishop A5 or just h6a really what the
G4 accomplished because after I play H6
you can't really play G5 on this Trader
structure that way the queen is guarding
on the fifth rank so perhaps a little
Hasty here by hunt
impetuous youth absolutely youth is
basically well I mean uh I would I would
be sort of agreeing with you
wholeheartedly if not for the fact that
you were pushing yes of course
G4 three minutes ago yeah so I I've
changed my effing
um as we go on break one amusing thing
that has taken place uh uh between our
previous breaks it's not a protest but
no Hans Neiman needed some you know
additional support and I tell you guys
uh he got that he should get that yeah
uh we're gonna go on break as oh we've
got the fan girls check it out check it
out out and there's not one there's not
two there's more than there's four
there's four so uh thank you ladies for
showing up and showing your support for
Hans we do appreciate it as we'll see
you on the other side of the spring see
you then
[Music]
hey St Louis the Ascension Charity
Classic presented by Emerson is back
this September don't miss the excitement
when the PGA toured Champions best
compete again all for charity September
9th through the 11th at Norwood Hills
Country Club Pro-Am spots Hospitality
packages VIP tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
if you have kids you already know St
Louis has a ton of fun stuff for
families to do like the magic house or
the science center and if you really
want to be a stellar parent come see all
the new stuff there is to discover at St
Louis Union Station with a new Mirror
Maze light shows and the 20-story high
St Louis wheel it's enough to make any
parent feel like a star
St Lou is always exploring
oh
we're the Corey family Welcome to our
show
[Music]
[Music]
you guys
[Music]
St Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of St Louis Sulu
attracts students and professors from
around the globe
in 2015 slew partnered with the St Louis
chess club to start a top-tiered
Collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the team's Inception slew
obtained second best university of the
Pan-American Intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose greater good
St Louis University
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
of the single cup and while we were on
break some very unexpected developments
happened in the uh the main by far the
main game of the round Marquee matchup
yeah the game between alireza and Wesley
because four four feels like years now
we've been discussing how you can not
give Wesley a sniff of an advantage
anywhere because he just never lets go
if you give him if you give him a good
position it's the commentator's curse
Peter the moment we've been louding him
for his incredible accuracy he's made
two howlers
howlers is maybe a bit too strong but
it's it's unexpected to see him uh not
find what uh what was the best play here
and I think while we were debating this
I think I figured out why with the help
with the help of our trusted machine
please the line that Alejandra was
showing in the line that we we showed on
there a little bit was Rook 88 here yes
the most obvious move of course the only
reason you don't play it is because you
realize 94 exists yes but let's continue
the why we play Queen G6 threatening
made on GTA we have three strictly the
only movie you can make bishop G4 once
again Queen E3 is really the only move
you can play here no other squares are
available for you lady and let's say we
go Bishop B6 here obish Play Seven there
might be a difference but it's
irrelevant to the point I will be making
in a second sure so now we're looking at
C5 C4 exactly we're threatening C5 C4
and for a second there I thought
probably he didn't like the position of
the bishop 3 because if white actually
manages to stabilize uh these Knights
yes and and stop C5 perhaps trade of the
bishopon B6 right will be doing quite
well this mission is minor save though
because Rook takes D4 uh she takes D4
Bishop takes D4 queen of Queen takes D4
Bishop three is basically made right
which I think is missable and this would
be perhaps an explanation for why Rook
88 has not been played onto the board
because if you if you don't see that
that position is bad for white if you if
you don't realize tactics continue past
the point where it feels like maybe
tactics have run out you can choose
something else because it really doesn't
feel it has a certain how do you say
flow that all of these moves look really
forced and and like you say it's very
easy to get here and perhaps it's very
easy to miss Rook takes D4 like if you
give white to Tempe here or even one
tempo to play or maybe you have to F3 or
Bishop C5 as we've been saying whether
it be F3 or Bishop C5 I like Bishops C5
actually just do it again to kind of
keep the D5 and and now really it
becomes it becomes very much a game
which you can lose with black because
white structure is pretty solid there
are those two beautiful nights in the
center if I get to play F2 F3 my king
side will also be quite safe yeah it
becomes a very very unclear position for
perhaps this reason Wesley played the
new Queen G6 threatening made on lunch
before the only way Queen G5 Knight
takes D5 and in this position he also
made a mistake which uh at least at low
depth the engine doesn't really agree
with you can start with rookie G8 here
which is pretty much forces cleaner
three we think yeah Bishop G4 once again
pretty much forces Queen E3 and we take
on H4 here and
compared to the game position this is
much much more favorable for black well
uh we can get a version of this if
alireza uh plays Queen F3 now I think we
basically transpose after Knight C5
Queen H4 if they also chooses to play
Queen F3 here we're going to get a
version of the same or maybe even
exactly the same I think the problem is
you can actually take on H3 shockingly
right now
which which I did not expect but
seemingly white does not get mated after
GH rookie 5 and let's say Bishop C1
Rook E5 yeah and the library G5 check is
probably going to be lethal but either
the immediate Bishop C1 or perhaps Queen
F3 followed by Bishop C1
uh and I have a sacrifices this is not
fate yeah this is not made Queen G4 is
going to come in Queen G4 yeah Queen G4
now that we've covered the G5 Square we
are now prepared I think quite well to
uh to start dealing with the threats and
yeah Queen G4 yeah and this exposed king
is not a non-issue huh well it is but
it's all I'm saying here is that this is
an absolute at least an unbelievable
improvement over what we have we had
seen earlier okay and you can definitely
imagine this being uh being survivable
for uh for Ali resin wow wow uh a huge
huge turnaround in this Marquee matchup
Alejandro
um and again just commentators curse we
were talking about Wesley's accuracy how
badly has he blown it I mean he had a
big Advantage currently
zero zero ah
it just hates both of last moves and I
think it's token H3 I was just looking
at the camera I just went off right yes
GTX H3 is the best move in the position
now rookie five is probably the most
logical one because you do want to play
Rook G5 check and you want to take the
Knight Bishop C1 is one of the most
Queen F3 as you mentioned Peter also a
good one you could take on C5 uh don't
have Queen G4 in this position you do
want to cover this but after Rook G5
sorry Bishop C1 preventing Rook G5 you
can play Rook E8 or something slow
Black's better in this position because
let's face it your pieces are active
whites aren't but you have to Queen G4
the queen actually has to retreat if you
want to keep the advantage and the game
just kind of goes on
after G takes H3 Rook E5 we also have
the move Bishop C1 and if you play Rook
takes C5 the engine is so unafraid of
your threats that it even plays the move
Queen D4
catching The Rook catching the rook in
the center of the board thinking you
either play Queen E7 and defend it or
you just give me the full rook and
somehow this is a Perpetual because if
you go to E2 Rook data is still a drop
Queen D3 is Checkmate and otherwise I
just got Queen G4 Queen H3 right so
Black's making a draw here but after
Bishop C1 you could consider the move
Queen takes H3 uh just continuing the
attack this however represents a full
peace sacrifice and you start to have to
consider very different difficult things
because Rook G5 is not a threat and it
doesn't seem like you have generated
anything immediate sometimes Knight G3
will work forcing you to take take kind
of if the Rook can swing to H5 it'll be
winning but when for the moment Knight
D3 Rook date is bad Bishop E3 doesn't
work because I just take on a C5 and
this overloads uh the bishop oops so you
still have to defend the Knight somehow
they're just saying that you have to do
it with the pawn and after Rook ae8 the
game continues the engine wants to play
down a piece but thinking you're never
really in danger because you have this
weakness of the king and that's white
that has to find the draw still so this
is what I expect GH3 Rook E5 and then
alireza with a big decision do you play
Queen after 3 which certainly looks
safer or do you play the more ambitious
Bishop C1 not ambitious in the sense
that you want to win ambitious in the
sense that it might solve your problems
immediately
thank you for that
Alejandra really kind of stunned uh
truth be told about this sudden shift in
the position because I saw these moves
Rook Dade and Bishop takes H3 and they
all look like they were just going to
play themselves and it was just going to
be over before it started and now it's
wow yeah you can definitely imagine this
yeah like objectively as we've just
heard Alejandro explained this is this
is not really uh at all bad anymore it's
it's just a playable position for once
for white it's still a scary position
for white because you're right
definitely in particular those Queen
takes H3 variations because here as I
was saying like even let's say if even
if the queen D4 is kind of funny right
but you did say queen H3 Peter sorry no
I mean after Rook C5 sorry I did not see
Queen D4 I did not expect that to work
but even if let's say if I make my move
Queen G4 Queen G4
we take take Knight F6 I do I will have
to shed some pawns but let's say even
let's say I go F3 here uh Rook C3 rookie
three right I'm not sure I'm not sure
I'm doing that poorly because the
structure is completely broken up the
bishop on uh like the iPhone F6 is very
restricted if you trade the opponent six
will be weak if you play Rook C2 I will
play Rook D3 assume control over the G
file start playing which before Rook C1
and so on yes I'm not culture of
entirely equalized but we are definitely
talking right now about positions which
could just not be better for black
anymore yeah uh which represents an
unbelievable swing from uh from what we
assume the game will look like after
Knight absolutely a second life if you
will for alireza as the tournament
flares Anew Wesley with a win today
would have propelled himself into plus
three knocked the Rival down the most
important driver yeah well that would
leave nepo uh on the outside looking in
but on the other hand nepo is now two
pawns up Peter we left the position more
or less around here has uh
Lavon managed to find some cheapos or is
it well but he is playing on the fact
that the knights are sort of connected
to each other through so this uh he is
he is trying to uh you know create a
situation where they they have to get
decoupled and it might it's in some
cases cost black some material but I
mean for now it's seemingly a very
healthy uh two bones up you can return
one you can play 96 here and say you
know if you want yeah if you want to uh
to break apart your Bishop pair you can
do this and I would say play Queen of
five here and try to play c65 and uh I
mean it's an improvement for white here
only one down now instead of two and
right perhaps there are cleaner
Solutions but even in this position I
wouldn't really like in a practical game
if I had this with white I would have
very low expectations of not losing this
okay and uh
besides Knight E6
g43 is fine I think D3 Queen E3 sorry
rookie three and then you can find a I'm
pretty sure find a good quiet move here
Queen 24 25 something yeah okay and
again that's the two pawns uh in the
other game between Lanier and uh A5
husband yeah Chuck understands the the
open Spanish really really well A5 and
Knight takes Pawn takes this was the
kind of positions that uh Alejandro was
saying yeah they're discussing this yeah
you know you're upon up but you know
this Pawn's weak uh this one's kind of
weak uh black got ideas absolutely
Bishop to G5 and so on and lastly the
Fabi game what has happened since oh
yeah before this one is very interesting
this one is uh the the least defined I
think you know of all the games today we
left it with Bishop A5 yeah couldn't do
three and five we just snapped on C3
here just to uh really secure the E4
Square for the night Han stuck with the
queen
I'm expecting 94 to happen because of
this is what we were playing for so why
why wouldn't we just exactly and then
the idea is that we could shut down the
long diagonal but also I mean the queen
will have to depart along diagonal so
we're not that worried anymore the queen
has to go to Island on B3 or seed so
which one do you like better uh
I got issues with them yes I realized it
too late
yeah but then I've got other issues
don't I Rook A2 and then we go Queen B3
or queen then it makes a little sense
that uh okay I'm not sure I like this
with white anyway yeah like Queen B3
here
well it really feels like this move G2
G4 lifting the kimono you know that was
protecting our King uh as suddenly uh
rebounded and gone against uh Hans in
this particular game
still if you let's say we after 23 we
pause and we talk about structures for a
second right okay
put the Rook back and just talk about
this position in general terms like if
white gets to play let's say Bishop 3
perhaps drive away from the knight from
E4 perhaps white gets to play Rook d1a1
uh solving the issue of currently we've
we've had to abandon the open a file
right and black guys has full control
over it for the time being white has the
two Bishops white has definitely the
healthier Pawn structure
yes black arguably has a slightly safer
King
but uh long term and in terms of for
instance end games I think white is
quite happy here so this I think becomes
a very very concrete game of the next
few moves and as I say this in this
position there's a very cute move oh no
it doesn't work sorry I wanted to say
Knight E5 exists yeah uh Knight E5 yeah
fe5 Queen E5 but then I realized I have
blunder Rook F4 otherwise maybe it would
have been an interesting try and it is
it is a concrete position let's not try
95 you don't have to switch to me but if
you go Queen B4 in this position what do
you play exactly question for the bishop
Peter I think this is awkward yeah this
is very awkward I heard everything you
were saying you know Pawn structures two
Bishops control of the center
more activity but I'm also looking at
that King on H2 and King position is one
of the five elements you know time
material space and so forth uh Queen B4
puts a question uh it's a very awkward
one because if you play Bishop A1 Rook
A3 is extremely painful it feels like
yes you have to start you have to start
giving up uh stuff in the center Bishop
C1 at the very least allows Knight C3
and there might be I mean Rook A2 might
be even stronger yeah it just feels like
I'm losing I'm going okay too with the
idea of Knight C5 winning the queen
hello
because we typically have no squares for
the queen anymore and actually 95
immediately might be winning the
exchange right instead of Rook a two we
can also go Knight C5 here we do allow
Queen C2 but then we have Bishop A4
which is our hello
previous movie oh here it doesn't matter
yeah okay so okay two is probably
Stronger Yeah Yeah but but again this
sudden attack that you're exposing on
the pawn on E3
um
which all leads me to the to my final
conclusion I mean which is after Queen
D3 Queen B4 I don't know yeah black is
the one yeah and one final thing there
is that please maybe you would like to
play Ruby one there
after Queen before yeah but because the
king is on H2 and not on some other
Square we can go 92 and Knight takes F1
will be a check
exactly against for instance Bishop C3
which would have been quite a strong
move but Knight F1 is a check so this
costs white an extra an exchange before
I play it yeah before on the board any
accounts will have to play carefully
here Hans only has one move
one move let's see if you guys can find
it you haven't mentioned it yet well
Bishop A1 just too ugly for Words uh no
Queen B3 too ugly for Words Right queen
I'm pretty sure it costs us material
exactly two or something and there's
Bishop A4 in those positions as well
yeah uh whoa whoa whoa Knight F5 no no
no no just no Bishop F3 no that's check
on B2
sorry yeah I I once again I feel I feel
extremely sad because you know when
Alejandro is talking I feel like I
should be sort of I can't keep proper
eye contact but I can keep eye contact
with his screen but then I see answers
and uh like I'm I'm letting you think
because unfortunately for me I am going
through the answer I'm going through a
listing and I've got it shows how hard
it is right shopping list is really yeah
low uh yeah you have to use the fact
that the Knight only four is not as
protected as everything else in this
position no I don't want to play F5 I
just don't know you're playing in like
no active moves exist but you have a
very good move inside here on Camp here
no kidding yeah
jeez I gotta tell you guys this at night
B3 I don't like we can play Rook A1 here
what oh because of Rook A8 yes
but I gotta tell you if this is nothing
this is going to save me
that's on the lower side of my shopping
wish list moves because yeah and it
probably still costs you the E3 Pawn
right after Knight C5 Knight C5 I can
take on no I can't no you can't take on
it you have to play Queen somewhere and
I think wherever you put it I think I
will be able to win the E3 Pawn but it
may be not enough to win the game though
I take take you just take stake Stakes
on E3 yeah
I mean it's good it's a very important
point I'm very happy I have won it yes
yes and also no I think maybe why
they're supposed to go for some kind of
an end game like Queen C3 I think with
the Queens off the board this may be
more manageable Queen C3 we take on C3
uh Bishop takes we take on A1 and then I
take maybe with the Rogue and give a
check from A8 or something
and those types of end games I think
maybe you can imagine not losing with
white
I want to imagine myself not losing them
but I'm not so sure my imagination well
I mean if you have to play rookie eight
like that I do have the two Bishops I
think my compensation will be decent my
question is what do we do against night
of Fate which is not an easy move like
playing Knight f8 into the pin of The
Rook on A8 so if it is a bit weird but
at the same time it's the active rock
or something and claim that we have
activity we've actually sort of
stabilized our pieces and how reasonably
well connected F5 here take away more
squares yeah I can imagine this being
manageable a salvageable or not easy so
again it's a black day absolutely all
across the board as shax seems to have
uh uh got exactly the type of position
that Alejandra prescribed for him he's
shed upon but the two the the double
pawns the fact that this Pawn on E5 is
very nicely blockaded you've got ideas
of Bishop G5
to further reduce material that looks
quite okay I I think so anyway Lavon
yeah Levon is still is still shuffling
because he he played Bishop before uh
Jan replied with Knight A6 probably
using uh you know some very very similar
ideas if you take only four twice I'm
probably the plan is very similar like
Queen of five C5 C4 and we're winning uh
or maybe even the immediacy five in some
positions might be playable because
Bishop takes you five Queen F5 might
cost you a piece right uh but yeah he's
just gone back 91 uh and yeah and young
is as expected sort of saying that
connecting my Pawns in the center is
more important very uh attractive
preserving both of my extra pawns yeah
exactly please give me one of your
Bishops uh I think in Practical terms
I'd rather play maybe bishop A2 Bishop
C4
and try to maintain some kind of a
blockade and all that yeah yeah
I mean uh very very nice back to our
Marquee matchup and uh Alejandro take it
away uh
has Wesley
really blown it oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
I mean otherwise is fully back in this
game dang I mean we have a three years
old game in our hands here
we left it off at GTX H3 and I thought
Rook E5 was gonna come so many threats I
can always take on C5 with the Rook
he gave a check immediately like he was
in a hurry G4 takes C4
let's analyze this position
yes king is not super safe you can even
start with move Rook E6 on the other
hand
how's the structure it's a little weird
B3 is weak but so is the entire Queen
side especially A5 in the long term
imagine we get any end game A5 is a
terrible Pawn I'm gonna be able to
Target it so easily and how do you
defend it this Knight is so far away
from the action you want to put it on F4
but you can't you can't Retreat to F6
upward Knight
I don't know guys I
see Ellie Reza winning this one with a
couple of more inaccuracies by Wesley
they just say zero zero as usual but I
don't know if Queen G5 is the first move
I'm thinking of here I get it you want
to get the Knight back into the into
play but I've been attacking for so long
I've been attacking for a while do I
really want to trade the Queens if you
go Rook E6 Queen F5
rookie Sixx to me is the first move I
look at yeah but this is annoying it's
just annoying you go checking H2 the
screen is defending F2 I'm not worried
about that Queen D6 is met with Bishop
E5 and we play King of flan because I
would like to play King of fun if it's
possible being F1 also possible Queen
now has to retreat to keep some kind of
initiative because if you go into an end
game as I said well now I'm getting the
Rook now this is going to be weak Rook
is coming to E5 who's playing for a win
here and speaking of blowing it
oh wow
minus 0.3
yeah I've
this is a completely different game live
on down to 12 minutes but let's see what
happened in this queen we left it off
here I think we need three D4 Bishop
beef but Bishop B4 Knight A6 and we
thought about this move
but this is lost because of C5 at the
end very nice little cute idea if you
take on C5 Queen F5 Forks the rook and
the bishop and if you take on D4 it
looks like you're hitting the D7 rook
and you're forcing me to take and I can
take with the bishop but actually Knight
takes C5 defends The Rook Q so you're
not able to do that instead after Bishop
E1 you could repeat here as nepo just
played Knight ac5 Bishop B4 back uh you
could play Just Knight C7 Retreat the
Knight it's not as easy as it used to be
but no big deal but after C5 which looks
logical and tempting to just push him
baby G4 this is I'm taking this pawn and
that's the anchor Square for the nine on
e4 and if I lose that anchor how do I
progress because these are two Bishops
your king is a little bit unsafe and now
you have some tactical problems and the
engines are far from impressed with what
nepo has done to his position now let's
go down C4 could be possible right one
takes I hit the Knight you don't have
time to play D3 because Rook takes you
don't have time to do anything except
move the Knight out of the way and then
Bishop A2 suddenly I'm targeting your C4
Pawn not so easy to defend guys
I can also see this being a three result
game the main issue for Levon more than
the position is that he has 12 minutes
left yeah but only for 10 moves they
actually blitzed out of a long sequence
at some point and uh it's not as panicky
as it could have been but yeah this is a
an unbelievable Improvement considering
that unbelievable yeah he was down two
for sort of no discernible compensation
from right from the beginning yeah very
very uh interesting development I think
over the course of this event we've
always talked about these the 2800 guys
as being incredibly resourceful and
finding uh ways of getting out but also
we talked about them it really winning
one position here I mean especially this
game of Wesley so this move with Queen
G4 I I you know the the
uh pardon me this idea of Rook E6 just
looks so compelling at first glance
Queen F5 is a kind of a cold shower
absolutely I mean it just like stops you
because the desirable takes takes I
don't know you have to be very careful
now with black light exactly exactly
with black suddenly I mean the the the
advantage shifted so greatly after Queen
takes C5 and we were really I'm amazed
at Rook 88 hadn't been played ages ago
sorry ages ago like there was a number
of times where Crazy 8 was clearly the
best move in the position starting from
maybe even before Bishop takes H3 I
think you do need to see Bishop takes B3
for that one but normally like on a good
day Wesley spots it in three seconds of
course and we're so used to him uh you
know recognizing those uh even so easily
Even In This Moment Rook a a to d8 here
is very compelling and then even and
evenly enough right the third time in a
row here yeah just start start with 28
here you're still better even though
it's unclear obviously the fact that the
bishop on C5 has been removed off the
board uh makes you changes a lot it
makes your attacks on the king side much
less potent but yeah it's just been a
strange game I think Wesley it's been a
strange day yeah and and the day as well
yeah sorry that was me that was that was
our analysis uh answering rookies if you
don't play rookie six here Peter
um yeah 100 was suggesting Queen G5 but
that's just such a difficult move to
make so you you really want to play yeah
that's what it's all about I'm sorry
please but yeah it's a concession yeah
but also very simply and games are
extremely extremely double-edged now
with the pawn on A5 yep so spending a
full Tempo here on forcing an end game
does not feel
yeah it does not feel that great like
you you might come to the conclusion
that you must do it because everything
else is weaker simply but
I I don't think you're doing this with
any kind of a particularly
enjoys cheerful feeling uh look yeah
um can I suggest bad move I mean and
really of course whenever I see a bishop
1 B2 I am loathe to play such a move
because I but I'm just stopping this for
the time being but then rookie 6 does
nothing right you've taken also a square
but rookie six uh Rook aviate played
guys Rook ABA Rook AB8 why why did my
engine just go plus 1.5
what yeah it says E5
it's going on the line guys E5 Rook B3 I
guess is the plan but because Bishop D4
wins a piece right 54 wins a piece
specifically because after Queen takes
C4 which keeps Taps on the bishop on D4
I just moved my Bishop back Bishop B3 oh
that is so missable
that is so but that's a piece well but
how many pawns I get four okay maybe you
don't lose but like F2 is extremely
solid I only need two like when the game
is over I only not one I mean one I
can't speak right right like I don't
need to I just one needs to survive at
some point right okay five rookie C1 now
this is horrible this is a good Pawn
this is a very I mean like four is kind
of weak like I think the way the game
might continue here something like
rookie C1 yes Rook Edgar C1 yeah and
then Rook H4 right Rook C6 will be
before
and I'll draw this and we hope that f2f4
doesn't work and if and if f204 doesn't
work we will make control I think three
against one on one side is reasonably
comfortable but if it works
but by the way that that's a that is so
easy to miss Bishop
but also I want to ask like if I start
with rookie three here if I don't spot
this as white if I go rookie three here
am I doing so poorly I guess the idea is
now we play rookie six and queen F5 is
no longer anywhere near as good because
well spotted I'm pretty sure this is
what why Wesley included Rook B8 because
yeah he's hoping for rookie three rookie
rookie six I think the point is like
rookie 3 is something you Blitz out
rookie three is it's a good move B3 go
on something it needs protection in
general it's just a good Square for this
Rook it provides additional security for
the king side it might be shifted to G3
later right so you kind of assume rookie
3 gets played right and then after
rookie 6 suddenly
you don't have a particularly
comfortable immediate defense against
Rome G6 maybe you play like King F12 or
something yeah we might be back to your
king and then black and play Knight of
six and continue you know creating
little ideas and and be better but once
again
pardon me once again E5 E5 the light is
hanging if you play G6 you run into a
full steam into e506
and you know this is a very very unhappy
position for black suddenly
I do you complete the G5 it's been F5
yeah but then F5 Queen G5 yeah but
they're like I think we just go into the
end game and we play Bishop C3 in the
end of the end game that was the ending
that um
that's very nice but you guys are
missing a chemo move before E6
if the queen could get back to the
defense we're talking about okay Bishop
default first and then three even
stronger oh whoa whoa what civilization
do you want to go to
I mean you got to go Ace yeah and then
after E6 you just get mated actually
yeah it is
stay away from this one it's just and
the evaluation after uh E5 G6
Bishop A3 is plus seven like
unredeemable dead lost
seven seven seven
so after E5 it is absolutely forced to
go into that end game like there is no
choice it's clear Wesley's missed it
Rook takes one three Bishop D4 clear
Queen takes E4 only move Bishop B3 clear
we got this far and let's see how bad
this is because the engines really do
hate it takes takes you could take on H5
it's not forced the Pawn's not going
anywhere but how bad is it Rook takes H5
the problem is that after Rook B1 or for
something like that get one one pair of
Rooks off get one pair of Rooks off the
board I think this is important and if
you take take you can always hold on to
this Pawn okay with my Rook but this
guy's gonna have to be guarded so for
example if I play Bishop D2 or something
you're gonna have to defend this Pawn
somehow and since I have two pieces and
you have one I will eventually capture
it probably the engine draws this with
that miraculous play I don't buy it I
cannot imagine a human drawing this
position I think that if valeresa plays
E5
Wesley doesn't hold this wow yeah it's
extremely possible that the Wesley ends
up losing this Mission which is
Unthinkable really things
a hundred thousand dollar uh swing
yeah this one is continuing slowly but
in in our Neiman Karana game Hans
actually did not find rookie one he's
played Rook B1 which is just a straight
up positional piece of our exchange
sacrifice you mentioned that one yeah I
guess he goes Bishop C3 and then he
takes on F1 maybe with the bishop and
tries to take on B7 next thing is too
long in my opinion it was something you
you had mentioned even night night C5
also very playable here I don't know
which one like you you have to compare
because okay night here Bishop takes
takes
yeah Quincy oh there's Rook A2 check as
well yeah we can we can throw and locate
the ship I'm not sure this is great for
white anyway yes it's not lost
immediately like optically it feels like
a position that uh I mean definitely
gets played out but maybe not even that
clear all together because the king will
be somewhat safe on G3 we have some
positional compensation The Rook on B7
will be active and so on well I have a
feeling I understand why Fabi is
thinking but this might be a very
interesting time trouble
uh and the alternative to a knight D2
Peter's just not C5 yeah
which feels like a very very uh nice
extra point maybe preferable actually
because yeah wherever the queen goes and
I think it's got to go to see frequency
too though maybe this is why he has not
played it here Queen C2 and if I I don't
think I can take only three here because
Bishop C1 actually wins material
yeah
um something about Queen C3
just a second just a second hold on
Queen C2 I've got Bishop A4 also yeah
let's go Queen C1 I mean it's ugly but I
would like not to be down material if I
can if I can actually remember that true
that
um
Alejandro our our
shining star uh uh help us here do
should Fabi uh be greedy and grab the
exchange or not I have an engine of
course they're greedy they want to go
for whatever gives them the most
material they don't believe in this comp
at all Knight D2 Bishop C3 take on F1
you take with the bishop and now you
insert this check it's a nice check to
insert first and the reason is that you
guys were really said it the King on G3
would be very very nicely placed but you
don't have it in this position no
because of check
no and the queen takes Queen B1 white
resigns therefore because of the
sequence the King has to go to the G1
Square now the game is not over Queen A4
the engine say is the best move just to
keep the queen in a position where he
can penetrate on the a file or on the
light squares Queen C5 is also okay
although it thinks that after Rook takes
B7 the game is far from over there's
only a minus one advantage playable
let's call it that way but definitely
better for black now the other
alternative Knight C5 also very strong
Queen C2 you could go Rook A2 and bind
uh the position that white has in the
here and I think that's very strong but
you could also take on C3 and after
Bishop C1 you go Queen C3 and it's
actually a counter sacrifice you could
take but after taking this King in very
dire straights Knight takes f4 on top
knight on D4 is hanging the Knight on C5
is absolutely beautiful Bishop on E2 is
absolutely garbage so you can see the
power of the pieces and this is not
really an acceptable position for the
white side the engine's saying minus 1.7
you let it think it grows and grows and
grows so after Queen C3 you probably
just have to trade the Queens but this
is a free Pawn for the white side for
the black side white does have some comp
because pair of Bishops and this Knight
on D4 is not bad and well there is some
pressure on B7 but it is a pawn so this
is why Fabi is thinking because he has
two very attractive options he needs to
know which one to go for the only thing
is he needs to make a decision soon the
more he lets his time run the better the
chances are their hands in some kind of
complication can trick him 15 minutes to
play still 15 moves of what should be a
complicated game coming up thank you
Alejandro and talking about coffee yeah
if I've played by lariza alireza plays
E5 but the complexity of the levona
ronian game after G4 G6 was uh nepo's
answer to that one what do you think of
that Peter uh I mean it's completely off
for you know I will do we off the rails
for black yeah we take I mean the
simplest would be just a take on a five
and then take only four twice like
bishop and rook and thank you very much
for trading this G3 Pawn for your G7
Pawn we're still down upon but the now I
think it's very easy to make an argument
that maybe our our King is actually
safer than the one on G8 uh I mean black
probably I think Jan is intending
something like Rook G7 here to at least
address the fact that it's already in
some checks this is just a straight up
completely unclear position I think uh
like Queen B3 check or Rook D3 first if
we're not blundering something right but
uh we have left made uh left made a very
left-like move this is a very very
stylish little move I don't know if it's
any good but it's a very level like you
like this Lavon from the mind of the Von
eronia yeah
um Queen takes it I don't know if I like
the fact that we've allowed the pawn to
progress we can take on these three here
I think this one because there is no
between C4 check yeah I think Rook d353
Bishop D3 is cleaner and you cannot take
once again because that costs us uh
costs like a full Rogue exchange yeah
it's a cute move I don't know I don't
know if it's as good as the very very
simple recapture on the five and D4 but
it's well let's see okay so I can't
exploit the move with the move D3 should
I be worried about this guy
um
I don't know my issue is
maybe
96 is good 96 nights no this no that's
your three I don't I don't like uh
trading the bishop Yvonne is not very
impressive I don't particularly yeah but
opening up the D file yes okay
well my point is please GF I can take
maybe even nine maybe yeah Knight or or
the pawn oh but and if you take on H6 I
wanted to go Rook H7 and claim that we
can kind of reclaiming we're claiming
that you know the the turns have tabled
and gotcha and now I want to play Queen
h4nx move and claim that maybe I have I
I'm the one with the attack on the king
side suddenly I don't know yeah F3 still
exists this is not really hakimati but
yeah but this is now a very very good
example Wesley played G6 guys
is one good move away from whoops from
being completely winning from from
the singfield cup one good move away
guys it's a move that I think is a very
very easy to miss because the bishop
kind of you you feel since you're
playing E5 V6 next pretty much always
the bishop really feels like it should
be on the long diagonal but I think the
moment you spot the Move [ __ ] Play 3
exists you instantly realize how strong
it is because
removing the queen basically from the
game entirely by driving it to let's say
B6 here right and then going 60 I think
it's very very obviously just a huge
Improvement to the immediate compared to
the immediate uh E6
guys it's the tactics Bishop A3 and E6
is just tactically gone uh our bird's
eye view well at this moment it's very
hard to tell if Wesley even is aware
no he's not aware of the move if he was
aware of the move he would just not play
G6 yeah right this has not crossed his
mind
he's he's definitely worried yeah I'm
pretty sure he realizes he's lost
control but he doesn't really realize
maybe until until now just how much he
lost control here yeah I talk about that
Peter for just a moment because you
mentioned something really uh Salient
here I mean in our minds as Grand
Masters we have this uh hard wire to
keep our Bishop on the long diagonal
especially especially when the pawn is
on G6 we just think that's where the
bishop belongs on this long diagonal so
this is not the obvious move that our
training has taught us we see it because
we just drive the queen to a lesser
Square I think the trick here is just
for your mind to suggest it to you and
it's it's entirely possible in
particular because I think he seeks is
very playable I don't think White is you
know worse after 36 I would maybe even
still think I'm playing for a win here
until you see Queen G5 or queen no even
there like that then game we were
discussing uh ef ef King F7 and I don't
think I don't particularly like taking
on G5 let's just go C3 here just Bishop
C3 and remind right away what we're
dealing with with Bishop takes A5 yeah
my feeling is if anyone is playing for a
win in this position it's probably white
right uh and uh there is a must note he
was in desperate desperate trouble until
until then oh there it is Bishop A3 on
the board guys
yeah he he wants to play 65 this is the
only way he thinks he might not be
losing but it gets busted very easily
like very easily so let's do it Bishop
A3 on the board Queens already played
now E6 the threat's up so much you have
to play C5 just to give yourself the f8
square for the king basically after ef7
uh and queen D7 check I so far have not
found how to win this position take take
okay Queen D7 king of Fate Queen D5
resign oh just oh very very simply just
Queen D5 and win yeah I was looking for
something more spectacular because yeah
no spectacular yeah especially not when
there's a hundred thousand dollars on
the line just play the simple winning
move Queen D5 that's it there's just no
defense Bishop C5 is coming yeah you
yeah this yeah the moment you realize
how how horrible this looks here you
kind of stop calculating
so simple yeah Knight F6 Bishop C5 King
G7 but if all else fails we can take on
B6 and only five like we can actually
switch back to playing the same game
only we're not two pawns up and
continuing to grab right what's that
especially the 695 man which is probably
five without you a take on A5 and that's
the entire Queen side and that's
probably the very inaccurate way of
playing yeah like there's probably
something that wins on the spot wait a
minute an accurate way of getting
playing get you three connected pass
pawns for free yes yeah
sign me up where do I sign yeah it's uh
oh it's amazing yeah these six on the
board and Wesley so has spoiled what we
think was a completely winning position
not more than one hour ago and now uh
he's losing I mean he's in pole position
for the sinkhole Cup victory
now is now in in a driver's seat for
sure because he's a full position for if
he wins this one four position for
singfield pole position for Grand
Chester exactly it's huge and this guy
plus one guys
plus one level
got to this position he played King G7
took took I assume Bishop E4 is going to
be played I don't think you can resist
this for too much longer and as I said
that Rook D3 electron doesn't want to
take on e4 at all right he wants to
Checkmate this guy I'm not really sure
how he's planning on doing so they work
F3 is his idea yeah and going through
that Pokemon F3 yeah but the edges were
saying just take take take there's so
many Avenues open to this King Rook D3
can be played later Rook G4 is a threat
wow this bishop which has been lame for
a while prevents Queen G5 because of
Bishop D2 right it all comes together
very quickly but Rook D3 it it's zero
zero but it's still you would feel that
white is the one that has the threats
because you count the pawns two extra
pawns for black and it's not giving any
advantage
that's kind of the giveaway right Peter
when you're when your computer your your
coupon's up and the computer says no no
no nothing's happening Rook D3 did that
spoil it uh basically what you're saying
Alejandro was Bishop E4 Bishop takes E4
Fe cash your chips in you have Advantage
no question about it Rook D3 weirdly it
kind of comes back to the earlier
conversation about uh perhaps Levon uh
having in his Mind's Eye some positions
with the Knight on A6 uh instead of an
iPhone B8 very early in the end game I
think one of the reasons the position
after which before in rookie 4 is uh so
good for white it's not even only that
the you know just gfgf taken E4 twice
yep
uh one of the reasons why it's uh it's
good for white obviously the first and
the first the most important one is just
difference in King safety right but also
there is this Knight on A6 which is very
very far out of play is kind of Tethered
to protection of the Pawn on C5 the B4
square is being controlled by the bishop
only one so you can't really bring it
back into the game and
yeah there will be would have been a
huge turnaround and yeah uh for the the
alireza Wesley game is hurtling towards
its conclusion seemingly because EF
Queen D7 already played there's nothing
else there to play apart from King of
Fate I'm guessing Wesley is simply not
at the board because King effect hasn't
been played yet right
otherwise he has he is at the board he
just played King takes episode yeah okay
no king is actually already on the face
on our screen yeah Queen just seven king
of fight and others is searching for
spectacular win for for something but
yeah I mean as soon as you realize that
your Rooks cannot really be I was
looking at something like rookie three
here just to try to open some files for
uh 25 is easy but yeah what is it he has
choices I think rookie 3 wins Queen H7
definitely wins
Queen H7 also also of course makes
perfect sense just start picking up
stuff
uh because the the equivalent V6 cannot
abandon the pawn on C5 he gets mated Ah
that's always yeah I was playing Queen
F6 in my mind's eye no and uh Bishop
takes C5 is Just Deadly not allowed but
yeah what community five clearly is sort
of far in the way though yeah and the
cleanest it's on the board what a what a
turnaround uh undefeated in the
tournament was Wesley so coming into the
game yeah today's games his accuracy his
level of accuracy I saw from a chess
based report by Frederick Credo was more
or less off the chart I mean like just
incredibly High degree of accuracy and
then just like a sequence of moves Ali
razor I don't know what it is he turned
it around against uh chakriar I mean he
was just that dead and then in six moves
he just won
it's very very odd to watch in
particular because I mean like what
Wesley Wesley in particular Wesley just
like this doesn't happen to Wesley yeah
this is extraordinary this is what were
our predictions
ah yeah I think uh there's going to be
there's going to be I know Alejandro
he participated for three rounds yeah
we're going to give you a participation
of trophy that says for three rounds
Alejandro look at this guy look at this
guy who could have possibly guessed yeah
Anastasia and shambles
today yeah she thought she won she won
the whole thing very very easily I would
like to uh give VAR a great deal of
credit because uh his boy is back in
business yes it's amazing amazing uh but
Queen D5 guys I think that just seals
the deal for yeah
if you don't play another six I think
you genuinely lose like the entire chess
set because well like nothing else
really saves any material as we were
saying like after Bishop C5 King G7 the
suspicion has to be that there there
might be a move here which means more
than Bishop takes B6 but why do you need
it right just take on B6 take on A5 you
want to include rookie eight you can
include rookie8 at any point I don't
think exactly
yeah because it's not like you're
anxious to allow The Rook uh control the
e-file either it's just absolutely
absolutely lost there's there's nothing
left to play there amazing just
absolutely amazing yeah truly
wow uh history in the making here as uh
if alireza ends up winning both of the
uh summer season tournaments St Louis is
going to be his favorite City
he kept on saying that that he's been
his dream to play in St Louis and yeah
if he had to win a tournament if he
shows up and sort of at the first time
of asking wins both right that's uh I
mean he hasn't won the tournament so if
if he wins this and I mean Jan might be
back with some winning chances now like
I don't know as Lavon let things slip I
the moment the commentators curse the
moment I loud it's unclear but black is
still two pawns up like you can
definitely imagine black winning this
position it's still zero though yeah
it's it's not better for black
apparently but it's a kind of a not
better which you definitely like you
make one mistake here with white you're
probably entirely busted straight away
absolutely I mean it was two pawns uh so
if if Jan actually ends up
returning to uh to being on top in this
game they will be tied for first without
a reson plus two above uh Wesley on plus
one with one round to go has um has has
Lavon captured on e4 no he took Rook
takes interestingly he took Rook takes
E4 in the previous movement not bishop
and he's now thinking which I'm which
probably means he is considering the
move Bishop p1g2 well isn't that NEPA
with the board thing yeah
let's play Bishop Bishop did two there
yeah very very cute I mean the one is I
think today today in particular like he
took first he took a template okay right
okay
yeah he is kind of going all in on never
making an obvious movement if there is a
non-obvious one available
uh he's definitely going uh with the
consternation here Bishop okay uh break
it down for us uh Peter I want to play
when I say 66. unfortunately you will
not allow me to play 1966 pointing out
the boring rules of Chess and things of
that yes uh yeah two two two moves it
takes you two hops to get there but the
night on A6 is really off-site I get it
that's that's my entire Point here is
that because that Knight is so far away
from the action this is why because the
king H7 really isn't that unsafe and
white did trade away many of the
attackers right and why they still do
central past pawns now hello yeah and
the the fact that the engines don't
prefer this public even I think is
basically solely due to the fact that
this Knight is so far away right and
with without it in the game it's so
difficult to you know establish any kind
of proper coordination of your pieces
okay help me out I I'm gonna play for C4
I want to play C5 C4 and or Rook H3 I
guess and I wanted to shut down your
action
um
also fair I obviously I blundered that
but
um
Queen B1 maybe Queen B1
uh oh
I was on a roll for two whole moves
there a night before well I will I
should think twice and claimed that the
King on G7 is so unsafe I'm not even
that worried good point I think that's
yeah like the question is some move like
27 here and do I have anything against
it
again it's just the two pawns right yeah
but even I'll give which plays a 40k1 I
was for a second there I was interested
in which before G3 Queen G6 but I'm
blundering a queen and one rookie one is
a yeah so we go I don't know Queen B3 or
queen B6 and then Queen B3 gosh my pawns
feel like they're stuck in cement by the
way there is a queen B6 also you could
maybe tickle this yeah yeah you have
rookie six but maybe 96 is useful yeah
and then uh after F4 you drop back
um
that's probably why it's zeros uh
Alejandro is uh is is that what we're
looking at here in the game of yan and
Lavon after Bishop D2
it says Queen E6 Rook H3 F4 is not bad
I'm not gonna say it's bad right Queen
B1 the game goes on the night before for
example as you guys pointed out the
actual stop move yeah who needs that
pawn
dang yeah
I'm gonna you know I'm gonna air mail my
Grandmaster title back to the v-day like
that was not on my no I don't think it's
anybody's radar it just it just starts
evacuating it just goes that way it goes
towards the queen side king walk huh it
just King walks all the way to I think
it just actually goes to C6 dang yeah or
just attempts to go it attempts to go to
c-section probably don't get all the way
there but it starts running it just
starts running it just says take my H6
Pawn it's all about C4 and getting my
kingdom it's still a mess it's an
unbelievable mess yeah it's so it's
still a very very complicated position
in the meantime alireza has just decided
that I don't really even want to spend
any time searching and yeah Western just
resigns yeah yeah game is done game is
done game is
done-filled cup wow what a turnaround
incredible guys I mean this one was
Wesley's game in the back tournament in
the back grandchester in the back Wesley
just blundered away a hundred thousand
dollars right
yeah that that's a very very costly uh
costly turn around there in uh in this
game because yeah in particular with him
he's really not a very volatile player
no putting it putting it mildly he
generally uh doesn't lose very much and
he also doesn't let go of advantages
pretty much ever right and today both
have happened in like in the space of 10
moves he turned the minus three position
into a resignation right just what we
saw once again with shaqreer I mean Ali
razor was definitely losing in that game
in a space of six months it went from a
winning to a lost and this was probably
eight but it was just so uh stunning for
us is because
everything you know was set up I mean
Rook d8 yeah
I think if he sees Bishop takes B3 he
just wins this game very automatically
also something I've seen on my screen
let me let us check something for a
second it's not really very relevant
anymore not this position here like if I
go Rook d8 yep 93 okay even let's say
you don't see uh Bishop takes B3 okay
can I go Rook D3 Knight of four
probably yeah I mean because I I saw the
reason I'm asking is once again I'm not
that smart I saw that if we play Bishop
takes B3 just one second we could go
back for one more uh Bishop B3 uh we
discussed Queen B3 of D3 but there is
Queen B1 right and against Queen B1 I
did see that the engine was going
through the three Knight F4
Aha and then you said well why why is
the butter cake pan so so important
exactly but but the question then became
if you don't like look in that direction
at all if you don't realize Bishop takes
B3 exists anywhere can we just go can we
just do it now and just give mate
let's have a look-see I'm gonna try to
cover up my king but yeah but that just
looks like it should be lost right yeah
Knight F3 no you have Queen G2 there in
the end maybe it's not that lost maybe
it's actually uh not as not as clean as
I originally I mean it still looks very
attractive for black but it doesn't seem
stunning developing stunning
developments for us here on set as we
take a look at our results uh
Wesley so has lost his tournament bleed
and uh he lost it to close his rival so
far only one game finished and that's a
decisive game between our two leaders
wow and alireza goes to plus two and
Wesley drops to plus one which is a very
very important turnaround others could
still be caught in the sinkfield cup if
Jan wins his incredibly unclear position
against Levon which is definitely still
very much on the car as you can I mean
all three results are in play there
exactly well
um but that would make an incredible
finish for turn Morrow's Championship
round with two players typed at first
should as you say nepo uh win this game
it's it's been a topsy-turvy affair I'm
telling you Rook H3 Queen E6 that would
be uh
and queen D5 yeah
still has plenty of time levels down to
seven to seven minutes but it is more 37
they've been really rattling through uh
through the moves in this game so by the
way seven minutes is not that horrible
for that four in like three months as we
were starting our broadcast you had
mentioned that uh nepo lamented the fact
that his first four rounds didn't really
get him give him himself a chance to
show his true chest strengths this is a
game yeah he's definitely playing he's
definitely at least playing yesterday
this will be a full-blown full-blown
Game World Championship Match Game if
you will the kind of game you want for a
training yeah at least he's guessing a
proper workout at the very least yeah
that's what I yeah absolutely exactly
yeah proper workout nice nice
man who goes to the gym uh every now and
again every now and again Queen he said
this is on the board we are expecting
Rook H3 because like rookies three check
would be a move but why are we provoking
Rook G4 doesn't
and the stunner for us Peter was either
Queen D5 just go ahead and take my Pawn
Yeah I think it's specifically 25
because if you go king of seven you are
really advising Rook takes H6 okay and
if you play Queen D5 and Rook takes H6
happens I'm pretty sure we're not
playing king of seven I'm pretty sure
we're playing like Knight C7 or C4
something over there yeah yeah Queen be
one played instead guys Queen B1 yeah
yeah and that is that is another idea
that I was I was including Rook H4 sorry
Rook H3 prior to playing Queen B1 but
it's always going to be an idea here for
why it uh reminding uh Jan that there's
a bottom B7 that needs attention but
also maybe there's a square Queen B6 and
that as well that could potentially like
I'm thinking I I'm very happy to post my
queen on D5 right
I I defend the pawn and if you go Queen
B6 we do have rookie six and there are
no squares for the queen to right uh to
to get into the black Camp further yeah
I think 25 is a very natural move here
but which begs the question why does the
inclusion of those two moves those two
pairs of moves maybe it would be three
though ah Rook B3 thank you three and
then after seven we go Rook B6 right and
we I was searching for a justification
for Queen B1 I think you found it Peter
yeah Ruby three uh giving up B7 was
check doesn't really seem very
comfortable right so rookie seven I
think is sort of your automatic response
Here and Now Rook B6 looks interesting
at least right because now you're
combining The Rook Bishop uh to work
together at least we're basically
playing all of these variations of full
piece down right this night yeah again
just continues doing nothing in every
single variation that we discuss and
this is why uh this is a compensation is
so clear uh young has played 25 I think
Ruby three is very logical is time a
factor Peter Well levers on on a very
low clock but it's only I think two
moves to go now maybe three two low
clock meaning five minutes five five
minutes but I mean with only two months
ago it's not really such a horrible
situation and we have an interview so
let's go to to Alejandra who is with our
sudden tournament leader yes absolutely
over to you Alejandro in a moment yeah
we're we're still we're still in the
moment there but uh very very soon I I
still feel like I need some kind of
recovery after this uh extraordinary
turnaround which we but now now we can
uh we can finally start discussing the
very exciting game
here with alareza ferrugia who has won a
huge game alert so first of all
congratulations on your win when you're
preparing for this game did you ever did
I cross your mind that this might be
worth about a hundred thousand dollars
I don't know yeah all the games are
important here because there are a few
rounds
so eight rounds it's kind of like you
have to be you have to be alert every
round so
um yeah it was a very strange game at
the first he surprised me with A5 of
course of course I knew they moved but
but I didn't expect him to play normally
there are better tries of course for
black but he wanted to surprise me I
guess and yeah I think Knight bd2 B3 I
knew
and yeah Rook yes and here maybe I
should have played better I mean
the way I played I think during the game
I was under a lot of pressures and I
should improve here somehow some move I
don't know yeah the main move according
to the database which has been played
many times is Bishop B5 yeah probably
it's a better move because the way I
played I unders I completely
underestimated the Knight H5 move how
did you feel after this Knight H5 came
on the board yeah I felt kind of uh kind
of stupid because it's kind of only
moved if he goes back it's I'm better so
I mean to this happen right I mean he
cannot defend the pawn in a proper way
so I should have calculated this when I
played this kind of Bishop B2 Bishop B5
so yeah I underestimated the move and uh
I still think that I could hold here but
this precise play but it's very
difficult
so I thought Knight C4 is a kind of only
move Queen F6 is a very good move takes
takes 95 and Bishop H3 of course he has
this Rook d8 also here yeah what were
you planning to do again I want to do
like D3 and here it's very I don't know
if Bishop history works but uh I don't
know what how he has to play Maybe
Knight F4 Knight D4 Bishop B3 I was
thinking but I don't know if it works
there should be three well the engine
was suggesting to start with this move
okay Queen takes Rook this frequency
four this is what I wanted to play yeah
Rook F3 and then Knight F4 and it's just
everything collapses yeah no no no
frequency five now you can see five the
Knight of four anyway ah yes this is
crushing yeah
93 just a little bit too strong okay is
this losing or it's pretty much yeah uh
wow yeah actually the engines think that
you're already lost here completely
after Knight H5 can I how can I hold
here I mean I didn't try the Android was
adamant about Bishop A3 or B4 okay
trying to just get rid of it before yeah
I subbed before I should have gone for
B4 probably I don't think you should
have come for B4 considering the game
one yeah yeah and yeah but he was he
didn't think about the bishop takes P3
because he wanted only two mates right
right I mean it makes makes a lot of
sense yes so we got to this position
after Knight D3
um very important yeah what did you
expect here
um I I expected Rook d8 right 94 Queen
G6 queen of three Bishop G4 23 and here
Bishop B6 baby yes very strong yes
because I don't have C4 Bishop D4 Queen
D6 this is what I blundered oh C4 yes
yeah if I have C4 C5 I'm better but I
blundered Bishop D4 I was calculating
this bishop D4 yeah D6 this is very
fascinating you can also start with uh I
think if I remember this correctly you
can start with this yeah because there's
Bishop of three in the end as well yeah
okay yeah anyways winning but I have
some defense maybe after Bishop B6
Bishop A3 maybe huh by three and this is
where it comes yeah this is this is the
one we thought before
wow that's crazy
same idea yeah I am no okay this is then
I'm losing right after Bishop B6 I mean
you're you're losing here yeah yeah yeah
you're losing after Rook yeah there's
just no defense but you got a little bit
of a breath of Hope after Queen G6 yes
here I'm still worse probably but okay
at least I'm playing and Knight H4 only
move yeah all the moves or only move I
guess I didn't see better try Queen G5
yeah Knight C5 yeah here actually we
expected
again yes ah queen queen of three and
Bishop G4 just pick up 23 Queen H4 yeah
yes okay
yeah but after Queen H4 yeah GH rookie 5
doesn't work I was thinking a lot about
this what did you calculate I wanted to
go Bishop sivon at the end I couldn't
find version here yeah Rook C5 Queen G4
and just bail out I mean yes takes takes
then Knight F6 and just F3 or C4 or C4
C4 maybe I said let's see if I give up
the G4 problem but then Bishop with four
yes
and I think this is still Maybe
I'm not better but okay I'm playing it
yeah it's very unclear the engine's
thinking that this was unclear also the
queen D4 wasn't clear surprisingly just
catching The Rook okay but what you said
was just as good okay okay I missed
Queen before yeah so after he goes Queen
G5 check Queen G4 he takes on C5 he goes
C4
what did you expect from him yeah here I
felt it's very tricky getting tricky for
him but I thought B8 is correct actually
and he could go for these four pawns
against the peace position this is what
I thought
and I don't know I think it's round
equal that one because it's okay rugby
three Bishop D4 take special E3 takes
takes rookie five takes takes and uh
first I thought I'm winning with Rook C1
but he has Rook before which is very
strong because I cannot take Rook G4 I
lose yeah oh that's nice yes
so yeah so then maybe after the Rook
before 29
then I no no sorry instead of Rook C1
and then I think it's round equal Rook
D3
or Rook C3 I don't know and The Rook B7
okay I'm a little better because because
of the phone on A5 but I think it's
foldable for black yeah we were debating
in the studio if I was holdable or not
the engines do think it's a very large
Advantage for the white side so Rook B8
you expected you thought he was going to
go for the four Pawn end game he plays
G6 right no this is very bad right well
what did you think yeah I thought it's
just complete when I saw Bishop first
when did you see Bishop by three yeah
then he played and then I thought about
one minute then I saw we show history is
just over I think he has to go before
even yeah actually they all lose yes as
much but did you I'm sorry when you play
the move uh when he played the move okay
beer and he played E5 you did not expect
him to play G6 no he said he has to go
for Four Points all right right but he
but you hadn't seen Bishop A3 no but I
felt that after G6 are meaning I mean uh
maybe at first I thought okay I wasn't
still in the mood of trying to bailing
out so I said at the worst case I could
go E6 Queen G5 and go to this end game
so I was happy already so this was and
then when it appeared on the board that
I found Visual History yeah and then the
game is pretty much over yes there is an
incredible turnaround here of events for
you going from losing to winning in a
crucial game St Louis you're lucky City
yes yeah it's still a very big game
tomorrow of course against maxim of
black so
um it will be very interesting I think
Leon is also winning so well he was but
uh I do not know if he is anymore they
have reached move 40 this is a crucial
game for the standings absolutely uh
actually how would you evaluate this
uh but before that was completely
winning right yes absolutely Levon had
no move
but yeah somehow we got this okay this
could go other anyway right I mean it's
like my game actually because the phone
on A5 could be very tricky at some point
that's right it could be Queen
but guys join the conversation
Ali raise it first of all uh
congratulations quite the turnaround
today quite the turnaround uh from
chakriar as well
um
just uh
that you've won from a losing position
right
yeah yeah uh what are you doing uh
you're hypnotizing your opponents
they're somehow I'm getting lucky that's
if they don't be precise I have been my
position has some Dynamic it somehow uh
of course against charrier was a very
bad blunder so
um yeah it's it's a strange but okay
somehow sometimes in this turn of
tournaments you have you get lucky so
um yeah what can I say it says there's
there's no there's no luck shaving on
this show yeah
we've all been recipients of very very
good luck
um big game tomorrow against MBL how
have you done in the past when you've
faced mvl yeah I think we have many
draws
um I don't remember if we made even one
win or lose but okay we didn't play much
I mean we played some I think a pigeon
bucharesto
oh you see between Bookers
I already forgot
I lost that in at the end right yeah
yeah that was a strange game but yeah in
general
um he's a very strong player so
um we will see what is going to happen
tomorrow there is a huge game tomorrow
we'll let you prep for that one
congratulations on your game thank you
definitely uh definitely congratulations
wow as uh young 19 year old surges into
the lead in The Sinclair Cup and the
grand chest tour as well oh yeah wow
here's a situation in the in the in the
overall standings for the tour has
improved tremendously absolutely uh
obviously the the the singfield cup as
well but if Yan wins it's going to be a
straight shootout seemingly uh between
those two in the last round it's
Championship weekend for a reason
absolutely yeah
young winning is nowhere near a given
it's not this position really is very
unclear uh the one that livon and young
are currently currently playing tell us
why uh Queen C1 I think we were looking
at some ideas of just uh yeah you know
abandoning the East H6 pawn and maybe
has gone Rook G6 first which I also sort
of like because I think you want to
provoke G2 G3 or something along those
lines
and it also prepares the some additional
squares perhaps for you to run towards
if you like including F6 f606 G7 and so
on so yeah I don't mind Rook G6 uh I
thought we could start running already
I definitely thought that Queen C1 like
in all the variations we've been
discussing it felt that the pawn on H6
is by far the sort of the least
important thing exactly it's amazing how
least important it is and Rook h36 on
the board did live on no pardon me it's
just a 40 so time control foreign
between F3 and G3 we are probably
preferring F3 pretty much every single
situation because it controls more
Square come on there's a reason he's
played Queen C1 and Bishop D2 and Rook
H3 let's take that Pawn King of six
let's say and let's put the pawn on it
exactly but I mean specifically the the
choice between F3 and G3 I'm leaving I'm
leaning F3 in pretty much every single
situation okay I still very much won
that night only six though can we play
97 and Away you go I really really want
to bring it over to E6 because I think
that solidifies my King's defenses just
so so much
removes removes a lot of potential
checks removes a lot of potential danger
just uh all together and then we can
start once again thinking about playing
C4 C3 and winning the game on the
Queen's side this is a mess like I keep
on thinking that black has to be better
but I I thought about I thought that
about positions which Alejandro has
informed us weren't better at all so I I
no longer really trust myself in this
game well folks we're gonna take a short
break here as everything to play for in
this penultimate round but as we go on
break we're going to leave you with a
special Anastasia caught up with some
support
fans of Hans demon I'm sure you're going
to enjoy the clipping we'll see on the
other side of the Sprite for exciting
conclusions
[Music]
hello girls it's really nice to see you
here what actually brought you here
today to Saint Louis chess club
we're uh out here uh supporting the
tournament that's going on right there
inside we're especially here to support
Hans
um we got our fun little signs here and
uh yeah just out here to show our
support we love him I appreciate some
Buzz for the tournament in general you
know we it's a beautiful game and not a
lot of people know about it so we just
wanted to get some excitement going
outside of the tournament chess is not
dead
absolutely not so that's for sure right
so would you like to make a surprise for
him today for those that you're here or
not I don't think he knows that we're
here so I really hope he comes out and
sees us and sees that he's got some fans
out here
um we haven't met him but we're really
hoping we get the chance to so
waiting
[Music]
hey St Louis the Ascension Charity
Classic presented by Emerson is back
this September don't miss the excitement
when the PGA toured Champions best
compete again all for charity September
9th through the 11th at Norwood Hills
Country Club Pro-Am spots Hospitality
packages VIP tickets and more available
now at Ascension charityclassic.com
we all know St Louis is a championship
Sports Town from the 11-time world
champion Cardinals to the Stanley Cup
champion Blues
but I bet you didn't know about all the
championship places there are to get out
and play here like the World Chess Hall
of Fame Westport social and Topgolf and
now even our own MLS team so whatever
Sports your team is into you can always
bring out your A-game in St Louis
oops sorry St Lou is always exploring
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to our coverage of the
penultimate round of the singfield cup
with all the three games still ongoing
uh two of them uh have reached a
somewhat dry endgame stage okay and one
also doesn't have very many pieces left
on the board but you can call it
anything but dry basically and that's
the game which might determine will
determine if alireza is a sole leader of
our tournament with one round two or
shared or shared unless the game where
Livonia onion on the white side is
trying
to defend what was I think entirely
self-made horrible trouble straight out
of the opening and at certain points
today Levon already was doing very very
well but it seems like uh as things
stand right now Jana is back in control
and very happily for uh Jan's fans the
Knight is now only six yes something
I've been desperately calling for for
the past ever since the night was on
Asics personally I'm just so happy uh
during the broadcast
the break of the broadcaster discovered
the chess is not dead chess is yeah yeah
we there is hope for us now you were
saying as we're coming back on break
that there's only two checks uh take us
through the position check I think we
have to play King of King F7 because
King E7 Queen H7 check doesn't really do
very much at all we have to go back to
F6 right and now the only check is from
H7 right yeah we can just go Knight G7
here and the fact that the the threat of
Queen takes G2 mate is just stronger so
why pro probably plays G3 here okay I
haven't figured out exactly how we win
with black uh because Bishop takes G7 is
a bit of an annoying thread because then
the F5 Pawn will fall if you just
recapture clear but we can we can use
the ladder to get the queen all the way
to maybe maybe we just win the F3 Pawn
with checks right so maybe this is
two queen E3 and so on
so maybe maybe we can't actually the
ladder stops there yeah we need Queenie
to check in this position but it's not
available so yeah I remember now because
this is where I kind of got stuck okay
if we could get to like E1 in two
squares we would be winning very very
comfortably but I don't see I don't see
how we get there right like one yes and
then specifically King F2 and in this
position I'm not allowing maybe G3 is
winning though I can imagine D3 being
winning somehow but it's uh
it's very touch and go yeah Bishop G7
the good thing about this is that black
always has the Perpetual of the
community always yeah but if you want to
play for a win you will have to at some
point give up on a five maybe you play
like Queen E3 check here okay uh to
defend C5 specifically King goes
somewhere choose a square I guess G2
right and I think on G7 I play King of
seven
and there's currently no threat no no
checks after King E7 right
that is true but we're also not
threatening very much apart from you
know cleaning the Jeep on and two moves
from here right maybe giving white a
Tempo to play something like Rook H4 for
instance
then you get checks and I get G3 assault
yeah so so this is a very very very like
early approximation of what you have to
calculate here wow wow but something
tells me that uh I've got I I can do
better for nepo Yeah by asking Alejandro
yeah
my guiding sir
uh Alejandra is nepo back in control
back in control indeed and vigilance to
pawn grab
Queenie Jay check yep Knight G7
check 97 yep and now we're looking at G3
just so you know I made it don't get
made it and just take this guy what oh
you're hitting E1 suddenly so if you can
do this and I go check and you do this
and I go check and I do this and I go
check I use the ladder but backwards I
get to a position where I'm defending at
five okay and once you go here I can
think
and do your worst and do your worst
check King E7 I start running towards
the king side Queen side yeah uh yeah
that side and it's just it's that's
probably the other the other king side
yeah right nice minus five is what the
engine says if you get all the way to
this position so clearly there's not
very much it doesn't say minus three
already in this one so the edges are
giving Yan the knot that this is a
winning end game that there is still
some problems to be solved because
there's a lot of checks your king is
Airy but eventually you should be able
to solve them and Yan should take the
full point after a long fight which was
longer than it needed to be wow really
does feel like this game is about twice
as long but when it's all said and done
it will feel like it it's maybe twice as
long as it should have been uh if he uh
was slightly more precise around the 30
minutes but how often in our careers
have we done that we had a completely
winning position we let it all slip away
and then slowly slowly we climb our way
back in the game and we're winning it
all again and you know we've had this in
a way yeah in a way it's not actually a
poor feeling at all like if he ends up
still winning this game you feel
terrific yeah he will not feel too
despondent at all because in in some
weird fashion he basically won two games
in one day against an extremely strong
opponent like yeah he beat livon
basically out of the opening through we
assume some kind of a you know wrong
page stuff one of those one of those
things where livon thought he was
repeating some preparation when in fact
he wasn't no uh judging by the outcomes
yeah it shouldn't have been preparation
because yeah and then he let it all go
and at one point I think the engine was
even preferring the white position for
for a very short time somewhere
absolutely
Bishop takes E4 Rook takes E4 we kind of
let it slip linear uh with his very nice
novelty rookie three got an upper hand
one upon in fact against Shaq but at the
certain moment we thought that Shaq had
sufficient compensation now looking at
the position black is doing his utmost
to just try to hold and create a
fortress it's all linear it's a two
result game leader absolutely yeah this
is but this is the thing about the open
and I've had experiences like this uh in
in my own career like one of those games
I apparently I'm destined to make
references of every single day on this
broadcast I think in vike maybe 99 I
want to say I had a game against Vichy
in those years I still had hopes of
eventually beating this
I somehow outplayed him in an open
Spanish and I got a position where even
more than than here I just had an extra
Pawn only five
and uh very nice and I think it was
maybe Queen and rook and this dark
Square Bishop against Queen and rook and
dark Square Bishop I didn't have even
have uh doubled pawns on the B file
everything was entirely safe in my
position just take the knights off the
board and and the Firefox but this is
the thing about the structure is that
you badly badly want to play 5v4
yeah oh like yeah you badly badly want
to take this Bond and pull it back one
square and open up this diagonal yeah
because weirdly uh the black Bishop
pretty much always is at least slightly
more active and slightly more
participating in the game only seven
than wherever the white Bishop is
because the white Bishop is very
restricted by white zone Pawn structure
right and that
even if there are no weaknesses and
there are maybe some slight weaknesses
here even though linear currently has
all of them completely covered Blick is
never entirely hopeless in these types
of positions because you have this very
nice blockading Square on E6 in our game
Against the Machine Queen was there okay
uh for because there was no night for
for shock it's even better here because
a knight has an absolutely perfect
perfect position for uh uh four is only
six things chill yeah yeah C6 is
seemingly a bit backward but white has
no pieces to attack it with because I
mean the only piece additional piece so
it could attack it is a knight and the
only Square really you can use is maybe
D4 but it's very well controlled you can
spend five things to bring the Knight
over to A5 by that point Blake will
discover some counter play probably so
it's very attractive uh and your plan is
as you were indicating like the the only
immediately obvious winning plan for
white involves playing a 44 and F5 right
and then you start thinking about
organizing it and you realize you play
F4 black probably instant replace H5 H4
right to shut down G4 and if at that
moment you are already not winning with
a 405 somehow
let's just put it on the board yeah so
if a 5 as it isn't here because of
Knight G5 if a 5 is not really playable
this is basically implicated for the
rest of the game black can even go 97
Knight to five and reposition his Knight
to an even better Square thanks to the
pawn being on H4 you're never playing G4
so you actually you're gonna have to
play incredibly slowly it's going to
take G2 G3 F2 F3 you know a lot of a lot
of Tempe to make sure that you you you
can establish absolutely and uh
and if we continue talking in the same
fashion like Queen disabled has been
played now right right with the queen on
this diagonal you play G3 you get hit by
Knight G5 even even if we disregard the
fact that there's a queen only four
which is hanging even let's say we
played Queen E3 here black passes right
we need three I don't know King H7
whatever doesn't matter G3 we get hit by
Knight G5
if this provokes h3h4 which is we should
often will because the pawn is very very
hanging we just go back to E6 and all of
your Pawn breaks on the king side have
basically been liquidated like you need
the ball on H3 to to have any hope of
opening opening files on the king side
truly
obviously you know white has a healthy
extra Pawn white will continue pushing
for a while if the Queens come off the
board maybe your prospects become a bit
a bit better because then maybe your
ideas of playing G3 are more uh
realistic counter play might not be as
quick and so on right but I think I
don't know what your feeling is but I
think it's like a 7-3 in favor of a draw
maybe even higher maybe even higher I
don't lose this very often exactly and
I'm even thinking
tell me I'm not 100 sure I'll even have
an edge after Queen D5 that's wonderful
yeah that's actually a very good point
even that which I don't think needs to
be played right because if you're wrong
you will be very wrong and happy yeah
and yeah shock continues shuffling very
happily has gone king of Faith here
without much thinking that's one
technical ending another one that I
wanted to bring you to is this game
between
uh Fabi by the way I'm I'm really
stunned that Fabi was able managed to
achieve this I just don't understand why
in this position Hans did not play the
move King F2 yeah we're discussing this
book on the break yeah yeah both
Alejandro and myself and yes are all of
us yeah we were we were all kind of
don't you just play King F2 here and
just chill but maybe I think he was
probably worried by something like Queen
ituru B8 it's very counterintuitive for
me to allow the screen trade but I guess
Hans uh figured that uh with the bishop
on D5 which is an incredibly important
resource here he's not losing the C4
Pawn
and uh well if you play it or is he not
if you if you know he's keeping keeping
the pawn okay and the issue is
Fabi of course let's say move 38 right
okay
Fabi had the option of playing Bishop E6
here right and taking on D5
right which generally I think is
obviously something that you badly want
in this types of positions breaking
apart the bishop bear exactly but then
the structure let's say we go I don't
know Rook A8 okay and even if y does it
in the most stupid way possible and just
goes like five for K5 E4 right
and then wants to play like H4 put the
bishop on F4 uh King on F3 and and say
no way yeah it just feels like you're
not making much progress there because
you are constantly tied to the
protection of the D6 Pawn white only
really has one here I might have a
problem with Rook unfortunately I do
have a timing yeah okay yeah so not like
this yeah we do it slightly smarter
right but yeah but I'm sure you king of
three first could have done it nice you
were just making the point that even if
you force F5 E4 H4 Bishop E3 you might
just force your opponent into a fortress
yeah which is why Fabi chose to keep the
Bishops on the board okay but the
position they have right now like if we
just scroll all the way this is to where
they are this is where we are yeah seven
is actually kind of a clever little move
saying that you know you would like to
have access to the B file I'm not going
to give you any access
that is actually kind of funny isn't it
I feel like not really risking very much
the the power of the two Bishops on the
open board may be uh maybe we
underestimate it or overestimated the
advantage for Fabi have we Alejandro oh
no but you've got uh lavon's game uh
you've been digging deeply into that
position because it might end it might
end just now I live on uh did he resign
no he play King H1 okay play King each
one so not yet but this game is pretty
much done let's see what happened in the
last couple of moves since we left the
game we left it off with this mating
thread on G2 and we said all right you
play check and then we figure it out or
you can play G3 right away we didn't
expect G4 and I think this is based on
some sort of miscalculation because he's
gotten takes on G4 check
okay King F7 Rook G3 Rook G3 not so sure
about what this is about because after
check King H2 check I think he played
King H1 play King H1 you know yeah I
mean you why can't I take on F3 first of
all
I think this also wins yes and then I
just run right yeah but I think that
there's probably cleaner ways of doing
the same thing because white still has
zero threats like the the biggest issue
for me here is that I don't really
understand why uh you know why this does
anything this we can just continue
ignoring it and yeah the queen is
already on E2 the point here being that
after after Queen takes F3 there is
still no threats on your analysis
yeah G3 also wins yeah G3 is also made
yeah if you go back we need one right
yeah Queenie one king H2 and you just
give another check and then G3 still
made yeah Yep this should end pretty
soon yeah looks like this this game is
yeah let's leave it barely fairly over
yeah look at the cameras then as I think
this is finally going to be the end of
this one I think you left played Rook G2
and now you can play G3 first you can
play Queen takes F3 first it doesn't
really matter all that much you're just
winning
wow this is huge guys I mean we're going
to have what a showdown tomorrow uh this
is setting up for us as uh we'll have
two players tied for the lead but in the
grand Chester scheme of things this was
an incredible really important young
might be actually now in contention for
uh for for third in the in the gcg
standings oh absolutely in particular if
he wins tomorrow and he has the white
pieces against uh I keep on forgetting
uh he's playing against Hans yeah
[Laughter]
yeah queen of one there chosen Bayan I
guess Queen F1 yeah with the with the
queen H1 check ideas and then Queen
takes F3 was also very very winning but
anything is winning I don't think it
really matters all that much but the
pond Grabbers Club well made into his
kind of good well Queen takes F3 I see a
meat in one it's kind of good sure but
they've been H7 yes
enough and there's the resignation Shake
wow
um well we expected two victories we got
different victories in the ones we
expected by the way but yeah they made
it interesting yeah at least we got the
Victor correct in this yeah in the other
one
we were saying it's a horrible position
but we we got to you know yeah go call
the ambulance but not for me kind of
situation yeah exactly oh my goodness uh
what a setup this is our Championship
weekend just got very very interesting
uh and uh the cards got reshuffled and
oh yeah take your bets oh yeah wow uh I
guess we'll we'll get to talk to to Jan
about this I'm pretty sure he knows he's
lost control at some point I don't know
if he realized during the game just do
which extent bad yeah just to which
extent he lost control but I'm pretty
sure he realizes that uh it wasn't uh
you know could have been less nervy yeah
it could have been uh could have been a
lot uh man do I want to represent
Leonard as his attorney in a lawsuit
against the hair stylist that color on
his hair
it was painful I mean that was
fluorescent that is very very harsh
is a Guiding Light in more ways than why
you know because he's probably visible
from visible from outer space
with that hairstyle I agree uh okay wow
uh Alejandro uh kind of reeling with
these two result adults that are in
their history books
2022 just keeps yeah that was actually a
very interesting very interesting shot
there we just witnessed because uh Yan
was sitting there a level already left
and Yan was
just sort of sitting there
mouthing something which looked like
displeasure let's describe it as
displeasure at something and he's just
beaten somebody very strong with the
black pieces I wonder what that was
about okay we'll get to ask him very
yeah maybe maybe we can ask yeah since
it was found yeah doubtlessly uh he will
join us and this Winner's interview but
I wanted to say Alejandro that we have
witness something a very special in this
penultimate round as the as the
leadership for the sinkfield cup is just
absolutely 19 year old that should be
making all the headlines right in this
Tournament alareza ferrugia of course is
just unbelievable so young coming in
winning the St Louis rapid on Blitz four
rounds to spare hello currently first
place in the singfield cup currently
pole position of the grand Chester first
time he plays wow wow just amazing
storyline we have here wow and uh
you can still I think I don't think he
will get very upset if we if we make the
argument that he's still not the
finished product there is there are
still things to polish for sure and you
know if this is the unpolished
unfinished product in his final form
yeah it's a bit scary yeah yeah it's a
little bit scary the Hope Diamond will
be something very very special
um boy I Lavon also coming into this
game uh help me out here guys but I
thought Lavon was playing some really
excellent chess uh coming into this game
I just didn't see this no this was just
an opening disaster and and then we we
saw
what makes him so strong in the way he
continued finding defensive resources he
continued fighting but he had to burn
through so much time in the opening just
not to resign basically I think uh the
fact that he was down to like 10 minutes
by move 25 was very much due to the fact
that he like he woke up by move 13
realized this is not the file
whatever this is this is not the file he
was trying to well this was this is what
he what he dealt himself two pawns down
move 25 he just played the move A5 black
has simply everything and then crazy
enough
completely unclear and somewhere around
here he was actually better for for that
moment like right about uh no I think it
was actually
GF would just take only four twice yeah
this part one a plus one advantage and
it's it's also such a one thing to do
like
it seems logical to win this Pawn
because it also uh further breaks open
the uh the black king side and so on but
for levonne I think when he plays like
this when once he was allowed to play G4
he was in the in this mood that like
maybe I am now creating something
something quite exciting and he just
continued refusing to win material back
right and it eventually I think led to
his downfall because the survival of the
Pawn on the five made Jan's defense
later in the game much much easier and
much much more manageable if you look at
further positions in this game black
eventually did give up the pawn on H6
but if you have to choose which one to
win I'm pretty sure every every one of
us chooses a five over H6 in the card
absolutely because then this this plan
of just running to the center will be
pretty much always unplayable and
yeah very strange game but uh you know
I'm pretty sure Levon will not be very
happy G4 was also a kind of a mystery
but it doesn't really from our
understanding it doesn't change the
result it changes the length of the game
maybe it makes it makes the suffering
shorter yes it does it definitely does
that as we get prepared for uh nepo to
join us let's just once again take a
look at Bobby's position yeah Fabi uh
because the uh the queen side is
unavailable for the rookies trying to
open up the king side he's played H5 he
hunts I think absolutely correctly it
takes gh5 because allowing allowing H
takes G and Rook h8 would have been I
think much much worse so you go GH you
go Bishop 3 and you you say to uh to
Black you have to spend so much time
winning the spawn on H5 I will be able
to play I don't know C4 C5 if I want or
something because black needs to play
Bishop A4 and then black needs to play
with B8 this is pretty much the only
realistic way of even winning that pawn
yeah and in the meantime we get to play
AC 45 we get to trade off more pawns it
feels like it should be
it should be a position that you should
hold with white
yeah I just if you keep sacrificing puns
I might find myself very interested in
continuing but no I I think what you're
saying is absolutely right that I do get
in the move C5 and you probably uh takes
I mean now I might be interested what
I'm just saying I yeah you might
suddenly find yourself in but even
something like this just Bishop C5 check
here let's say King G7 I play E4 Bishop
takes H5 Bishop G2 and then I play 45 or
at least try to play 45. and with every
with every Pawn pair disappearing of the
board the drawing uh the drawing margins
become wider and wider and agreed just
feels like this should not now be too
much of a problem exactly and finally
Lanier
once again we are getting ourselves set
up for an interview with nepo uh Lanier
um
it's going to be very very hard he's got
he's got to prepare a number of moves G3
F3
G4 F4 uh yeah it's a long very very
difficult task for him here not
impossible but very very difficult
um as the interview is almost queued up
so I'm very bear with us and uh Nepal
has arrived let's jump to Alejandro with
our new tournament co-leader Jan
congratulations on your win you seemed
unhappy that you had a few games where
you didn't play a lot of Chess a couple
theoretical draws seems that you got
your workout in today yeah after five
consecutive first days yeah okay not
completely rest days but sort of yeah
like not
ah not toughest you know days uh in the
office yeah it was I mean the pleasant
surprise that Cliff decided to go to
Queen City five line which is very very
complex and I think there is not some
not so much Theory uh
despite some like correspondence games
and uh yeah probably he wasn't quite
quite aware of what was going on but
yeah he played this move Knight bd2
early in the opening did it surprise you
Knight c3's principle or in other ways
something like netbe Detroit maybe than
before uh and maybe the AJ Queen B3 is
not so is not so bad itself but
as far as I remember it should be
combined with the nitron C3 somehow
right because then again you're doing
Bishop F4 or something let me just put
it and this is like I mean okay very
complex but uh
I mean just just would be um I don't
know a big fight but I think the way uh
the way he played was a little bit
clumsy and pieces wasn't really well
coordinated and uh yeah in fact I could
play five probably even my one with
earlier because yeah you can do an A5
immediately yes yeah after nine to one
maybe maybe five minutes much more sense
than you know than H6 but effort or k H6
maybe not sporting anything yeah no not
at all yeah so it's still like very
complex and somehow after a five black
Souls you know the problem of developing
there uh the Queen's side without like
touching your queen yes so for example
like Queen C8 would be fine but then
okay Knight H4 F3 and white gets a lot
of Tempe so that's important like to
to be tricky and uh there is always like
some move like B6 it exists but then uh
probably the idea of 95 becomes very
easy for white because the pawn is not
it's no more I mean Pawn is not hanging
it's not boundary you know it's not
existing anymore yeah right on C5 yeah
so you get to this position it seems
like a very clear advantage over here
and he decides to shed a couple of Pawns
well I I actually don't know what like
what was his like intentions but I think
the position is practically
uh I wouldn't like maybe like lost just
like a little you know a little bit of
strong term but uh I mean it's it's very
tough to play here with white because I
mean okay I have one Outpost only four
another outpost on B4 and it's you know
it's more or less a question which you
know which Pawn are you going to to give
give away some probably 95 doesn't work
due to the United j65 yes instead of 9g3
uh sorry yeah position
95.95 I mean okay besides the the fact
that D1 is hanging also like something
like Knight xc5 always like always when
something looks like crushing here I was
like more or less sure I'm like
I mean I have a completely dominant
position again here well I maybe I could
play something like Bishop a 3G uh yeah
okay GF freeze like strategically lost
or something yeah so if Queen E3 I could
start with Queen D4 and also but here I
felt like okay maybe bishop C3 Queen C5
Knight E5 uh Rook f8 for example and
then G4 and well at the end of the day
his pieces are not so bad he has okay he
has all pieces into the play so maybe
okay this is just completely uncalled
for to to take such risk as black
because I mean after what I did it
should be like
uh you know uh routinely winning
position but at that moment as they say
like brain exists stopped working yeah I
mean so I ended up like calculating okay
which is nice if Knight C5 and I more or
less you know expected some resignation
here right uh but as well any Bucharest
uh and then I also expected a
resignation uh yeah suddenly he started
like playing I don't know if he played
well but uh yeah clearly uh
here I could you know spend you know a
minute or two
a minute or two more like calculating
but since brain wasn't working at all I
just ended up like playing dd5d4 and of
course I miscalculated because after
Bishop before
my intention was to play Knight C3 this
one right here yeah Bishop C3 takes
takes on D7
uh so probably I take okay my plan was
to take with a rook so he quantify The
Rook D1 check yes so that's why Bishop
A2 King H7 green takes C5 and queen
juicy uh yeah yeah Rook D1 King H2 and
here Queen G5 doesn't work because of
Bishop F7
and queen G6 doesn't work uh because of
uh G4 Queen G4 and Rook E3
and once I managed I mean once I found
out that uh there is some some surprise
like rookie free is waiting me okay
maybe I wouldn't be surprised if
hurricane computers are just something
but it looks like I have to like to to
go for a draw a queen H4 F4 and you're
down a piece oh okay that's uh you know
that's not a big deal you know if I
deliver a mate then I you know I can
live without a PCF or foreign but
probably I don't deliver anything and
here uh okay probably started
calculating some lines again but uh
which wasn't you know My Brightest
achievement why did you start getting
worried about your position
say after we missed the G4 so g4all I
mean okay instead of okay let's say
instead of first of all instead of 96
you can play 96 if you just want to give
away a pawn like one point you give away
and you just I mean it should be
completely winning because the cash we
just have to connect and pass it past
the Pawns
but I decided to play well tonight yeah
so uh battery not available
oh Jake's Jake's okay Jake's everything
group D7 takes rookie eight
maybe this was the way yeah but here I
wasn't I wasn't sure about this position
because I'm still well tonight yeah and
uh well if I don't deliver a bit maybe
I'm just I don't know maybe I'm lost
already so like after after rookie one
okay there's a queen C1 there is rookie
six uh coming so I mean okay I had
completely no idea what's going on right
uh so yeah here I started like uh you
know trying to get to get some stuff
together which was not simple after you
know you just
uh uh after you were absent for I don't
know five moves and here if it's all
right maybe G6 is practical now so no
not so bad because I mean even if my
king remains uh about some
uh we want some I don't know gnf pawns I
mean still I can put my Rook on G7 or
something so let's say queen C1 is the
move which shocked me a little bit I
thought okay it's time for him to
exchange and get a pawn back and then
try to play Rook D3 yeah but uh I
believe we both like played uh quite you
know
you know up and down game yeah which is
badly he got to this position we're
surprised by Rook D3 yeah he's
absolutely surprised I mean I was
shocked so yeah probably I had no reason
I said no reason for him not to take
that pawn I don't think he's like Master
rewards here I'm not sure he's worse at
all I was like more worried if I mean
maybe he's better already but uh okay uh
that's somehow I hoped that you know
that's not just bad and here I thought
okay wow I should be winning already
again but uh yeah the idea he came up
with is quite interesting so here
maybe I have something something
different yeah but in this position we
have to Bishop D2 uh just to no just one
second just to you know for you to
understand the level of uh my you know
concentration is that I seriously
consider it the move 97 for quite some
time 97 yeah but uh I turned it down not
because of Queen takes C5 which I
spotted like the last moment or because
of like it will be one yeah and it's
it's hard to protect B7 Pawn Yeah so
that was like uh that was the player and
you know yeah I like uh at some point I
thought okay if there is like a player
in this tournament who is capable of
throwing such position uh he's basically
right now at the board yeah
with black pieces yeah yes to be clear
it should be even more clear but here I
think I found out some some nice plan
like at least I'm imposing on B7 and uh
in some in some positions I even tried
to run with my king to you know to the
center or maybe my knight so finally we
are playing without the Knight for I
don't know for a dozen of moves and then
finally yeah playing you know in you
know inequal
inequal lineups so okay Queen V1 Queen
D5 probably he had some options like
Rook B3 at some point but yeah rugby
three immediately they just were still
thinking it was about zero that could be
but uh I mean okay I had no idea what's
going on but he was in sort of a Time
Time trouble and I don't think he he
played it like he managed it so what was
the moment that you thought all right I
have brought it all the way back to
winning
I think uh after okay this Rook G6 so
here's more or less forced to do like
his Bishop H6 yes and that's clear
without the king of six I'm just in time
I mean it's basically up to me if I want
okay I just move my king to some you
know to D7 C6 okay then I get made it on
B6 so this was a bad idea
I mean theoretically yeah yes but what
is
it what seemed to me like more uh smart
like to bring my knight to E6 and
probably with such a setup like 96.5
from G6 uh it would be like in the worst
case some couple of checks yeah and
that's exactly what happened in the game
right no I mean okay Queen H4 effort was
the move but Dr quinnish four uh king of
seven I think Queen H5
he's somehow trying to play Ruby here
yeah so there is a pin but maybe I can
go for Queen E5 and I didn't really see
if he makes any progress because once
his Bishop Retreats I always have this
Knight to seven move uh and pinning I
mean okay uh maybe also some Queen trick
will work as well okay then Queen if
I've checked maybe that this is uncalled
for I mean yeah it was uh some sort of
some sort of Madness but yeah
I mean very shameful well you wanted to
add the end and cheerful or not it puts
you on first position here at the
singfield cup title with alareza
ferrugia how do you feel about your
matchup going into the last round
unpredictable predictable anything can
happen
yeah it's been a long tour but certainly
you must be looking forward to trying to
win your first Springfield cup uh this
would never harm but I try to remain
realistic here so if I like keep playing
because today from let's say move 20 to
move 30 and probably I can only win some
I don't know uh where's the game price
yeah so I should yeah I should yeah [ __ ]
his bedroom well you know we don't have
one of those we do have a brilliancy
price we hope that you are fighting for
that one tomorrow
we'll see we'll see guys any questions
no uh just uh congratulations and your
co-leadership Jan and we're looking
forward to uh not your drifting but your
focus uh for tomorrow we we wish you
good luck in the championship round
thank you yes sir absolutely
what a game and Peter you were calling
it brilliantly The Night on Asics you
were trying to bring him back young
sitting in there thinking to himself why
did I go Knight C7 A6 when I could go 96
give him back the pawn gold it's a you
know the emotions you've just watched
they're very very kind of familiar to me
this is you know you were very
empathetic towards as the quote from one
of my all-time favorite TV series goes
you know self-loathing was strong with a
strong in him that day
it's it's a good thing like on days like
this when you still end up winning the
game yeah it makes the pain go away a
little bit exactly exactly
a lot of it yeah I've actually noticed
that between chess players there are
some people that when they win it
doesn't really matter right how the game
went yeah these top level players when
they win and their game was shameful I'm
not calling him it's painful he called
me himself it just it's like it didn't
win at all yeah it just feel it entirely
they feel it you feel it in their face
their attitude it's like they lost and I
think that's the drive that a lot of
these Champions have yeah uh very very
much so with Victor korch doing if he
won a shameful game he was you know
self-loathing it was strong absolutely
but nonetheless a victory is a victory
it does make our Championship weekend
that much more exciting absolutely for
tomorrow and what is going on now so
what games going on yeah and this one of
them just had a turn right that's what I
wanted to ask about the uh Fabi games
yeah okay because we left it off here
after The Rook h8 Bishop F3 defending
this pawn and you guys were harping
about the idea of C5 get some pawns off
the board also makes that King very
uncomfortable Bishop C2 was played
Bishop G4 is logical to defend that pawn
but look at father he's not giving him
that time to play C5 to the point where
after rocket shade I was playing around
with the angels and they thought that uh
it's playing C5 quickly was perhaps
better than holding on to the pawn
forever but this is fine Rook A3 in this
position and finally we'll get the move
C5 in and then this check and then you
have two choices go to E4 or go to C4
and I just don't know too many humans
that go to E4 in this yeah I don't think
it's a move yeah but it's the better
move
it's the better move by a long shot
because apparently after King C4 and 5
is still deep in thought if you allow C
takes D6 you just never make progress
exactly but D5 check but D5 check and
let's continue King B5 and here's the
thing who's protecting this guy
but the only question is should I throw
in the check first it doesn't matter
according to the engine both win okay
but check is good uh you could play King
C6 but after Bishop B4 since your king
is blocking right and D4 is a threat you
still lose the E3 pawn and then you're
just lost you're not you're not quitting
the C Pawn no you're just not going to
do that and
the other way of doing so is without
giving up giving the CH or going check
and going King A6 and then trying to
pass this guy you're in time Rook C3
hits this Pawn if you go C7 King B7 you
would love to get rid of this guy but
it's staying forever and on King B7 you
always have this idea of Bishop E4 and
once the bishop gets there and you see
the D4 is coming
I think it's clear
that one side is going to push a pawn
and the other one
the best that you can do is keep a
threat keep a threat alive try to tie
Black's pieces to it the engines don't
hold this end game they do say it's
winning so a crucial decision here for
5A D5 is a winning move I think he can
see it and that might be a last round
victory for Fabiano caruana which again
he kind of came to the tournament didn't
make a very big impression but because
of his Buy in the last round Fabi
winning this round would really uh plus
one yeah yeah all things considered even
if it doesn't he would be happy at the
final count even if it doesn't net him
you know anything spectacular in terms
of the I don't know the OverWatch or the
overall singfield Cup standings it's a
very very well known phenomenon that uh
basically you your results in the
tournament emotionally are basically
equal to your results in the last round
yeah in many many cases like the way the
way you've played that final game
determines how you remember the
tournament and for him to win today
would be a huge Improvement just like he
will he will feel like this is not a
write-off you know exactly and uh that
would be obviously preferable to the
Alternatives right and uh oof not
another we've got a queen ending in the
linear
found a way to actually get rid of all
of those light pieces which is very
interesting yeah magician how did he do
it by the way your your comment there
about uh the pawn on E5 and why
desperately wanting to play the move E5
E4 that's the whole problem with the
Berlin and the white ever could play E5
before
exactly completely unplayable the pawn
and even one second yeah so somehow the
bishop went from C3 to E3 then it went
to C5 that was very clever actually yeah
the moment I realized in here has this
plan of Bishop D2 Bishop P3 and black
does not have any active counter play he
made it around 40 right probably came
back to it too and then he played Bishop
G2 allowing 94 chair because we will see
in a moment but 24 check doesn't really
do very much and in fact I'll move later
he just returned to E6 and the bishop
was just so much better on E3 than it
was on C3 because there's a lot more
squares and also gives white precisely
the opportunity that linear has used to
liquidate it it still feels like like
I'm not sure this is winning anyway
right because uh in order to make any
progress you probably need to play for
Queen d46 and if you play for Queen d46
checks will you know restart with
vengeance exactly but maybe weirdly
maybe the winning plan is something like
King F1 King G1 and then 2046 because
they're picking away yeah music is
extremely strong we just need to make
sure we don't get immediately
perpetually checked after we do that so
exactly first we secure some kind of a
hideaway for our King right and then we
go in with the plan of placing the queen
on D6 I don't know exactly how to go
about things for that
maybe we played G3 here because I think
we're always very heavily trading h34 C6
or something but yeah this is now a
tricky end game you reminded me because
we teased we teased uh pal benko about
that pal benko would take all of these
Juniors at the uh in New York uh the
Manhattan chess club and show us his
studies and he would say first you
secure the draw and then you play for
the win so first you circular your king
and then you play for the queen trade
it's interesting that this kind of made
its way over to the American School of
Chess as well because I think like for
uh you know the Soviet chess players I
think this was supposed to be a quote
and it's very shameful for me as well
that I will now say it's bondarevsky and
it will turn out to be but it's love's
game right
I think I think it was probably
bondrevsky because I think I I sort of
associated with uh the uh the spotsky
team the and I think when the rescue was
coaching
but this idea that let's say you have an
adjournment
and you start you you have this evening
and morning to analyze the adjourn gain
right and you start by establishing how
you make an immediate draw right and
once you've established that that you
can secure the draws
so this will be a drone he did or did
not he did not he did not play
uh oh my goodness uh missed opportunity
why don't you play default well I mean
he left himself seven minutes and the
pawn does get to C7 so maybe he was
starting he started seeing ghosts of
some sort I don't know so just to be
clear you think this Pawn getting up the
board even though you've got it firmly
uh contained I mean this one looks
completely lost somehow the one with the
kingdom B7 you might become a bit
worried about like for some like let's
say he was calculating only Ruby three
check for some reason okay and then the
king yeah
seven yeah or King B7 27 yeah something
about Bishop before he got three force
is 74 checking B8 King D7
okay and you realize Bishop D1 exists
here for instance right and you start
feeling that you know it's actually
possible to lose control to allow some
kind of Bishop Bishop for check and it
might cost you everything okay uh I I
assume this doesn't work because I know
I'm sure it takes a five it looks like a
good start yeah
yes please give me that one check I
don't care right we're still winning but
I think on seven minutes after a tire
some uh kind of difficult game
I assume because I mean he clearly spent
the entirety he knows the tx5 as a draw
so he always can play this and the game
pretty much ends so he spent more than
half of his in the remaining time
clearly only calculating D5 check
and didn't play it so he he obviously
saw something there yeah he did not like
uh still for me uh Alejandra I want to
say that's a huge Miss and very
uncharacteristic of uh the Fabi that we
know as the human calculator I mean he's
just his calculation skills are off the
chart it's an uncharacteristic for a
Fabi or the fire over the last three
months
exactly I mean it's painful to say it
but
probably just keeps missing things right
I mean
I still I'm still not over the fact that
he didn't finish linear off in that game
right yeah that one that one was very
very odd because yeah he would I mean he
he sees almost everything and then not
quite right and this this game is the
same right he sees something some ghost
and just doesn't finish it off
yeah the game is still sort of ongoing
because some were shockingly familiar I
thought white should like in a matter of
summer as a matter of some urgency why
it should be trying to play three four
it hasn't been played yet another Bishop
can lend on e4 and perhaps even be
maintained on e4 and then the structure
is a bit broken and if what if black at
any point manages to attack the pawn on
the five with two pieces instead of one
it will fall
yeah that's not over yeah yeah this is
this is still very much it it is also
because Hans just didn't find the
correct move I mean if you go back a
couple of moves instead of the move uh
Bishop D4 right just go Bishop F3 and
yeah just just generate content just
generate you're just checking me yeah
give give a check on d54 from there yeah
I mean the bishop on G4 is a big Pawn on
D5 it's a it's a bishop and a bit it's a
powerful bishop and uh where's the king
where's the King on F7 hide
yeah you got to go to E8 where you're
exposed you got to go through da I'm
just going to keep tracking you yeah
yeah and if if we provoking JP we'll
have a [ __ ] perfect as a source of
counter play yeah you by the way I mean
the more I'm looking at this I think I
think you probably would just play
electricity bishop d55
and Bishop F5 and make a draw but thank
you very much yeah let's go with it uh
this move Bishop D4 spoils a lot and now
like you guys were saying
E4 now we have a game guys and uh the
game felt flares the new it flares
completely on you yeah uh Hans is in in
total control in terms of time remaining
he's on 35 minutes against six okay it
will be difficult for Fabi to convert
because of that but this is still like
this is now definitely a position you
you can lose and will lose at least some
of the time with the white yep
the one good thing that uh Hans dusk
have going for him this king is Tethered
to the pawn on F6 you never want to move
your king to such a square that uh White
could sneak in ages do we just
immediately sort of like if I play okay
for a check here I have a feeling
confidence to play Bishop before but
then after the bishop before okay one I
think the F5 Pawn is actually gone like
as far as I guess as far as I can figure
out maybe King D5 still saves it my
point is King D4 yep I Rook F1 okay E4
Rooker four weirdly I have actually won
the E4 Pawn here right because white
doesn't really have a good way to to do
anything about it
as far as I can tell King C3 Bishop
takes C4 and The Rook on the four has
few squares yeah a lot of squares are
you sure
just a second I think you're right
before yeah and let me go away for
somewhere yeah it was I'm not sure how
easy this is winning but like obviously
yeah we pick up a healthy Pawn as well
exactly exactly exactly so there are
easy ways for Hans to lose it uh still
yeah you can you can definitely lose
this position with white now which I I
don't think would have been true at all
if you move to yeah activated your your
one somewhat passive based on G4
wow
we do have yeah before first which is
also a very sensible choice because you
you can't shake it away King D4 runs
into Rook A4 check and the bishop stays
uh secure yeah very secure I mean still
the question to me is how we're making
progress there but for the time being
this is uh
let's assume we are uh quick question
for you Peter Bishop oh Bishop ether too
I'm blundering the E3 part no you're not
okay I'm not oh excellent why
because that guy can't take like King D4
actually wins much ah rugby three okay
I'm sorry
I was about to say good good morning St
Louis but uh yeah I think we're both
getting to that uh
you know I'm blaming it on nepo I think
nepo you know we went into cruise
control and you know we drifted we
drifted as a but Bishop E4 interesting
uh stuff going on uh I I dare not ask
Alejandro about the queen upon ending
because we've had Queen and pawn endings
earlier in this tournament that were
just painful to try to commentate upon
Alejandro do your best what's happening
in the queen ending very nice trap
available to uh Shakira right now if you
play King H2 here yes I think I can play
Queen C4
um I think I can play Queen C4 I think
this is what he's intending I mean
there's still Queenie one I mean you
haven't actually thrown everything away
right obviously if we if black gets to
remove the queen from E4 to E1 it's an
achievement through that and I'm
assuming yeah I think that three might
be I mean the three is not a move you
want to make but you might have to it's
not the first on my wish list F3 is the
top move F3 yeah it's because everything
else is worse I'm just I'm just saying
that did we want to play it at this
exact moment in terms of structure
changes for future Perpetual
possibilities I think f2f3 is a very
very counterproductive move I think what
we wanted is to get King H2 G3 King G2
and then we're taking on C6 so happily
yeah so once again what we wanted was
let's just say King H2 what did you say
I mean here we can even maybe already
start taking I understand but that's not
what you want I want the kids this is
the setup that you want it uh and then
with our green with our Queen on the
long diagonal basically there's never
any checks right so very good whenever
we can take on C6 we can take on C6
because we're not worried about anything
and no preparations and uh if we are
obliged to play F2 F3 uh perpetuals will
be available much much sort of wider for
uh for uh here I'm pretty sure exactly
so you wanted the setup but due to G2 G3
King on G2 and uh just give me a
numerical uh number on this one Ali two
two
especially winning yeah and the issue is
not winning as played in the game okay
King H2 and Quincy 4 is yeah I think he
might have seen Queen C4 and I think he
was tempted well I don't know if he was
but Queen C4 Queen F3 still keeps the
game going the point is that if you take
and you should take you still have E6
that's important now only F5 draws to
the world everything else gets mated and
he might have seen something like Queen
D1 not Queen D3 because you got a check
and like Queen D1 because it holds the
first Rank and then King seven king of
six yeah and King seven check and
shockingly King F6 is the draw was after
E7 King F7 the only way to support this
promotion allows Queen F4 Queen C1 or
you allow my queen to go behind the pawn
so for example the move Queen D7 which
by force promotes next move
doesn't win the game because of this
Perpetual right on time King H2 is equal
and mahmet has to find this move but if
you find Queen C4 with the following
King E7 King F6 I think that's the hard
part he draws the game
yeah and uh if if in order to continue
the game you have to play Queen e41 as
we were saying uh black probably plays
something like Queen C4 D4 and then
white basically King yeah King H2 Queen
C4 yeah if the queen has to remove
itself from the center yeah Queenie one
we play Queen D4 here with black or H5
H4 first and then Queen G4 exactly I
just know I don't want to allow Queen G2
my point there was like after 21 I would
very much like to stop Queen D2 from
happening so let's play Let's Play Queen
D4 here
and then y just is completely pinned to
the protection of the the B4 and the E5
pawns to such an extent that I might
even want to play King E7 King E6 and
start collecting exactly under under
favorable circumstances exactly you just
it doesn't really feel like you're
better even though
as if your queen is definitely the queen
is um the worst uh somehow
uncharacteristically linear played this
move he I think if I understood that
correctly he still has 18 minutes
probably he's here maybe he is
calculating all of this I mean I I must
say once you you picture this position
in your your head you kind of go wow
I've got this the I don't see the
Perpetual checks for my opponent I see
that I'm going to get my queen to D6 or
to to d8 I mean I could just stay here
like instead
just kind of shocking Queen to D2 it's a
similar idea but I thought like if you
sequence before why would you not play
maybe just didn't consider Quincy
Queen to D2
well he's still eyeballing now so I
guess the point here is white might need
to play King G3 and that not and then
not play King H2 and this is the
difference because Quincy 4 does not
allow white back to the same position uh
but here we can play queen king G3 Queen
C3 check and then play F2 F3 which has
Alejandro informed us is probably
probably winning right but uh yeah is
operating under the assumption that
linear does not believe that to be
winning right so he is reasonably okay
with playing quindito here how did can I
transpose back into that previous line
that we were well yeah it's the same
draw right it's exactly the same drug as
we I mean but you have to find this
incredible move King E7 which is
wow stepping into uh these checks
uh
no it's uh but I think it's a visual
yeah it's a familiar idea though because
like you you know that for for you to
survive these types of positions your
King has to get off the back crank so it
doesn't get mated but it has to stay in
touch with the pawn because otherwise
the pawn just Queens on its own uh so
it's it's not unreasonable to uh to
expect a strong player to find it all
right and as we prepare uh to take a
short break we want to once again tell
you that that Championship weekend uh
wow we're we're looking for fireworks
for tomorrow but we're going to see you
on the other side of this break as our
penultimate round in the single cup
winds down it's been exciting day here
in St Louis and uh thank you for the
chess fans for coming out and support
foreign
[Music]
Louis the Ascension Charity Classic
presented by Emerson is back this
September don't miss the excitement when
the PGA Tour Champions best compete
again all for charity September 9th
through the 11th at Norwood Hills
Country Club Pro-Am spots Hospitality
packages VIP tickets and more available
now at Ascension charityclassic.com
[Music]
a St Louis Public Radio journalist's
most precious possession isn't a notepad
camera
microphone or recording device their
most precious possession is credibility
a journalist's work revolves around the
truth
finding it
verifying it and Reporting it
great journalists work hard to find the
facts and put those facts into context
examining all the arguments and
including differing opinions
amplifying fascinating voices from our
community telling captivating stories
offering facts that may have been
omitted
we work every day to earn your trust for
news turn to St Louis Public Radio
when you visit St Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals or the blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error
instead Boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the national Blues Museum
Broadway Oyster Bar or even the
legendary Blueberry Hill so whether you
love the Cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us and you guys
know I can't play this right St Lou is
always exploring
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to uh arguably the the
final segment of today's show I don't
know why I said argue it will be the
final segment of today's show we still
have two games running but in the end
game between uh Hans Newman and Fabiano
caruana the last couple of moves shook
us up yeah produced a significant
significant change and it looks like
Fabi is back on top and I think he found
the right solution so Fabi looks like he
might now be winning again wow as we
were coming in the studio here we were
looking at this position uh chess
engines were calling only a slide event
which a seven tenths of a pawn in favor
of Fabi then Hans produced H6 was still
fine but then this position and then he
touched his bishop and he moved his
Bishop to C7 and then Hans had this
horrible realization and he was about to
blunder and rethought and then
eventually he did Play Bishop C7 Peter
and why is this I think rookie fourcheck
is also very strong but the more of the
Fabi blade looks like it's just sort of
winning on the spot Rook D5 check and
the issue with the rookie five check is
that if you play King C3
simply Rook C5 check group takes C7 is a
very very comfortable Victory the pawn
leashics is weak also the King on B3 is
like seven files away from where it
needs to be which is F4 yeah somewhere
there yeah so so this is just completely
lost or at least it looks that way and
if you play King E4 after D5 check which
is the other the only other alternative
legal move after Rook D2 you suddenly
realize that you've run out of squares
for your stuff
uh because Bishop D5 check is coming
and there really aren't any good squares
for this bishop only two you can play
King of three okay after which I suspect
even Bishop G1 might be winning but even
stronger is the Play Bishop D5 check
first default Bishop takes E4 right you
have King E3 but you've lost a kind of
an important E3 Pawn right now here yeah
this no longer really feels like it
shouldn't be holdable wow
wow so Rook so it was right here so you
think H6 is fine but now now you just
need three weeks E3 makes things easier
that's just it's just over yeah I don't
know why he played King C3 uh but yeah
in the position we had before we go
because there's really nothing to
discuss there just play three four here
this move needs like you you need to uh
kind of break your Bishops apart a
little bit give yourself squares for for
the king maybe and also I think I think
we genuinely want to play 45. one thing
I want to ask you let's say King H7 and
the reason I'm saying this let's say
King H7 I go E5 here right
and if the best you have is this I
publish before check I play Bishop G5 I
don't think I ever lose this position
boy we actually uh came into a table
base and this was just draw yeah so it's
it's really kind of
strange that
uh uh plans did not play the movie E3 I
I think he was just expecting King H7
and he was going to retreat his Bishop
back to the G5 square and
here I think it it finally he noticed
this move and yeah but King C3 steel is
a very very inexplicable decision to me
because yeah all of this has been
blitzed out proxy7 Bishop D3 and now the
choice is you can play a 5h5 GH
GH Bishop takes a five and I don't know
H4 or whatever like doesn't really
matter and again because it's this King
it's just so boxed yeah it's just a way
I think it's very obviously and like
very visibly losing for why there's no
way you're ever fast enough here with
white exactly or you can even go Bishop
D3 G5 frankly and and just start start
running like that Bishop to D3 53
already played a five also already
played five b Fabi made his uh
determination yeah he goes H5
I mean even G5 probably wins by y just
take on H5 yeah H5 GH Bishop takes H5
you can play you know I was about to say
G5 even looks even more convincing than
F5 but G5 looks like yeah uh why not so
yeah so we've already progressed to h5j
I think the cleanness probably is Rook
C5 yeah because E4 I will just take on a
five and queen my Pawn I'm pretty sure
I'm way way well what's the plan here
babe what's the plan here yeah sir push
and Bay push it baby it's all that's all
there is left to it right I know you
just get the pawn to H forms we're just
lost completely awesome so you play Rook
C5 and uh it's just so completely and
utterly lost absolutely
being really really cut off if Fabby
would win it that would be our second
Victory with black the crazy part is we
were almost predicting three black uh
sort of easily going three uh three and
uh three and zero and uh push them baby
it is or still not wrong Euphoria and
now once again Rook C5 just wins on the
spot exactly because Rook takes a five
is a threat which you cannot afford and
if the bishop goes Bishop G4 we can go
King H7 King takes H6 or rookie five
Rook takes E4 I mean there's yeah plenty
of very very Bountiful choices here
exactly all we're trying to do is get
rid of that Bishops and then with this
Pawn uh goes home yeah it's just gone so
what's uh we can we can stay with this
because it feels like Khan's probably
waits for X5 and resigns and then we can
switch to the queen ending which uh is
still very much ongoing there it is Rook
C5
you know
well let's face it I mean Hans made a
huge Splash with the his first three
rounds of play
but uh since this whole thing
controversy the last few days it's been
impossible for him yeah I mean clearly
clearly uh yeah so there it is you won't
wish this on your worst yeah yeah
playing under this this Cloud over you
yeah you know whatever whatever sort of
the outside circumstances are and uh
some some statements published you know
this will continue being deportedly
debated exactly for for a time yet but
S4 as for him playing uh playing in this
tournament obviously uh it's the one
that he held on he held on for for so
long before it started coming coming
unglued chess is a cruel game uh
Alejandro uh this uh
did
this is tough it's a six hour game five
hour six hour game and to lose it at the
very end sometimes you just crack Under
Pressure right like you've played been
playing forever your mind goes loopy
it's not so easy to explain to people
that I've never played a tournament
especially around robin tournament
especially a grand chess tour and you're
nearing the end of it right a tour of
tournaments and you get to the fifth six
hour of some games sometimes you're just
not looking at moves much less the best
moves right it's uh you had a feel for
Hans about this one it seems like he had
to draw in the bag in more than one way
but that doesn't matter for chess for
chess is actually making the result and
he didn't finish this game off yeah and
we have our first uh sort of completed
tournament Fabi will not be playing
tomorrow so he ends the tournament on
four and a half out of eight plus one we
will know tomorrow what this equates to
in terms of the listings and so on but
yeah his his tournament is done he will
be obviously relieved to have won this
game exactly uh it's a nice comeback
just at the very very end but not a
stellar tournament like his by his
standard certainly not and I turned to
our attention to the remaining game as
Lanier is trying to nurse this extra
Pawn to Victory does he have a
does he have a chance of doing that well
the the engines indicate that this is
obviously much much better like huge
winning chances for white but it it
keeps stable at around plus two whatever
you do which I think it's kind of an
indication that there's an indication
that at the very least it's not easy
because white has achieved a kind of a
very nice stable situation there is no
counter play currently
but this queen is ideal Peter I mean it
makes it very difficult for you to make
perfect active contemplate like yeah
black has
a kind of a holding pattern here yeah
it's a fortress that he's trying to keep
that's all yeah and wife has plans white
can try you know somehow activating like
getting the queen and queen sorry the
king out of the
uh the restricted area on the king side
there and then perhaps take one C6 and
run right like one winning plan would be
to somehow make sure the queen takes E6
doesn't allow an immediate perpetual and
then you start running shedding however
many pawns you have to shed it doesn't
really matter you just need to get to I
don't know D6 E7 V6 right if you lose
like three Pawns in the process it
doesn't really matter very much because
your C Pawn is supposed to be your
second Queen eventually so but it's
difficult to organize
um and or a second plan here would be to
play like Queen F6 and try to push 45 E6
and perhaps some of those ball endings
might be winning uh but both of them
feel like they might not be
uh practically uh
let me interrupt you here for a moment
Facebook uh to say that uh
Bobby is in town
with Alejandro uh take it away Alejandro
you have completed the tournament you've
completed the grand chess tour how do
you feel your results have been
throughout the tour itself
it's been a mixed bag but yeah it's a
good way to end it I don't know if this
gives me some slim chance of getting
like third place in the overall Tour
rankings if the results go my way maybe
I'm not exactly sure but um
but yeah today was a good day it was
quite an interesting round I mean it was
one of the bloodiest rounds in uh in the
top tournament I've ever seen you know
um and okay Hans was also uh gone in for
a fight today
well tell us about your
fights where did it go wrong for him it
felt that you got an advantage pretty
early on well you know the thing is he's
he's an interesting player because he he
plays like extremely uh responsible
makes extremely responsible decisions
um very quickly and I I had a feeling
based purely on intuition
like his decision to play G4 yeah was
a surprise I mean he played it I don't
know within like two minutes I was very
surprised I basically like stepped away
from the board thinking
okay it's a complicated position and now
it's he's going to take a long time and
the G4 gets splits down and I was like
um I I was a bit scared by this move but
on the other hand it also felt
extremely risky to me
um
and also I was wondering by the way uh
after like C5 he he played very quickly
but like Knight DB5 was interesting I
need to be very disposition are you
planning what C takes B
Knight D6
no PC is bad I think Bishop takes E3
because BC is just an IDE CD Knight B6
oh yes and Rook da and I end up down a
pawn for for very little right so Bishop
E3 uh and so BC
okay it's some sort of mess I thought
that it would be
sufficient for black does the line
continue
I guess he puts the queen on D3 and I
move my queen probably to C7 or well see
yeah I don't know maybe but C7 looked
natural
ah
I don't know what this is like 98 rookie
I mean F4 is falling
I couldn't uh fully calculate this but
um felt like it should be good for black
he goes bc5 very quickly Queen C5 G4 and
then you took a long time here on your
move Bishop A5 but you've started to
feel that this was too much for for
white well I wasn't sure I didn't think
I was better still or I wasn't sure if I
was better but Bishop A5 felt very
natural
uh the thing is like first I want I was
just wondering G4 H6 and I think I
understood his point which is now if he
plays Bishop F3
Queen C4 he has suddenly G5 and if my
knight moves Bishop D5 everything falls
apart that's what I was thinking at
least uh so
then I thought okay let's let's not keep
the tension let's try to resolve the
issues a little bit also I was getting a
little on time
and okay I was thinking maybe Knight B3
was a bailout but wasn't 100 sure take
on C3 Knight C5
take take Rook D2 rookie three I'm up a
pawn but my feeling is somehow White
should be fine because of the pair of
Bishops yeah just somehow I mean also
the my pawns are rather weak so are his
but uh
I would be surprised if black is
actually better here okay
and then Queen D3 I think he he missed
this queen before right and after that
he suddenly like just tactically
everything's hanging did you see any
resource for him in this position well
so I was like there's like five
different ways he can try to defend his
Bishop only one works and I was just
tell me which one it is
that's one of the moves I didn't
consider the second option you know I
was thinking in Bishop A1 Bishop C1
Queen B3 Queen B1 yeah none of those
words I know that none of them work
we're okay one I I didn't see it all and
I guess he equalizes like that yeah yes
uh take take Queen E4
you know yeah I mean
I I guess I still it's not like like
entirely without risk here also
but it should be equal right so he plays
Rook B1 you actually took a long time
deciding whether you want to take the
exchange or take the pawn I assume with
Knight C5
yeah yeah 95 I mean there was even like
Rook A2 but I didn't really like it
um
yeah Knight C5 but then I know I spent
most of my time calculating id2 I was
just trying to understand this position
okay because he does get a pawn and
didn't seem entirely clear-cut to me
right so Bishop C3 let's go down the
line this check is important and of
course to prevent King G3 we went over
this on the broadcast King G1 here yeah
I wasn't sure about Queen A4 also like
okay uh I mean queen C5 is also natural
Rook B7
and like
you know like Bishop C6
has a point like Rook C7 Bishop B4 but
but he can take and then Queen D4 I mean
after Bishop C6 all right okay Bishop C6
take Queen D4 and Knight E5 I wasn't
sure what this is take queen queen B7
take I mean okay I was a bit worried
about this one it's a mess yeah I was
kind of scared uh so this I I was proud
of this Knight at Queen H Queen A4
Knight H4 idea yeah but I was surprised
that
he okay Bishop B2 is maybe a good move
but I I was thinking like
the critical move after Knight H4
is um
what's the critical move
uh Queen Bishop B1 Bishop B1 is
extremely critical I thought we're just
kidding A8 this is the point that if
Rook takes D7 Rook G2 King H1 rookie
Rook d2i I win the queen
but after Queen A8 he has this move
Queen to B3 I think yes Bishop C8 Rook
B8
Rook G2 King H1 Queen E4 and this
position was uh because he has moves
here like he has Queen D3
and yeah
and uh I wasn't I think I saw something
here but
I can't remember what it is there is
like some
crazy position almost 903 almost works
are three
um yeah which is the only move not to
lose but but sufficient but wait after
Queen D3 what did I see there was some
some move here ah wait don't I have Rook
another Rook F2 I don't have
no why not because she won I get made it
on the back rank after Queen E4 take um
would you like me to be Alejandro for a
bit
um
I swear I saw a move here but now I I
can't Peter is uh wondering if you want
the answer
um
not really
the pride the pride of the chess player
uh I actually don't say it I want to
calculate too I know I want to cook
that is not really working at the moment
um
all right Peter gone uh instead of
Bishop C8 Bishop C6 is winning Bishop C8
actually is not great you should not be
doing this bishop C6 here yeah Bishop
six does win though
ah you cannot take us another three
checks and Rook B8 doesn't exist I think
stopping Ruby 8 is incredibly important
yeah
yeah I'll just um I'll just assume that
I would have found this yes good
assumption and you get to eventually
play this end game out Knight F3 check
the game Transformers a little bit
Bishop E2 was actually a very good move
Knight takes Bishop takes Rooks C8
you're a little bit down on time here
you see the second stick down how sure
are you that you're going to convert
this oh I was like 70 sure it's a draw
okay
um
I I thought that maybe like my my queen
D4 decision wasn't the best but on the
other hand I I was low on time and
if he gets Queen F2 and I get pushed
back and then his piece is coming like
he's not down that much material right
so I thought I would take the the safe
Edge rather than go for some total mess
but I I thought that this is a very
drawish ending uh there are a couple of
critical moments that I want to ask you
about specifically here 54 why King D4 I
mean after like we were repeating why
did he decide to do something else
I mean I would have played another move
after Bishop D4 besides Bishop A2 but
but I didn't see the move
um I didn't see how to improve my
position after Bishop D4
so I was very happy with King Depot four
because then at least like I can play H5
and he has to think about how to like he
he has so many approaches to after H5 I
mean there should be a draw but he has a
tough choice because everything looks
playable uh we got this position here
after check on D3 King C4 you spent
still a lot of time in this in this
decision between taking on C5 and I
assume playing D5 yeah I chickened out I
was like D5 should be critical but his C
Pawn starts to run
like King B5 and okay I thought I had
two choices Rook B3 or let's say take I
mean Rook V3 is also C6
um yeah if Rook C3 the problem is Bishop
C5 King d8 and his Bishop goes to f8
when I saw this I started to get kind of
scared because of this colorful okay and
then I realized that he has more than
one past Pawn so I guess check uh check
where after C6 probably Rook B3 check is
is crucial King A6
yeah uh King B7
I assume
um Bishop Ford c7d
C7 and like King D7 or D4 first step I
think 87 first no maybe it doesn't make
a difference yeah check let's say can be
a king to seven yeah
yeah I I don't I saw something like
Bishop D1 and got scared in this
position but Bishop A4 right but maybe
it was like Bishop C2 here I don't know
but this was very hard to visualize uh
such a
I mean
I thought the other one is like a safe
try and this one five minutes left I I
really didn't think I would be able to
keep control uh and he was blitzing I
like I knew that he wasn't
like calculating things he was just
trying to like semi-bluff me right but
uh but it kind of worked I guess this
was the critical way to play but I just
couldn't bring myself to do it now you
mentioned that he was blitzing he was
trying to Bluff you when did you feel
that he finally let his guard down and
you were able to take this one home well
at some point I got this F5 Pawn like
after I was surprised when he played
Bishop B4
although I thought he already gone to
very oh wait oh so the first thing is
after king of seven Bishop D4 I thought
he rushed with this it wasn't there
Bishop F3 here yeah that's immediately
yeah I just uh I was ready for the draw
and and then he played Bishop before I
was like so thankful for this gift
because now he he's in a very unpleasant
situation his King is in a in a very
awkward place he can't get it to the
king's side where it needs to be and um
and then I thought Bishop B4 was also
like after that I I do win his his F
Pawn right um
but not the game necessarily yeah maybe
you would still draw but suddenly white
has to to find some very difficult
um path to dry thought I think we've got
all the way here and I think the
decisive mistake was finally with Bishop
C7 so so this is still dry E4 apparently
it still keeps I thought the king H7
Fall by G5 I would like have
I think we analyzed this in the
broadcast
uh King H7 and we decided that
we went to the blue five I don't know if
it works but we wanted to please by the
way in E5 I thought so Rook A4 King E3
uh do you put the bishop on G5 you just
put the bishop on G5 really that's a
draw that's a draw yes oh okay yeah I
like saw this line take and take on H4
and Bishop G7 and and then uh I thought
I would win that
um
or
no I mean thank you yeah I was like
looking at this position but I didn't
consider Bishop G5 but I really was down
to like my last minute for these moves
so right that's very true
um you play Rook C5 and it feel it felt
that the game just yeah this king is so
cut off that's the problem for him and
it didn't feel like I really like I had
a wealth of choice to win I thought like
F5 is probably the easiest but Gmod
should also be winning absolutely yeah
let me just check real quick on how this
game is going it feels like we have
plenty to analyze there uh E6 is
actually kind of a crucial moment linear
with one minute wait how is this not
dead for black
it might be I don't know I just saw it
uh he's collecting all the pawns though
Queen G6 Queen H6 or yeah Queen F6 uh
after King f8
where do you go G8 I guess and
in G7 or something yeah
okay so you can collect H5 if you want
with check right
I don't know about you with check but
you kind of collect it no I mean like
with this check oh yeah yeah
I suppose yeah and then just take but
then but you can also
no you should do this yeah so where does
it can go to G8 I guess G8 or f8 yeah
we're already all the way down to Queen
takes E6 we're taking G7 but it's not
force of course yeah King fate is
probably the same the same the same
thing yeah
so I think that you're a huge favorite
to win this one we might have a four
decisive game around again what is that
winning after you collect H5 because
black puts a queen on
I guess it's winning now I mean Three
Palms
it's a passport here on the B5 you play
Queen F4 and then you push well White's
Queen is a little bit awkwardly placed
somehow I'm getting ghosts of this uh
end game of Lanier against Levon in the
American Cup I also had to design a game
against linear like this a very similar
one to this where he had like one pass
pawn and I had three pass pawns with
queens and it was it was winning but
what we eventually Drew and this was in
the year
like 2010 or something something like
that some time ago yeah
Bobby
this one is over what's next for you
uh the well there's some online stuff
like there's this Global Championship
that uh
has now sort of on everyone's radar and
uh the next uh well then there's also
chess 960
um
Championship after this which will which
we'll play yeah and um
and then there's a US championship and
that's pretty much all on my calendar
for for this year oh it's a busy year uh
overall but nice to have a couple of
months break at the end yeah
I mean who knows like I might end up
playing some
event that I don't know about yet you
came up with a podcast recently with our
friend Christian carilla tell us a
little bit about that initiative yeah
that was uh he came to me with idea I
thought it would be interesting and fun
it's uh it's an enormous amount of work
um
and
yeah we're still starting out we're
still trying to learn the ropes but it's
been fun I'll let you plug it in you can
say the name of the podcast it's called
the c squared podcast and um and you can
find it on yeah we have it on YouTube
Spotify
um Apple music and
other places too I'm not exactly sure a
great plug there well thank you Bobby
for joining us in this interview
congratulations on finishing the
tournament and the grand chess Tour on a
high note thank you yes uh let's uh let
us do the same uh Fabi it's always nice
as Peter was mentioning uh to finish
such a tournament with a victory and uh
very deserving I mean
it winning a game of chess is really
really tough this was an example of how
difficult it was but not least in these
lineups in particular yeah winning a
single game of chess is uh more of a
problem than people than people think I
think yeah exactly yeah
yeah that that kind of uh his overview
it was very interesting to uh to to hear
him just discuss things in that game
because it it was a very kind of an
unusual game because it went through
through all these phases a kind of a
balance perhaps slightly better for
white opening and then right you know
his approached from there
uh yeah I'm sure he's not entirely
thrilled with with how the tournament
came out and how the GCT in general came
out but yeah it's it's obviously an
improvement yeah in fortunes when you do
win your your last one the queen ending
yes does look much more promising than
it looked earlier and uh
uh I think uh they've already reached
the position yeah uh linear is not
taking on H5 just yet he's giving a
bunch of checks just to get some time on
his clock because he goes down to a
minute and uh okay this allows him let's
assume king take it from here Peter I'm
still not sure I think we probably want
to take specifically if we can force it
with the King on G8 specifically I think
this is the square we don't even give a
check from G5
uh we we take right now okay so I'll let
you guys know that probably the ECS
after King Jade is King G3 and it's
actually a very clever move it's just
sort of like says hey your queen you're
gonna have to get out of the way check
this Pawn Yeah but it's you don't
actually because I'm guessing yeah I'm
guessing again some squares we might be
taking on C6 even or you could even play
Queen G5 and take with the chuck
because now I'm in the Square you're in
the Square oh I like King G3 oh yeah
King G3 is a very very smart uh very
smart choice yeah if he sees it he will
play it yeah the issue is in such a
forcing position you have to realize the
move exists but you're right you
probably do realize the movie and then
the worst part if I do something like
this you might just go after the SCP
yeah you can definitely at least
consider yeah I'm going like winning
8.66 and then running with your key
forward yeah King f8 played and now
right now King G3 also and it's it's
very similar and uh I think we have
Queen F6 yeah it's played queen of six
he's still gaining time he can he can
always get back to those squares he will
play King of six King G8 is only uh is
the only move that you can even play
right he's still he's still very far
away uh actually he ah this is a problem
for him competition
hang on so he's he's given the check
from E5 to the King on G7 twice already
so if he does it again but the problem
for Shakira and this is where like it
feels extremely weird because I've been
a chess professional for quite a long
time basically Shakira can claim without
making a move right because he played
King G8 once and King f8 once okay so
Shaq can't actually claim after he's
made a move right but he can claim I've
already seen this position three times
and any okay uh linear did take on H5 I
think
he was running kind of low and I I loved
that moment where the queen was on E5
and you just played this very nice quiet
move King G3 you keep everything and you
stop Queenie one check nevertheless
Queen takes H5 yeah but this is this is
a bit trickier because now I think we
most definitely we play Queen F4 check
why not and off the king H3 we just
start going and we just played B5 before
we need to be closer to our eyes and uh
we rods go uh we run and with the King
on H3 basically right this moment why it
cannot offer Queen trades because even
if you trade like bringing your king
closer to uh to the B Pawn you look even
trading on the air file is impossible
because the pawn queen is the answer
it's just way way too far away meaning
that white will have to at some point uh
switch at least some some part of his
resources to uh to protecting against
that pawn being pushed
okay let's do it yeah Grenade shade king
of seven and then oh he's playing G3
this is very very interesting to me like
why I guess he wants sorry from the
start he played G3 immediately he played
G3 yeah I guess his idea is after coming
to 27 he will play G3 G4
because otherwise actually it's a
Perpetual I wonder why he felt this is
stronger than the other version
I guess because the queen D7 is not as
active as it would have been on the four
I think I can get behind this okay
we're still not threatening to trade
Queens but we are threatening to give a
check from each other perhaps just start
pushing our own stuff right which uh
that that kind of begs the question too
like uh maybe maybe that's kind of just
just a spot here just a shot I mean and
go for it right you can't play Queen D3
but I think I can maybe even spend a
Tempo on King G3 in that position
because there are still no checks and I
want to play H6 next that is very very
uh comfy indeed
um looks waiting to our eyes uh
Alejandro but uh
sometimes these chess engines find
incredible resources G2 G3
yeah it's very close to a draw on King
H3 which actually zero zero King H3 with
zero zero and G3 was his best chance
then yes
okay but why on Earth is not at a time
yeah
what what did we look at Peter Queen D2
check right is still fine but I think
Windows 7 check might be a horrible
mistake just by placing the queen it was
fair uh and I'm saying this because I've
stared it does like Queen E3 better
Queen E3 better so yeah we don't need
checks checks you know who needs them
who needs checks
is not a threat I've got there's also
now I think potentially a threat of
queen of two queen F1 Queen C4 so we've
established Queen F1 Queen C4 in Queen
C4 okay so let me check out I think we
go to E7 okay
and then we start pushing and the queen
only three I guess the argument is very
simply that the queen only three uh
provides such a measure of control
that and it also supports before B3 B2
that white is not really faster
yeah Queen endings Queen endings the
fourth phase what can I say uh there are
tournaments where we never see one right
yeah on there and suddenly every round
you know and they are terrible
so they're terrible I feel like I
shouldn't really give the same the same
exact impassion speech I gave the
previous time but there's a kind of a
recap trying to try not to play them
avoid them at all right if you if you if
you value your life and you sign a team
stay away from the more there's this
there's this side like chess metrics or
something right that like values the
accuracy of your moves yeah and I feel
like if you get into too many Queen end
games
[Laughter]
right
you'll break your head um
yeah Queen E3 by the way that is really
uh
yeah that is so upset yeah that is
upsetting actually uh Queen E3 yeah just
kind of stays also also not really a
move you can make very easily shakas so
I think he has three minutes right okay
let me take a different approach after
Queen E3 Queen h8 check Peter yeah where
we have seven left seven let's put our
Queen on some a f8 I don't think I'll go
forward right
and uh
where do I go to okay I go ahead give me
a series of checks let me drive me on
the board yeah I think you may have
already allowed an immediate draw right
because we need to okay queen of one
okay we need to I hope I was running uh
for them Hills I think I completely
seven check is my point I know you have
king of five here in this year and a
year in in this yeah okay the point is
still won't be five yeah apologies it's
gonna completely lost the question yeah
okay
um
I was actually about to go King G6 and
somehow use my three pawns B1 is a check
to the King on G6 that one I was
actually kind of okay with because I
thought that might work out for me but
you simply are not like yeah
okay so uh F4 let me go back a form of
75 uh let's just play B5 before here B5
B4 mm-hmm
[Music]
right P5 B4 no checks
for me
dang no checks for me yeah okay
up we go
okay but now I was hoping that after
B3 H6 I've got ideas of check and
picking up your your Pawn on the past if
you did play Queen D2 you played Queen
just looking H3 Queen E3 was just such
an awkward and the fun thing is in this
position once again after King H3 the
best move in the position is Queen E3
once more yeah but he's already not
played it once I think after King H3
it's extremely unreasonable to expect
him to play agreed agreed and judging by
our like my screen currently seems to
indicate that Queen E3 probably doesn't
lose Queen D3 maybe doesn't lose and
everything else does lose these two
moves yeah and uh I mean how do you how
do you make them it's yeah
like how how are you supposed to figure
that out I I really don't know
uh once again for those of you who are
joining us late first of all shame on
you second of all we are nursing three
decisive games in our penultimate round
uh Bobby has won nepo has won but the
real story of the day is that Ali Reza
the 19 year old phenom
upset our tournament leader Wesley so
and uh and not only that the topsy-turvy
game yeah not only did he win this very
very important game but he also won it
from a position which was at some point
just mathematically completely lost
exactly
um and uh yeah very very unlike Wesley
to uh to to fail to be in a good
position before played by shark and now
now we can actually sort of explain in
human terms how to win the solution for
white you put the queen on the good
Central Square like Queen of five check
Queen E5 check if the King goes to to
the file which it probably does and then
you start pushing your H Pawn and with
the queen as centralized as this and the
problem before now some was vulnerable
to checks excuse me you're you're going
to struggle to to push it much further
because B3 Queen C7 check I might just
be winning it with checks
because yeah if you go to the sixth I
pick up the pawn on C6 was check and we
continue giving good checks and if you
go to the background Queen B8 Queen
takes B3 wins
um and yet gave up linear's first check
was from my chair not from a five I
don't think it spoils very much I would
have preferred the queen on a kind of a
more active more controlling square but
this shouldn't be horrible either
oops we went P4 yeah before Queen the
shade king F7 currently on the board
be a this is you know we somewhat
unkindly to uh to Fabian MBL we kept the
count for for that Queen ending of
evaluations kind of not dropping a
couple of Pawns but just dropping from
winning to drawn right I think this this
one we shouldn't even try because it's
just so counter-intuitive and uh I have
a feeling we haven't seen the last of
this game really like I'm I'm watching
this unfold
and I really do get the feeling that
it's still extremely easy for linear to
lose control
but just this king's safety is just so
nice and this Pawn really doesn't feel
like it's going anywhere it's not really
running very fast
it really is not
like for example again
um
exactly exactly and the idea is that uh
the end of this day at the end of the
day it's like our King is incredibly
safe yeah
something like this one is very
comfortably if you if you play H5 in
this specific constellation of pieces
you have to worry a little bit about
green G5 maybe in some positions
yeah just try to kind of box in your
pieces a little bit and then push B3
before when your checks are very limited
but I have a feeling I will lose to a
three or four somewhere exactly exactly
the king is so cushy on on H3 that I get
the feeling that eventually The Black
Queen will get pushed away from good
squares right but
yeah I still like the idea of bringing
the the queen further back back into the
game by bringing it pushing it on let's
say uh F5 on E5 Let me refresh Chuck
blade King F6 which I actually kind of
like I think it creates maybe kind of
additional questions to ask if we go
back to the position we were just
discussing H5 King G5 for the King on F6
oh King F6 yes
and now if you go H5 here yes which is
very logical I play Queen G5 and on top
of everything else I am now threatening
Queen F5 check I think with the pawn
already on before I'm pretty sure my one
will run faster than three uh or at
least as fast uh always hard to judge
but uh but if three or four might just
lose for white here right which is a
kind of a stunning development
considering where we are
um so yeah I like king of six modern
King effect it also stops white from
kind of uh correcting the previous
mistake and playing Queen F5 Queen E5
right
white is winning though
well uh most certainly we assume where
I'm actually kind of finding myself
drawn to moves like Queen C7 as well as
Queen B7
just to stop this Pawn from going
anywhere and to remind you about your C6
Pawn yeah Queen B7 you you have to maybe
calculate some things but maybe it's
fine he's played Queen B7 okay now it's
uh suddenly a draw what and Chuck
instantly plays the move that wow this
is so beautiful
Queen takes C6
E6 check oh my 21 zeros yep zeros
because you can't take on C6 and black
is about to start giving a a tremendous
amount of checks I feel like linear's
tournament has been like this like the
entire tournament right yeah yeah
but as I said it really felt like this
is still a queen and queen ending which
is very very easily misplayable right
and you you can't even blame linear all
that much you were also arguing for
Queen B7 of course and I was sitting
next to you watching you argument and
failing to produce a single move-in
reply right and I don't think the roller
coaster is over I mean it's not like
zero zero because you just draw
immediately
by H5 right yeah yeah you know it's it's
still a game yeah but you're you're
clearly far from being in control
anymore
well just a second hold on either you
draw right away or no I just put your
queen on D5 and just keep going
yeah exactly
put your queen on D5 and just keep going
yeah because you can't take on
could be four queen of three is an
immediate Droid because the king cannot
run away that's an H5 on the board and
yeah
it's not it's not the only thing that
holds but
yeah the other thing is very similar but
even more inhuman the other way after H5
apparently to make a draw is to go Queen
F1 okay King H4
Queen C4 H4 is strong okay sorry uh for
reasons yeah no understandable reasons
Queen C4 F4
Queen C4 checkout yeah yeah with the
King on G4 we need to make an immediate
very understandable draw but in this
position apparently we go Queen D5
it was and we're still completely fine
because Queen H1 D1 and this setup
that's actually holds yeah it's like 26.
26 played and yeah after after G4 we we
assume
he might have to play Queen D5 Queen D5
and white also can play King H4 right
now which might actually force you to
find that Queen C4 Queen D5 maneuver
exactly yeah this is still a lot of fun
yeah and I use the term very reservedly
yeah like it's fun for us maybe yeah
definitely not much fun for them maybe
we just sometimes in moments like this
where these guys I'm sure they're
exhausted like the first thing they they
do is go back to their rooms they turn
on their engines they confirm certain
ideas and then they do a face plant yeah
you know like
yeah you're still producing some amazing
moves this this find of Queenie one in
Queen E6 was not obvious at all yeah I
mean I would be proud of myself he has
played King H4 and that line is the only
thing that draws by the way
the only thing that that's the only
thing that draws yeah you have to play
Queen Seafood you have to provoke a four
because you need checks from the G1 and
then you get and then you go cringy
Queen D5 and that actually produces a
perpetual
uh wouldn't you be proud of yourself if
you had this position in a tournament
game and you found those moves Queen C4
and then you found them when you were
exhausted no I mean one myself
nobody finds everything for like in this
positions so easily no no and he's found
Queen C4 he's played Queen C4 linear
will now we assume play uh F4 because
yeah G4 Queen takes C5 I think is easier
to understand why it's a draw because uh
we still have no checks and queen F2 is
coming precisely yeah so I think that
one you sort of instinctively understand
there's a draw but after F4 Queen takes
C5 creates no threats and white will win
after H6 Queen G7 check H7 and so on
yeah I think
oh yeah four plate and and now yeah
everything else loses
except for except for Queen the key move
Queen D5 everything else loses yeah has
46 seconds that was against a minute
yeah minute and a half for 46 seconds
yeah
if he finds it then I think by this
point honestly you can actually get
there by process of elimination right
because you do want to create the
biggest threat you have while also not
blundering the C6 spawn with check I
think it's it's actually a findable move
but on 40 seconds the question is it's a
heroic what's the difference between
Queen D5 and queen E4 right that was my
next question
right one wins the other one sorry for
the one draws and the other one doesn't
yeah 24 Queen D7 apparently and you
don't have checks from D1 later
wow okay that's enough that's a really
nice point that uh yeah
these are you know despite mistakes
despite like five five Pawn swings these
are very good chess players just yeah I
want to kind of state it for the viewers
these are very very good chess players
showing very very good chests regardless
of the amount of quote unquote blunders
yeah yeah these are yeah Gladiators
respect how do you keep a DOT going now
I think I think I know I think it's just
I think it's just over it's a Perpetual
yeah you can't stop finish 121 yeah
wow it just ends from here yeah I think
so yeah
hold on I can cover E1 right so just a
second but you don't need one yeah H1 do
you want
and I go here right where
oh you go you don't go to English
this is where I wanted to say I cover E1
no no we we don't we don't get it this
might be a draw but we never we never
ever we never check yeah like we do a
wiggle greenish one there yeah oh boy oh
yeah and then you're understood by this
point but there's nothing he can do
it's it's it's it's it's gone yeah he's
taken on before and yeah we will he will
see a handshake in a moment
wow what an eventful round guys I mean
it could have been four decisive games
we're gonna see three decisive games but
boy what a setup we have for tomorrow's
Championship round
as well as again the tournament's up for
grabs yeah and uh so those are three but
yeah
entertain any of those Notions
thank you very much yeah thank you very
much for the kind offer of the H5 Pawn
which I am
not really planning to accept
wow what an impressive game yes it was a
very very difficult game they showed a
lot of correct ideas they also made some
mistakes of course but this is the you
know the cursed nature of the queen
ending uh is is very much on display
here
said why what's wrong what's what's
um yeah and we will we will see a
handshake in a moment yeah and there's
the handshake yeah the Arbiters need to
just allow them to shake hands yeah like
please don't make them go through it
again
is just like my goodness uh boy did I
just dodge a a bullet in this one huh
yeah I think I think he knows he was in
trouble for for sure even though at some
point it was a it was a manageable end
game I think he made
um like allowing white to collect all
those bones was not necessary there was
a point there in the game but it's all
in the past I think I don't know what
the producers think about this but in my
opinion we probably should not be also
asking them to commentate on the entire
life exactly exactly uh so yeah we'll
we'll let those guys just uh talk about
the game commonly between between
themselves but I think we do have uh
Anastasia with uh more rounds up of
uh of the the things happening outside
of the chess club all right well in that
case let's uh do it let's go to
Alejandra who is with Anastasia in
studio
let's go straight to Anastasia I think
she's got all the all the school all the
scoop yeah of course I mean the the day
was quite long and I just wanted to show
you a short video which was published
also in our social media in grantchester
and St Louis chess club you can see if
alireza firoud are working away from the
studio right after your interview
Alejandro and his fans were waiting for
him next to the Saint Louis chess club
and the liresa tried to run away from
them so probably we can see the the
video yes so he really tried to run away
but they caught him and they took all
necessary autographs and photos with him
so liresa spent lots of time you know
until he left finally he's the leader of
the tournament one of the leaders so of
course I mean has lots of attention from
local fans of Saint Louis and then uh
probably you remember that they said
there were no statements and then a few
minutes after the beginning of the round
the chief Arbiter came out with the
statement and he pointed out that uh
confirmed that we currently have no
indication that any player has been
playing unfairly in the killed cab this
includes all rounds played to date so
the statement came out you can see the
whole statement on the official website
as well as in our social media and of
course there was a reaction from of
course from the followers from yours and
then what we see it's a big news I mean
fans of Hans Niemann showed up today
they stayed next to the chess club for a
long time you know showing their support
to Hans who was playing at that time
with Fabiano caruana unfortunately the
game lasted too long and they didn't
really stay until the end one of my
versions why it didn't happen maybe you
can choose the next two photo I think
maybe they just right here
oh yeah this is my version they go they
managed to take the photos Alejandro and
that's it I mean that was enough you
know so they left after that
happened after has you know didn't I
mean he lost the game
I mean it was nice day and I'm also nice
games so back to you guys
yeah wow
yeah two notes on this first of all yeah
one of the placards there said cool hair
and I think once you take a picture with
Alejandro like any other hair exactly
and also secondly as an old shower as I
suddenly realized we were one move away
from like a shower a number of heart
attacks right here yeah because when you
have sort of we thought King H3 was a
winning attempt well in fact it's the
only move that saves the game if you
play King H4 here kind of expecting
Queen H5 and check in a handshake King
F5 is made in town
ouch
oh my this is the cold shower this is
like the when you just your three pawns
up this is where like you collapse onto
the board right and then emergency is
cold
I mean I'm glad we didn't see this I
know yeah I wonder if they knew but like
he played kingishly very convincingly
there but like you play King H4
expecting to an H1 check and your
opponent on like 10 seconds realizes
that there's another move in the
position here ghost king of five
and you just quit chess or something so
all right well first of all Anastasia I
really want to give you a great shout
out because you were competing very well
through eight rounds uh so
congratulations to yourself yes I mean
Wesley lost this game and yeah it was of
course very disappointed with the result
but what to do but that's the best one
to win this event exactly exactly well
and uh not bad theater not bad
and we will do our results as we get
ready to close this penultimate round
what a broadcast what a show we have
one round remaining yeah there's only
one run remaining the the person you see
there at the top of your screen has
actually finished the tournament he will
not be scoring any more points because
he's played the eight eight games out of
eight right and everybody else is in
action tomorrow meaning that uh alireza
and Gandhi permission four and a half
out of seven are leading the tournament
half a point ahead of Wesley right and
uh well I wanted to say nobody else is
on plus actually 5B isn't plus but 5B is
sort of already secured on plus one
right will not go either up or down and
then it's all important the pairings for
tomorrow let's do our two leaders play
yeah Wesley is playing against in Europe
is playing against
is playing White against Hans Neiman who
has had a difficult uh very few days and
uh yep black against Jan in the last
round is not going to be a walk in the
park either exactly but a lot of
exciting chess coming up also not just
for tomorrow but after the tournament
we've got more tournaments for you take
a look at the uh St Louis chess club
it's the tournaments all the way down
all the way down here are are the
upcoming events we've got ultimate moves
our trash talking event coming up on the
13th of September followed by Fisher
random yeah very very strong field and
one donkey yeah we're gonna be losing
you to this tournament the commentators
I'm sure I'm sure you will have a good
time explaining exactly exactly why I
blundered uh
yeah so yeah that's uh that's the
follow-up and after that a bit of a
break and starting in early October
there is a uh the US Open and the US win
women's chess championships also here in
St Louis so wonderful
tournaments tournaments are bound here
absolutely well I think that's it it's
time to go uh we want to thank you all
for sharing your day with us we'll see
you all tomorrow see you tomorrow
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited